for
[Music]
well good morning to members of the
committee and members of the public on
this uh snowy day in some parts of the
state evidently uh the southern part
evidently is getting some snow I have
approximately a half inch up here in h
and so you can keep it down there uh
we're very happy we got just a little
bit we got um to begin this meeting I'm
going to read the Chairman's script as
we do at the beginning of all public
meetings which we're doing both on the
hybrid model both it remotely and uh
today's meeting will be totally done
remote wise as chairman of the House
Education committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the education
committee executive session on pending
legislation may be
held please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call and I I'll read
the telephone number here
271-3600 or email
HCS LG
l.st do.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Jennifer four is our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required on the
right to no law that includes dogs
representative
luno go ahead uh recognize the clerk
Barb sha thank you good morning everyone
morning uh this will be an attendance uh
roll
call uh representative
B representative Al I'm here and then
this is representative B I'm here in the
room by myself okay representative Al
uh good morning I am here uh but an
occasional dog or cat May wander
through representative leakas I'm here
and my husband may eventually wander
through representative mopit I'm here in
Lowden all
along representative
Hobson I'm here in my office my husband
is in the house and I'm with my dog
representative
Andress I'm home alone in
sorry
muted unmute yourself sir did and it
there we go there we go okay I'm here
and
alone okay thank you thank you uh
representative Lon I am here and dar in
the house I have my three sons here I'm
getting child care in the house shortly
I have a dog and my husband may or may
not be working from home but you're in
my ear so nobody else will hear
sod I'm not
home um family members are in the
house but and they might walk through
occasionally but otherwise I'm in a room
here by myself thank you representative
Myer uh good morning uh I'm calling in
from Kuka New Hampshire from my home
office and I'm here alone thank you
representative luno good morning uh Dave
luno here in Hopkinton and I'm joined on
this ground Dog Day by Aussie the
representative Shaw is here and um my
husband is in and out
snowblowing representative
Cornell I'm here in Manchester and my
husband and my dog are in the
house oh yes I'm in Manchester also
Tanner hi uh I'm here in beautiful sunap
New Hampshire where the skiing is
fantastic um and I'm here with my rescue
dog
Raven representative
Ellison uh good morning I'm here in
conquer I'm alone in my
home representative Mullen good morning
I am dialing in from my dining room in
Bedford and with uh the unpredictable
cat that shows up
periodically representative
Le good morning I am calling in from
Jaffrey New Hampshire my home in Jaffrey
alone representative
Woodcock good morning I'm calling in
from CER Conway New Hampshire in the
midst of ten Ines of snow blown snow I
have my dog walking through and wife and
only my dog will be
backing I want a dog or a
cat uh representative lad good morning
I'm here uh in hail New Hampshire in my
home
with grandchildren and a wife wandering
through every now and then and i' have a
cocker spaniel that you're welcome to
take Barb
okay all
present thank thank you very much um so
we do have a quorum and we have a bill
scheduled right off at the beginning
here it's HB 497 I hope everybody has
that in front of them at this time uh
I'd like to inv uh invite the Prime
sponsor of that bill representa long to
provide us a better understanding of
that
bill rep long will be here in a minute
thank
you
hopefully
rep you
muted oh there he is okay I'm sorry
about that uh good morning Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee my
name is representative Pat long and I
serve Hillsboro district
10 um this this this proposed
legislation uh came with a conversation
uh that I've had with our former
Manchester's former superintendent Dr
Vargas and current superintendent Dr
gohad and Madame clerk I'll be I'll be
emailing you this testimony um thank you
so this proposed
legislation is for school district's uh
SAU superintendent are given a choice to
have the district contribution and their
personal contribution to the retirement
system at whatever the current rate is
either be contributed to the New
Hampshire State retirement system or to
have this same contribution put into a
private and approved retirement account
or a combination thereof if the
contribution exceeds Federal limits uh
if the superintendent chooses this
option the local school board will
include the rision in the
superintendent's contract furthermore if
the superintendent chooses this option
and they in the district they work for
have made contributions to the state
retirement system up to three years of
past personal and District contrib
contributions to the state retirement
system may be transferred to the private
retirement account uh however uh with
conversations with uh OS we couldn't
determine whether this
um whether this
benefit could be to people that are
already in the system if it would have
to be for somebody that would be new in
the system we haven't been able to
determine that um the the purpose my
understanding is that the number of
superintendent vacancies in the United
States and in New Hampshire is
increasing while the number of
applicants for those
positions is decreasing the likelihood
of continuing to replace retiring and
resigning superintendents with current
District leadership is also decreased
substantially being a superintendent is
no longer a sought-after and covered
position like once it was in my opinion
I've recognized that in the last four
years uh with the more challenges to
superintendence it may have always
happened but I've just recognized it the
last four years um that uh you know for
simple decisions
um uh there's controversy for example
snow days there's major controversies
for for a superintendent uh to fill the
need to to fill the need to
superintendent turnover many districts
utilize search firms to recruit
candidates in National searches the
likelihood of hiring a superintendent
from out of state is quite High allowing
superintendant to have the choice
between the current retirement system we
having the exact same amount of money
contributed to a private or approved
retirement or a combination there
thereof enhances the likelihood of a of
State superintendent candidates
accepting positions in New Hampshire
most of not all a of State
superintendent hires will come with many
year of previous experience and will
have many years already vested in
another state system the likelihood of
getting 10 years for vesting rights in
New Hampshire is unlikely and in my
opinion is a is a big dealbreaker for
candidates I've I've worked uh I've
worked with four of Manchester's past uh
and current um
superintendents uh two of them were from
New Hampshire uh the last two were from
out of state and I've watched um and
I've watched the applicants diminish and
or drop out after the interview process
was
applied for example not one of the last
three superintendents in Manchester
state PA more than five years and the
last superintendent was the uh was the
last applicant remaining uh fortunately
from Manchester School District that
superintendent was uh very
capable I do realize that this proposal
would have an impact on an the Hampshire
retirement system
contribution however I'm not convinced
that that impact would be detrimental to
the allall sustainment of our retirement
Financial
stability I may be mistaken but I
haven't been able to confirm
I'm of the belief that that if I'm faced
with a choice between a superintendent's
contribution to the retirement system or
the superintendent's right to maximize
their invest their investment I I would
choose the
latter so in conclusion I thank you for
your consideration of HS Bill 497 and
ask that you support the
concept in the interest of our students
families District employees and
municipalities I will finally also add
that when I was told by Dr goart that
Manchester's current superintendent that
he was not able to testify I was taken
back for about 15 seconds I would rather
see him dedicating his time to our
district than being present today uh it
qualifies my belief that he was the best
choice for Manchester I thank you and
I'll take any questions uh thank you
very much representative long
representative long has said he's
willing to take questions are there
questions from committee
members
yes representative Miler uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
long for taking my question my
presumption is that if this bill should
pass then the uh the amount of
retirement that a superintendent would
receive would be up to negotiations
between the individual and and the
school board and not necessarily reflect
the amount that he or she would be
receiving uh would they be
if they would be in the retirement
system is that
correct uh my my thank you for the
question representative my understanding
is that um
the it's it's an agreement between the
the applicant and the school districts
and the uh School District or
municipality um but my understanding is
that they would both need to contribute
to whatever retirement system um that
they current at the rate that they're
currently
paying so I I don't believe the city
could cut a deal saying you put in your
amount and we'll put in half of
ours um I you know that's the way I
understand it thank you thank you very
much representative Miler uh further
questions uh representa long I do have
one question and I I I see that
represent go represent LE you had your
hand
up sure thank you Mr chairman uh and
thank you representative long for taking
the question um do you have any data on
the current numbers of superintendents
who um are not vested or have uh not
stayed on in other words do we have any
notion of the size or scope of this uh
uh imputed problem so thank you for the
question the the uh what I do know
serving on the Manchester uh Board of
school
committee um that the average the
average length of superintendent in
state of the Hampshire was three years
that was uh that was probably three or
four years ago that data so no I don't I
know Manchester Nasher a few other
districts have a high salary rate um so
I realize that's quite a bit of a
contribution um but the average I'm not
sure of and how much how much money the
potential has for in reducing the
retirement
system uh I don't have that figure
either thank you thank you very much uh
yes representative who do we have Ford
Ford yes
yes
uh can you hear me now yes I'm still
struggling with this system thank you uh
um representative Turner I'm sorry I
lost you the my picture I don't have
your name in front of Oh Long
representative long
um my question is does this allow people
who have been in our system gone away
and then transfer those credits earned
somewhere else back into this
system I speak as one who's done exactly
that it's very common in University
Systems to be in three or four different
because you moved around in your career
and then at some point you pick the one
that's most advantageous to you trans
transfer all the other funds into that
and that's the one you actually retire
from but I'm just wondering how that
works for school superintendent I'm not
familiar with their system so uh thank
you for the question representative I I
um I would suspect that this would be
attractive for superintendents that are
coming to New Hampshire from OT State um
I think I know the two uh superintendant
that were in Manchester from within the
state uh had no issue with with
contributing to their retirement plan um
it was the two from OT state that
thought it would be more attractive uh
and more of a Le leveraging Point for
the municipality and or the district to
um offer such a uh a contribution as
this well at some point when you have so
many of them collected three or four
maybe uh it becomes almost NE necessary
to transfer all the ones all the funds
into one just whichever one you think or
can do it with and that that becomes the
issue for them and so that that's why I
support you in what you're we're doing
here I think this is U perhaps
overdue uh representative long I'd like
to follow up with a question um in your
writing and designing this
legislation uh most likely would the
superintendent that we're speaking of or
both individuals you spoke of in
Manchester was there any effort on your
part to communicate with the school
administrators Association to discern
where they stand on this I note in the
testimony requests here we have the
school administrators Association not
speaking but they oppose this
bill okay I I did uh through my uh Board
of school committee asked a few of them
to ask the association as to where they
would stand on this
um and I I didn't get that result so no
I wasn't able to uh to connect with them
thank you are are there any further
questions of Representative long yes
representa Mullen thank you Mr chair and
uh good morning representative long um
representative the last part of this
bill has a section that indicates that
if a school superintendent and the
school district they work for enter into
this agreement and they've already
contributed to the New Hampshire
retirement system then they can go back
as far as three years and transfer that
money from the retirement system to the
private retirement account am I am I
correct in that is that was that the
intent of the bill yes yes yes it is the
intent of the bill and you're correct
however has I I mentioned in my
testimony uh the office of legislative
services and I couldn't determine
whether or not somebody who's already in
the system was allowed would be allowed
to do that by tax code or
General Financial practices so that that
is to be
determined uh yes thank
you thank you uh we do have some more uh
another individual would like to
testify um are there any further
questions of represent long yeah we have
one more question by um representative
Woodcock Woodcock yes represent Woodcock
thank you Mr chairman representative
long thank you for taking my question um
if I if if a superintendent participates
if this bill is passed in this program
stays in New Hampshire two or three
years as a private non contributor
leaves and comes back four or five years
later later can he buy back into the
system for the time he did was here or
is this a one option you're out or
you're in uh yeah well actually the bill
doesn't give you a one option uh that's
that's a good question that I haven't uh
thought about um you know I mean for
sure they could make another contract if
if they're going to be a
superintendent um for this bill uh
however the opt in to the retirement
system I I guess they could if there's
no contract to do this than thank you Mr
chairman Mr representative thank you
thank you very much representative
further
questions not seeing any hands flying
here so uh thank you very much
representative long uh we will go to the
next person in the queue uh
representative Hobson Marty Carlon from
the New Hampshire retirement system
thank you thank you Mr chair uh for the
record my name is Marty Carlin and I'm
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system I am in home so if a
dog barks I
apologize um nhrs has no position on
this bill um because we see it as a
policy matter uh as to whether there's a
a you know a need a policy need to
exempt these positions uh going forward
however I did sign up to testify to
provide some background information and
try to answer any questions the
committee may
have um essentially um according to the
Department of Education there are about
100 to 105 superintendents in New
Hampshire uh with an average salary of
$126,000 so that makes them the
typically the highest paid School
District employee in all um all of the
districts um superintendent contri
employers contribute at the employee uh
rate of 14% um for superintendant and
the superintendant pay 7% into the
retirement system is a member
contribution um the way our
contributions are set up and this this
will this will be important as we go
forward is the member contributions are
always associated with the member's
individual account so whatever money the
active contributing member puts into the
system they're going to get that back
you know either through a pension
ultimately or through a refund of
contributions plus interest the employer
contributions however aren't credited to
individual accounts like you'd see like
in a match in a a defined
benefit defined contribution plan rather
employer contributions are put into the
state accumulated annuity fund which
pays the benefits for for all members so
so there is a distinction there it's not
like you know there's an individual
account for a person and that the
employer contributions match up to those
person to those folks
um there was a similar piece of
legislation introduced back in 2018 uh
it was House Bill 1427
um and it was u in in response to an
issue with the prior superintendent in
Manchester before the current person um
my understanding from my notes was that
that individual was given the option to
participate in the retirement system or
not which it is a mandatory membership
position so um you know the bill was
attempted an attempt to address that I'm
not sure what the situation is with the
current superintendent contractually uh
that bill actually was heard by Housey
DNA not educ
and um adna amended the bill to make it
um a limited window to allow Manchester
um to to to fix its situation but not um
keep it going prospectively that that
did pass the house and and died in the
Senate uh when the Senate uh amended the
bill to a completely different provision
regarding our statute um in terms of
this bill a couple of
um uh sections of how we interpret it
because this plays into some of the
questions you had for representative
long um on um page one line 20 um it
refers to um this opt out at the initial
at the time of initial hiring or
appointment so we would read that to be
when someone you know is hired as a
superintendent that would be the period
in which the opin would be allowed not
retroactively um and when someone opts
out of the retirement system as is
allowed for chief Municipal officers I
you know Town managers Town
administrators positions like that um
you know they can't choose to opt in in
that position while they're continuing
that position if they went to another
town and decided to join their
Retirement System in their new job uh
they could you know become a member
there uh but they wouldn't be able to
purchase prior service because there was
an opt out so that you weren't there
wasn't any service to a crew and buy
back um the town manager provision in
our statute has been around since um the
early 70s uh I think I think Municipal
management was a relatively new field
then and it was more of a Transit
position where people would move from
state to state you know for for jobs so
um that that piece uh allowing optional
membership at the time of hiring for
those folks has been around for close to
50 years
now um couple of other provisions on
page one line
29 um it refers to
um uh the school District May by
contract pay to the superintendent a sum
equivalent to the employer contribution
so may is not shall so I think that
would answer the question of uh you know
there's no statutory requirement to pay
the nhrs rate to to a new superintendent
who opted out that would that would be a
negotiable point and then finally um the
the second section
um on page two lines 1 through 7 the
three-year um look back um we we see our
our legal staff seees some potential
Internal Revenue code issues um with
both of those Provisions the refund of a
member's contributions if the person
isn't um you know eligible to retire um
you know may may violate the separation
from service provision and the Internal
Revenue code and then the transfer of
employer contributions from the state
accumul accumulated annuity fund to an
individual reti enement account for a
specific member um you know may be an
issue in terms of the exclusive benefit
rule in the code if if the bill moves
forward we'd uh likely reach out to
outside tax Council uh to to get more of
a clarification on that but our initial
interpretation is that that that's a a
problematic look back uh that that does
not apply to the municipal manager um
exemption in the statute if those folks
are hired there's no look back or retro
with them um so um you know this this
would be a unique benefit specifically
for
superintendence I I other than the raw
numbers from the doe website I don't I
don't have any information on how many
of our superintendents are vested versus
non-vested um we don't track position
titles in the retirement system they're
just you know considered an employee um
so I would I wouldn't be able to to run
anything to to get you that number and I
you know I just just from reading the
paper over the you know the years I know
Manchester has had a lot of
superintendence and um I'm not sure how
that how other communities do because
they they're not as heavily covered as
Manchester um with that I'd be glad to
answer any questions anyone may have uh
thank you very much uh Mr Carlin are
there questions for the New Hampshire
retirement
system yes represent La thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Carlin for
taking the question so would it be
possible for the nhrs to um just look at
the number of superintendents and
determine how many years or or group
them in terms of okay this many have
this many years within the system this
many have this many years within the
system so that even if we don't know
whether vested or not uh we would have a
better idea of what we're looking at
here um I you know probably me well if
we would if this if the doe has a list
of their names you know we would have to
manually look up their records to see
that but um you know and that that's I I
suppose it's possible it may take some
time for staff to to pull that but you
know I believe this bill is prospective
so it wouldn't affect anybody currently
in the system it only be for future
folks and maybe the school
administrators
Association has data like that I know
they didn't sign up to testify I I would
probably reach out to them myself as
well if if I came away from the hearing
um you know with with that request from
you just to see we how we can get us you
fastest thank you followup please yes
rep and Le thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr Carlin for taking this other
question so correct me if I'm I'm wrong
on this but I think you were saying that
uh in one portion of the bill um it's
basically stating that this is um the
decision has to be
made at the time of higher or
appointment correct and if so how then
would that that last set of Provisions
lines one to seven on page two work
because there it has going back three
years um and and it states that um those
are contributions to have been made I
Believe by the district but the district
would not have hired that person would
not have made contributions prior the
prior three years if they're just hiring
at this point that that U that that that
puzzled us a bit as well I mean you know
just sort of trying to play out
different scenarios if a you know an
assistant superintendent or a principal
in the district was hired as
superintendent that that's that's what
we see as a possibility I I we didn't
see it as um you know if you were the
superintendent in Portsmouth and you
went you know to conquered would give
Portsmith money back to the individual
when they moved to conquered but you
know if it was somebody who was in The
District already is is the only way we
would see that is working so your
understanding then is that that that
sort of look back is applicable only to
funds uh contributed by the specific
District that that's how we would see it
yes thank
you thank you very much uh
representative Le and Mr Carin are there
further questions we have a question
from Ralph B representative
bom represent thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking a question I see
one little problem here or maybe not
maybe you can ask so if a
superintendent's contract runs out and
being renewed so in the case of being
renewed is it then a possibility ility
that that superintendent May opt into
this plan or but because he's already an
employee would it not so good
yeah um the way we've always treated the
the provision as it exists currently for
municipal managers is you know initial
hiring or appointment and initial is
they weren't working in that position
and they were hired to do that job not
that they were
renewed
thank you um we're getting close to the
time frame we have for this hearing are
there any more critical questions that
you need to get out or are they
something we could you know follow up
later or would the uh administrators
Association or some other
Association not seeing further hands
thank you very much I appreciate the
retirement system coming forward in a
neutral Manner and explaining some of
the details associated with this issue
thank youi uh representative lad uh we
do have a a question from attend from an
attendee are we going to take questions
from the audience today are we no the
this the hearings are set up for
questions only from committee members
right not from attendees all right thank
you you're welcome so I'm gonna uh
seeing that I don't believe we have
anybody else had signed up to speak on
this issue so I'm going to close the
hearing here for for HB
497 and representative lad yes I
apologize for interrupting um but uh me
individuals in the attendee list may be
raising their hand if if they have
registered since the print out of pink
cards okay see you may want to ask for
that that could be the reason for the
hands yeah the question was initially uh
are they asking questions no but if
they're there to speak they're uh we
will go ahead and and
listen if it's new information okay I'm
sorry so I I didn't recognize the name
so uh Carla Smith um I'm not sure if she
signed up to speak but I can promote her
to panelist and it looks like the hands
have gone down so maybe just I took her
hand down oh I see I see I'm
sorry I thought she was um a person from
the audience I am from the audience
thank you but I'm here for House Bill
oh okay so I'm closing this hearing down
right now um in conclusion we had
supporting this issue three folks signed
up opposing it for one neutral uh person
so so that was uh
497 we're moving now into the next bill
which we have on Deck here starting here
at uh 10 uh 10 uh 9:30 it's HB 349
relative to certification requirements
nurses so that's 497 or excuse me that's
349 and
um do we have representative Hill in the
queue um representative
Hopson I'm sorry yes we do I just
promoted him okay thank you uh represent
Hill is the prime sponsor of this bill
welcome to education
committee uh thank you Mr chairman um to
the committee um good morning I uh I'm
hopeful that I don't get interrupted by
a dog here I've got a
chirping smoke detector and the dog uh
gets set off every time the chirp goes
so um I'll do my best everyone can hear
me all right
yes good morning Mr chairman and uh and
for the record I am representative Greg
Hill um I am serving the District of mar
marac number three covering the towns of
Northfield and one-third of the city of
Franklin um I am introducing to you uh
House Bill 349 which is uh to repeal the
school nurse
certification um program
this is uh a an original bill that came
out in
2016 um very unusual circumstances uh
the original bill was heard in HHS and
had nothing to do with School
nurses um It ultimately went through
house and into the Senate where it again
had no mention of School nurses and then
on the house floor I'm sorry on the
senate floor
um an amendment was added for the first
time it added a school nurse
certification um it was uh therefore
never passed with with no public hearing
whatsoever
um this has been a rush job all along
and uh and no one seems to be able to
tell me why the rush job but as with all
bills that we've seen that have no
public scrutiny
um there were problems with it right
from the start um one of the biggest
problems was school budgets had uh no
time to correct for any increase in
wages um it also had problems with
existing School nurses not being sure
whether uh or how to do any continuing
education or whether they needed any
continuing
education um it was also a problem that
um that there was no Ru making Authority
in the original bill so the doe had no
ability to create certificates of any
kind and you'll see if you go back in
the record that it had to they had to
wait a full year before they got all of
the doe rule making done for this in
order for um people to become
compliant the key thing in this bill um
that I would take a look at is that um
from the very get-go um all of the
existing School nurses were Exempted
from this new
law I would take that to mean that um
that there is
no um emergency um there were no case
for um for need ever having been made um
there was no immediate danger to the
public um or to school children that
would be
indicated um there were no legal issues
that caused this change there were no
lawsuits there were no federal mandates
um nothing shows that our constituents
gain any benefit for what would
undoubtedly be higher costs and probably
U most important ly uh greater shortage
of quality
candidates um during that that hearing I
happened to sit next to a fellow that
was in the hiring business for School
nurses and he mentioned that he hadn't
seen a candidate for three years with
that would have qualified under the
these new
qualifications what happened was they
would be going from a um an associates
degree to a bachelor's degree plus three
years of pediatric nursing
experience all of that seemed honorous
when my district was already telling me
that they were having difficulty finding
School
nurses um and I should tell you that
School nurses are not a mandated item um
by the doe in New Hampshire um it's a
voluntary program so um the immediate
concern would be that uh that school
districts would just cross off School
nurses from their list of needs and and
make it a want but uh but not fill the
position um one of the other things that
we've seen lately is that School nurses
uh I'm sorry School departments have um
have circumvented this law and changed
the name of the people that they are
hiring from school nurse um and they are
calling them Health coordinators in some
cases to get around this uh this state
mandated uh requirement of hiring a
bachelor's degree with three years of
pediat pediatric
experience we also heard in a prior uh
bill that um you know there are people I
think uh anecdotally this was a
pediatrician that had uh 20 or 30 years
as a as a pediatrician that was
determined would not qualify as a school
nurse um she was looking for a
retirement job quote unquote and uh and
she didn't qualify under these
requirements well that's just crazy as
far as I'm
concerned finally um I would like to say
that um I've never met a more competent
group of people than School nurses um or
that nurses in general um I believe uh
anyone that calls themselves a nurse
uh could probably rebuild my car
transmission and and run a hotel and
probably run Wall Street um these are
extremely competent people and um and to
say that someone needs a bachelor's
degree and three years of pediatric
nursing to be a school nurse uh just
flies on the face of of reality I think
um with that I will end my testimony I'm
happy to answer questions but I'm sure
there are people better better capable
of answering the questions behind me
thank you very much representative Hill
are there qu questions for
representative Hill uh representative
bone uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking the
question isn't it true that whether or
not a a nurse has an associate degree or
a bachelor's degree they still have to
take the same Nationwide test to become
a registered nurse
that's my understanding as well
representative thank you for your
question um I'm sure there will be a
representative uh coming to speak to me
speak to you after me um from the
nursing uh profession that would be
better able to answer that question
however thank you thank you further
questions of Representative
Hill not seeing any hands up um oh yes
represent Miler thank you uh Mr chairman
thank you resent Hill for taking my
question as we as we look at bills one
of the questions that I always have of
the sponsor of a bill is what is the
intent of the bill so could you
summarize the intent of this bill for us
please um thank you for your question
representative um it's an it's an
excellent one and and I wish more people
asked that question um the intent for me
is to um alleviate the uh the problem of
our school districts um that have
difficulty had difficulty already uh
filling this position of school nurse um
what we've done with this legislation is
make it harder to um to hire competent
um School nurses and uh made it more
expensive for the taxpayer um and and
finally with all of that um we haven't
made uh the position there there's been
no need shown why we need to do these
things and and I think that's important
in any legislation uh to make sure that
we're we're honoring uh the goal which
was to make the public safer and that
case just hasn't been been made as far
as I can see so thank you very much for
your question and thank you for your
response thank you very much again uh
further
questions I don't see anybody else
represent Hobson do you see somebody
else with a hand up
or okay we're going to go on to the next
speaker then I'd like to invite forward
um from the New Hampshire Nurses
Smith Mr chair oh I'm sorry I promoted
um Miss McKinnon from The Nurses
Association okay well I don't have a
particular order here which who would
you which one would you like uh we can
do either one they're both from this the
the association so uh let's first go
with one have up hold on we um Miss
representative Tanner has a question for
the chair yes I submitted um I that I
would like to speak on this this
[Music]
bill do you have that uh uh Jen I didn't
morning okay apparently it came in
after 820 then it wouldn't be reflected
did represent Tanner seeing that you are
would like to speak I I I I'll put you
up there right now go ahead please okay
thank you Mr chair for the record I'm
representative Linda Tanner representing
Sullivan District 9 the towns of
planfield Cornish Cen Grantham
Springfield sunap Newport and
unity um I was a public high school
teacher for 35 years at karge Regional
High School and worked very intimately
with our school nurse on uh teaching
health education and also as a former
EMT I worked with her on all the
different injuries that occur uh
normally in a school
situation I'm uh very distressed by this
this bill which seems to be coming up I
guess groundhog days a good day for it
to come up um the I'd like to address a
couple of issues that uh representative
Hill brought up one is uh that he sees
no need for uh specialists in this
particular field and that um pediatric
experience is necessary uh through this
law it also has a point for related
experience so it isn't um strictly
pediatric U experience that's needed uh
for many students entering our schools
today uh they're dealing with serious
injuries uh and serious issues plus
covid um and chronic uh complex chronic
medical conditions like diabetes asthma
depression abuse and neglect
homelessness food insecurity sexual
assault substance abuse and violence the
school nurse is the lifeline and the
main reason the many of these students
can continue to attend
school the health of the student and
staff in the entire building or School
District can be significantly affected
by the actions of the school nurse it
seems like under covid this would even
be uh more critical and when a nurse um
receives the uh Registered Nursing
certification after that most of them go
on to different Specialties um and
nursing in a school situation you're by
yourself for the most part um you're
confronting all these different issues
and you're dealing with either young
children or even worse teenagers um so
that they uh have to balance a lot of
plates up in the air they have to
balance uh State education laws uh
concussion protocols the use of
epipens uh the use of Bronco dilators um
oxygen and
nebulizers uh emergency response
procedures and then they have to balance
that with federal laws the Hippa furpa
504 Ida they're actually uh School
nurses are listed under the
SSA um they have to also be aware of
Public Health laws that affect um
schools with monitoring vaccinations and
covid um communicable disease outbreaks
in school uh rep reporting laws for
abuse neglects uh universal precautions
training and screening programs many of
those things would not be something that
an RN would know right out of um school
and so this the school nurse um is
really important and in many of our too
many of our schools don't have a school
nurse in the uh laws there's actually a
way that um a person with three years of
experience related experience can
actually get certified uh through a
program of mentoring and continuing ed
credits so that's not a problem and I
think you'll find out from uh Paula and
Carla who are going to speak that School
nurses are not a shortage uh nurses in
general are a shortage but often uh
School nursing positions are are high on
the list because people who are nurses
like the fact that if they have a family
they're working the school hours and the
school year um I'd also like to address
another issue that was brought up and
that is in this bill is that it also uh
addresses the position of the school
nurse coordinator in the Department of
Education um I worked very hard in 2018
uh along with poly campan who was
representative in health and human
services at the time to reinstate a
position in the department of education
for a school nurse
coordinator um the position was
originally established in
1919 and was funded through various
funds and federal funds but in 2010 when
we had the last austerity uh drive this
was not funded and remained vacant until
at that time the commissioner
commissioner Barry secured funding
through a grant to reestablish the
position and the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Grant samama ended in
September of 2017 and the position
became vacant again um this made New
Hampshire one of nine states only nine
states in the Northeast with no Central
qualified person to give guidance and
direction to School nurses or School
Personnel who are not qualified who who
work in that area who are forced to deal
with these issues responsible for school
health leaving few places to find
answers for questions um all kinds of
questions on these laws and and
different things that are happening to
students in school so um that position
still is vacant uh it has been unfilled
even though there have been applicants
for that position and and um I find that
uh very distressing particularly again
with the epidemic that we had have and
the and the um communicable disease
problem we have in schools today so um I
strongly oppose this bill um I think the
situation um this is a bill that is just
um spirited towards uh reducing cost to
schools uh at the expense of students
and staff so with that I'll take any
questions thank you very much
representative Tanner
questions
yourself got
it I'm curious as to what a teacher a
stu a nurse learns in those two years of
college which are
often
[Music]
um writing and
Humanities and other things for those
additional two years what she learns
it's going to give her that information
of all those things that you listed and
what difference there's going to be five
years down the road
between um a teacher who has the RN you
know the four years and the teacher who
experience well I think um you know this
is kind of uh a question of you know
what does a doctor learn in the four
years that they take after they take a
general uh Bachelor of Arts degree uh
you know nursing is is a a specialty
it's um I I don't know about you but
when I'm in a hospital situation and a
nurse comes in the room I don't want
just uh jeie Smith off the off the
sidewalk that's maybe taken two years at
a community college uh with um basic uh
education and I have something that's
that's very technical um I think that um
you know certification for certain
things indicate a level of expertise and
education and that is acquired in in
those two years between
um an LNA or a nurses assistant and a a
registered nurse and and as I said
before many registered nurses go on to
Specialties uh a nurse that works in a
surgical ward has a or an ICU H has had
experience and training in that
particular aspect of medic medicine and
uh School nursing is no different thank
you very much uh representa Tanner H are
there any other questions we do have uh
some other folks in the queue here to
speak we have uh an individual from New
Hampshire School Nurses Association the
New Hampshire nursing association uh
school boards Association we had
technical support from the Department um
are I see repon Hopson yeah I had a
question um so uh oh yeah I'm unmuted
the um covid has really shown that
nurses are um are needed in New
Hampshire and um I was wondering if
it it seems like we're making it more
difficult to get nurses into positions
and at at UNH or at the other nursing
schools they're required to do an
internship so that gives them experience
in the job um would that not be
helpful I assume that question is for me
and um yes you know just like an
internship in in any particular field
whether it's plumber or Carpenter um or
teacher or nurse uh internships are very
relevant to the experience but uh a
nurse who who has just come out of
nursing school goes is accepted at a
hospital Ashley goes through another
training program and usually that
training program is anywhere from six
months to a year just for a floor nurse
um and that's not a nurse that's in a
specialty I mean when I was when I was
teaching and working with the nurse you
know we we had incidents obviously
broken arms and things like that that's
kind of typical that that happens in a
school cure Sarge it was eight minutes
um for an ambulance to arrive from New
London Hospital we actually had a staff
member have a um fatal heart attack um
but we were able to keep him sustained
until he got to the hospital uh we had
some some terrific injuries uh um that
you know it was um through training and
experience that we were able to handle
them but other than that the school
nurse has as I said um you know issues
of homelessness and food insecurity
they're dealing with a lot of public
health issues they're dealing with laws
from uh not only School law but federal
law and and healthc Care law so it's
it's um much more complex than as I
think some people people think it's
putting Band-Aids on little kids uh boo
boos thank you uh further questions of
represent
taner U before you move on um we have
Drew kleene and I'm not sure he's in the
attendees and I'm not sure if he signed
up to speak um or what what his role
might be uh yes I'm I'm aware of that we
have two other folks that have signed up
previously we're gonna take them first
and as I mentioned the school board will
come in following the two nursing
associations okay I believe we have uh
both speakers ready to speak in the
[Music]
McKinnon thank you representatives for
allowing me to speak before you today I
want to start out by saying um I'm
confused by uh Representatives Hill's
comments that the original certification
Bill had nothing to to do with School
nurses uh quite the opposite it it was a
work in progress since
2014 uh between commissioner Barry and
the New Hampshire uh School Nurses
Association and in 2016 it definitely
was a bill for School nurses it was not
a rush job um there as all other bills
was plenty of time for anyone to
research or testify just as the very
short notice that we got to come here
today to speak with you um it was no
different back in
2016 I I'd like to give you a very brief
synopsis of the history of the bill so
that you all can understand where the
Nurses Association might be coming from
in 1919 to 1947 New Hampshire's first
school nurse was Elizabeth merphy and
she worked for the city of conquer and
became the director of school health
services in the department Department of
Education for 23 years running from 1919
to
1947 in 1947 the New Hampshire Board of
Education voted unanimously that School
nurses who care for children's health in
the public schools are teachers of
Public Health and are eligible eligible
to join the State teachers retirement
system so we joined the retirement
system in 47 somewhere in the 40s or 50s
School nurses were included in the
department of educ ation certification
system and the rules at that time is
that they had to have 30 hours of
continuing education above their diploma
um in years back most of your nurses
were diploma nurses meaning it was a
hospital that trained
them we could not find in the history
and it was very unclear when this
certification was repealed but we do
know that in
1971 a certification was again
legislated for School nurses in 19 75
certification was repealed during the uh
massive teacher strike in New Hampshire
and the nurse could no longer be in the
teachers contract during those
negotiations during the strike in
1989 Barbara Ward who was the president
of our association filed a brief on
behalf of our association documenting
the legal and professional basis for the
role of the school nurse this went to
the Supreme Court and it was ruled at
School nurses could now be a part of the
teachers bargaining
Union so then we fast forward to
2016 the certification law was passed uh
that uh is the first time that you'll
see that this present certification was
passed in
2018 a bill was presented to uh repeal
it uh it was defeated in
2019 a uh it was again a bill to defeat
it was
presented um that was voted
down however the current bill was
amended and it increased the length of
grandfathering that a nurse could um
have more time to get into her
bachelor's degree uh at the same time in
2019 it was legislated that a school
nurse coordinator position uh would be
funded through legislation so where does
that bring us
now well it's it's uh where are we now
School nurses have shown their
contributions again and again as an
extension of Public Health and the most
obvious uh example of that is the work
that we've done uh during the
pandemic where are we now the school
nurse coordinator position has still not
been filled by commissioner edel blut we
do not know why there have been
interviews uh but there's been no action
taken on that and again someone made the
very uh valid point that the school
nurse Coordinator would not just answer
questions and uh for School nurses they
would be advising school districts that
don't have school nurses uh to be able
to help them to develop health programs
within their school so I first I want to
dispel some myths that have come up time
and again because um and these have all
been stated at past hearings when
there's have been attempts to repeal
certification we hear again and again
that Manchester and other school
districts have difficulty hiring BSN
nurses the fact is that Manchester is
not even under this law Manchester hires
Public Health nurses and as such Public
Health nurses are exempt from
certification because they're not paid
by the school district um the same is
true of spear Memorial Hospital and
Huggins hospital as well as any travel
agencies that Supply nurses to school um
this certification law does not apply to
them a second myth is to keep registered
nurses license the nurse must complete
uh or to keep the certification license
it's a burden to um get more hours in
order to keep their
certification here's the truth okay a
every nurse in New Hampshire must
complete 30 hours every two years to
keep their board of nursing license the
45 hours every 3 years that the DOE
certif ification requires is not an
added burden because it is the exact
same hours the hours can be counted
during both so if you break it down by
year the Board of Nursing requires 15
hours per year and certification
requires 15 hours per year they can be
the same hours submitted to both
organizations there are zero additional
hours that a school nurse would have to
put in there is no burden anywhere uh to
the school nurses on
that and the third myth that keeps being
repeated that schools have trouble
filling school nurse jobs because um
because the BSN nurses don't want the
job the fact is that schools have
trouble filling the school nurse jobs
with BSN nurses because they don't pay
them well enough even though we're
allowed to be in the teachers union
we're treated separately many school
districts pay them less
the school districts that don't pay them
less and have had them on teacher
contract at full te teacher pay for
years have seen no difference in in
hiring
nurses um I would also like to give you
a few stats on Who currently is
certified um in the state of New
Hampshire there are 568 School nurses
presently in the uh certification
system there are three levels of school
nursing certification school nurse one
are nurses who are currently enrolled in
an RN BSN degree there are 22 nurses
that fit that category so there are 22
nurses in the state of New Hampshire who
are currently working toward their BSN
school nurse 2 is everyone who was
grandfathered when the law first was
enacted they were grandfathered because
we didn't want to put an extra burden on
these nurses we wanted to look ahead we
want to move forward forward we don't
want to look at our present Workforce
and make things harder for them we're
looking to the Future and making a plan
for the future the school nurse 2
category presently has
366 um and those School nurses
regardless of their degree we still have
some diploma nurses working in the state
of New Hampshire uh we have Associates
nurses but many of those could also be
BSN nurses at the time that
certification was first enacted there
were was no fee to become a school nurse
too so many of our BSN nurses opted to
go with a two the school nurse two so
that they wouldn't have to pay the
higher fee for school nurse 3 now we
come to school nurse 3 there are
presently 180 School nurses that are uh
certified under the school nurse 3 this
means that at the time if they hire they
either already had a BSN or they
completed their BSN after after they had
applied for certification certification
is a three-year cycle we are coming up
on year three and there's many School
nurses that are going to shift out of
school nurse 2 into school nurse 3
simply because they already had their
BSN but they chose to go for the option
of school nurse too because there was no
fee attached to it
um so that's that's coming up
soon do our nurses support it we hear uh
uh complaints that there are nurses out
there that don't support it well we've
got some solid facts for you uh there
were two different recent meetings held
one of them was with 240 New Hampshire
nurses not necessarily School nurses but
New Hampshire nurses the certification
bill was talked about and presented and
89% of the nurses present voted to
support school nurse
certification the second is a poll that
our association took of its school nurse
membership uh we had 178 School nurses
respond
36 did want certification to be uh
repealed which represented 25% and 142
voted to keep uh certification so 75% of
the school nurses voted to keep the
certification why did they vote to keep
it the feedback that we got uh this is
coming directly from one nurse the the
nurses of my sa were able to advocate
for placement on the bachelor's uh pay
scale for those of us who were State
Certified another nurse said state
certification gave us a foundation to
Advocate as a professional practice
through Union negotiations for our new
contract this year another said
certification requirements have helped
the principles understand better how to
hire new School nurses in our district
Paul Paul excuse me for a second um
we're going on uh upwards towards uh 15
minutes uh oh I apologize yeah we have
you have a fellow nurse waiting to speak
and then we have the school board also
so uh can you try to conclude it sure I
I will conclude it by saying that we are
tired of having to uh continually come
before the legislature to defend our
professionalism uh and we hope that here
today we can put an end to that and make
a strong statement that School nurses
are where they belong thank you thank
you very much for testimony other
questions of of Paul McKinnon yes
represented
likeus un
muted got it took a bit um I'm gonna ask
you the same question what is the
difference in training between a
two-year nurse and a four-year nurse
given that both have to pass the same
test that's well I have two questions
but that's my first one yes it it it is
actually very different and I believe
that one of our members has submitted
testim written testimony to that regard
the uh extra schooling for a master's in
education is very different than for a
uh bachelor's and nursing public health
is a big part of it statistics is a big
part of it how to navigate the bigger
picture is very much a part of
it thank you and you have a followup yes
please um
I notice it says a school nurse shall be
a registered nurse currently licensed in
New Hampshire which means um I'm
wondering wouldn't a two-year nurse who
did the 30 hours and all that other
stuff also you know fit that
qualification an Associates nurse has
until a certain point to be able to
apply for certification and then have
six years to complete a bachelor's so a
bachelor's degree from Associates nurse
to to a bachelor's degree spread out
over six years we feel is not an undue
burden in fact it's quite generous
length of time to give them that a
length of time to get it uh no we're not
gon to allow any follow-ups to that
we're going to go on are there further
questions repres Miler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss mckinon for
taking my question you had indicated
that there are
568 uh School nurses in the state and we
have heard under previous testimony that
it's difficult to hire uh teach nurses
under this particular law can you tell
the committee how many vacancies are
currently in schools uh regarding School
nurses vacancies yes we researched that
right before coming on and we could only
find three uh that currently have
vacancy
uh one of them being Manchester who
clearly states in their ad that they do
not have to be certified so of the of
the 568 there are only two vacancies to
your knowledge at this point in time to
our knowledge that's all we could find
yeah thank you very much further
questions yes represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair and uh and uh thanks
uh thanks again um Miss McKinnon for uh
for your time uh in committee this uh
this morning um uh I want to sort of get
at um I I I think something similar to
to some of the other questions with
regards to you know what's the
difference between you know a two-year
and a four-year degree with respect to
um toh to professional nurses and um and
I guess what I what I'd like to like it
if you could talk with us about a little
bit is um is is like the management and
Leadership of a um of a nursing staff in
a let's say a hospital environment
compared to that in a in a school
set I could I defer that question to
Carla Smith who is an educator uh uh and
teaches at that level she yeah I'm I'm
happy with that as long as the chair
will allow me to ask that question again
when um when when Miss myth speaks well
I I think uh she's listening and I I see
her smiling so yeah I I'm sure she'll
answer your question if she doesn't I'll
recognize you again represent luno okay
uh so with that let's go on to
um uh uh nurse Smith uh who's recognized
and you you are from the New Hampshire's
uh nursing association is that correct
yes I'm here representing New Hampshire
Nurses Association today so we are a
Statewide organization that um
represents nurses across all specialties
in turn I also do serve um with the New
Hampshire school Nurses Association with
Paula McKinnon so I can really speak to
those areas of questions that you had
been asking of her um I'd like to start
just to tell you a little about my
background so I have been a nurse for 18
years a registered nurse in the state of
New Hampshire and I actually started my
profession as an associate degree nurse
and the big key takeaway here is you
don't know what you don't know um and
it's very enlightening when you return
to school as an adult and you get your
BSN degree the difference in educational
preparation um from that student growth
perspective is enormous um I have worked
at Portsmouth Regional Hospital in their
cardiac Telemetry unit in their ICU I
spent eight years in their emergency
department before I became a school
nurse when I became a school nurse for
SAU
883 I was on an island all by myself
with an associates degree even though I
had solid nursing knowledge experience
and
background I knew nothing about the
educational world I never even heard of
a 504 plan an
IEP working with team members who didn't
include other nurses it was a very
foreign environment to me that's when I
was inspired to go back to school not
only did I get my bachelor's degree but
I got a master's I spent five years in
my district I loved every moment of it
and I decided to pursue higher education
I am now a professor of nursing at mcphs
University in Manchester and I teach in
a BSN program so I feel I can very well
articulate to you what the differences
are between these education platforms um
prior to taking on that role I did work
um at St Joseph's School of Nursing in
Nashville which is an associates degree
program so I've experienced teaching at
both levels I can tell you I have
graduated fantastic new Nur nures from
both programs but that's at entry level
nursing entry level is what you need to
sit and take the
enlex the BSN nurse is prepared above
and beyond the ASN nurse especially for
those roles where they have to work
independently I actually pulled some
statistics from and I used UNH um unh's
nursing curriculum and I use the
curriculum from the New Hampshire
Community College on HTI to give you a
better understanding and I thought by
using a state level platform it'd be a
little more applicable um than just the
the two schools that I have um taught at
at
UNH you need 133 credits to obtain a
bachelor's degree in nursing 70 of those
credits are nursing specific meaning
they are dedicated n are only given to
nursing courses this is not A&P this is
not lifespan this is not microbiology
because those applied to multiple
degrees nursing specific is 70 credits
in comparison an associates degree at
nhti you need 71 total credits to
graduate with an associates degree only
21 of those are dedicated specific to
nursing so the difference in education
is not liberal arts based it is not
additional writing classes Humanities
classes it is a significant difference
of 49 credits in specific handson
nursing curriculum I I think that in
itself is just a profound difference um
to speak to that some of the differences
in the coursework that you will see is
pediatric specific content and
Pediatrics spans a it's a lifespan it
goes from the newborn up to age
21 in a school district we give early
intervention services to Children
starting at age three up through age 21
so we're really capturing that
population my particular course I taught
over the summer was nine credit units
dedicated to that population including
clinical placement in
labs in the associate degree program
that I taught my students got one day
one single day that they were allowed to
go out into the community to work with a
school nurse or a wick program and they
spent two days on a labor and delivery
unit they had a handful of one-hour
lectures that is a vast difference from
a nine credit load okay um specific to
Pediatrics in turn the other difference
is public health
nursing school nursing is a subsp
specialty of Public Health it is
recognized that at the national level
because we don't just care for the
student that's in front of us but you
care for the entire Community the
community within the school building and
the community beyond the school building
that extends into a home and you arrange
for services and yes we do a lot with
homelessness food insecurity um social
emotional Wellness that is not just for
your school counselors School nurses see
that on a day-to-day
basis we have children that come into
manifestations they're not they come in
with that physical
manifestation for Mental Health Services
mental health curriculum we have three
dedicated credit hours to a mental
health course that includes practicum
experience our students go to Hamstead
hospital and work in the children's
units there they go to the New Hampshire
State
Hospital okay they have actual Hands-On
practicum experience with mental
health they go out into the communities
as part of that public health
curriculum they will spend an entire
semester in a school nurse's
office that's one to two days per week
times 15 weeks versus one day in
isolation so the difference in schooling
and preparation I it it's really a night
and day difference the best comparison I
can give it to you is your difference
between your par Educators and your
licensed
teachers there are wonderful parent
Educators in our school systems that are
dedicated to their students who are
highly
professional but they are not qualified
to design and deliver the curriculum
that is needed for that teacher
certification it doesn't mean they
didn't qualify for an entrylevel
position it means that they needed that
above and beyond to give the best to our
students so I key takeaway I'd really
like to share with you and I feel Paula
has addressed this is supported by
nurses I think she's addressed the
questions that there really is not a
school short uh shortage of School
nurses like she said there's three
identified positions in the state I will
add to that to say there's a multiple
positions adverti for substitute School
nurses okay there's always a shortage of
substitute School nurses because we all
know substitute pay is really not in
be substitutes do not require
certification this does not apply to
them other districts that may have
difficulty finding a nurse are not
hiring at a full-time
equivalent if they're hiring at a
fractional part-time rate it's very hard
as a nurse to work full-time in a
hospital system in part time in a school
system I know I did
that before I went full-time as a school
nurse so the key takeaway here is really
you're giving your students
certification
allows principal superintendent hiring
systems to know that this nurse has
really got that above and beyond
training to give the best to a
supportive learning environment because
that's what School nurses are there for
to bring Wellness into the school that
allows those students to have that seat
time to keep them in the classrooms to
keep them learning to decrease
absenteeism related to illness that can
be easily managed in a building and the
care that is given is so complex and
different um it's kind of interesting as
an as a nursing Professor right now I
see things that I teach my students that
I learned in
practiced completely differently 20
years ago when I first learned about it
Healthcare is is evolved the complexity
of the Care in the students and this is
even in a hospital level right now an
associates degree may get you in the
door but you're also signing a contract
within a hospital system and this is
very common in New Hampshire that you
will obtain a BSN within three to five
years of hire it is an expectation at
this
point Hospital Systems Health Care
Systems View and Associates degreees
this is awesome thank you for going to
school we're going to take you in but
now we need to put you through a
mentoring program and you need to sign
up for continuing education or you're
not going to continue to work
here okay and this is really seen across
the nation but even very specifically
here in New Hampshire I have students
past students and graduates all the time
reaching out and telling me about this
um so thank you I really hope um you
vote to support certification to keep it
in place um I think as representative
Tanner said it's kind of ironic it shows
up on Groundhog Day because I think this
is the third time now I've sat before
you to to say please keep certification
and do not remove it so I'm available
for questions and I thank you all thank
you very much Carla uh we have seven
minutes left in this hearing and still
several folks out there uh are there
some questions for Carla did your
question get answered representa luno um
i' i' I'd actually like to ask it go
ahead and and then we're g to try to
spin to some of the other folks to
testify sure no thank you very much and
thank you very much um Miss Smith for um
um for uh being here this morning um you
you you started to um to address it a
little bit and certainly your your uh
professional experiences both in the
hospital setting as well as the um the
in school setting and uh and I I I was
just gonna ask um how U management and
Leadership uh uh uh over you know of a
nursing staff uh how that compares in a
in AAL hospital setting versus uh what
you find in an in school setting uh uh
particularly as it relates to I think a
lot of the um you know
complexities that you that you talked
about not not just in terms of of uh of
of students but uh but in terms of um of
their the you know the educational
environment absolutely thank you um and
I apologize I did not touch on that so
one of the things BSN nurses are
prepared to do and this is actually a
course that I'm teaching this semester
is um has to do with leadership in
interprofessional education
IP which is really working with members
of other professions not just nurses and
how to collaboratively sit at a table
and look at something from a
multifaceted view to manage and plan
care in any setting um a and we see
teams do that on Hospital floors we see
teams we do that all the time at my
University um these teams can happen in
school systems and it really has to do
with the receptiveness of including the
nurse but it also has to do with the
training of the nurse to be able to step
up and participate as a member in that
team versus just sitting passively in a
room um nurses do approach things with a
very unique and different perspective
and there is curriculum that is
dedicated to that type of training um
that is not taught in an associate
degree level thank you Carla we we
really are running short of time here
going to jump to the school board's
Association not not Association School
State Board of Education and uh Drew
kleene is in the queue waiting to speak
there can you hear us Drew hi I can hear
you um uh Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you this is Drew Klein
I'm chair of the State Board of
Education I had not intended to um
testify today I was catching this
meeting and saw this and I thought I
could add a little bit of perspective
from the state board so uh forgive me if
my thoughts are um a little bit
disorganized I just want to make first
of all a point of clarification if I
could um understand this bill um as I
read the bill it does not remove the
state law requirement that nurses School
nurses have a bachelor's degree
correct it it removes the requirement
that they receive Department of
Education certification but the law
continues to say that they must have a
bachelor's degree so as I read this bill
um am I get do I have that wrong I see
rep tanor shaking her head so um I hope
maybe the sponsor can clarify that
because that would change this a little
bit so if there is if the bill simply
removes the requirement for
certification
um that uh from the state board's
perspective that would be a relief we
really struggled certifying uh nurses
and writing these rules the law driving
the the law um requiring a bachelor's
degree for nurses is what really drove a
lot of this um we created the
three-level uh
certification on the fly so to speak
because it wasn't even clear that we
could do that and the testimony we
received from school districts was if we
didn't do that there would be an
instantaneous and massive shortage of
School nurses on top of the already
existing shortage of School nurses and
believe me we have heard from districts
um consistently that there is in fact a
shortage of School nurses and the school
Nurses Association told WMUR last month
that there was a shortage of School
nurses you can see it on the wmr website
there was a national shortage of School
nurses um so so there is a shortage the
bachelor's degree requirement um makes
this worse much much worse um so what we
had to do was write rules that that
grandfathered in but also that created
the school nurse one so you could have
the registered nurse and get the uh and
come in in the process of getting the
training um so we can have uh registered
nurses who had Associates degrees come
in so um it was a a difficult process
and and the board really felt like uh
this was not our expertise or our strong
point we we did not want to certified
School nurses we didn't want to be
involved in that at all we thought that
they were health professionals and
should be um hired on on the basis of
their skills as health professionals and
I wanted to dispel some of the myths
here we just heard some testimony that
uh that is really driven by the
bachelor's degree requirement um the
certification if you read the the 500s
where we certify School nurses nothing
in the
certification requires School nurses to
learn anything about education there's
nothing in the certification that says
they have to take teaching courses or
learn the school environment or do
anything like that we wrote these rules
to comply with the law for bachelor's
degree requirements um the way we we
wrote the rules as Loose as we could
possibly write them um in in our
view so that schools and districts
wouldn't we wouldn't burden them any
further in making it in even greater
school nurse shortage um
so the certification itself does not
require nurses to know anything about uh
504 plans or IEPs or any of the stuff
that goes on in schools there's nothing
in the certification requirement that
adds to that um it is it is really
driven towards their um education as a
nurse and their experience as a nurse
and so removing the certification
requirements with wouldn't affect that
in any way
um one of the previous speakers talked
about entry level and I think that is
really really really important we
created the three
levels to create an entry level nurse
that's the school nurse one um because
that wasn't in the law had we not gone
down that path um you would have had an
entry-level bachelor's degree
requirement basically and then the
people would be grandfathered who were
already
and that would have created again as I
said a serious and immediate shortage on
top of the existing shortage so what we
see and this is I want to share with you
some of the antidotes we've received
some school districts
um Manchester for example has zero
certified School nurses to my
understanding because they hire their
nurses on the city side of the
department uh of the city not on the
school side because they hire them
through the public Health Department
they are not um they do not fall under
our certification process so the largest
District in the state has no certified
nurses they do not have to get the
certification so if you were to say that
the certification is necessary and adds
all these um benefits I don't know how
you can um can feel comfortable that the
largest District in the state does not
have this certification and goes around
the process other districts could easily
do that um if they arrange their hiring
in that way so there are workarounds and
I'm it's not clear to me how that really
helps the situation um if we have
workarounds and have outs um but we have
this requirement in place we're just
creating a bureaucratic system where we
kind of force districts to go around and
we force schools to go around the system
um we also have received feedback back
from schools that uh this has made it
harder for them to fire to hire nurses
um as an antidote I can tell you we had
one School uh tell us that they had a a
person who was going to be hired as a
school nurse this person is a registered
nurse with I think a couple decades
experience as a registered nurse who
came to the school because he wanted to
get into this uh become a school nurse
these requirements certification
requirements were pretty burdensome so
they just hired the nurse as an admin
administrator at the school and the the
person is on staff as an office
administrator but is the school nurse is
is a nurse in the school and that and
they don't have a school nurse so we are
seeing districts and schools try to come
up with workarounds from the bachelor's
degree requirement in particular and the
certification process so my point is
that this multi-layered certification
process even as um easy as we tried to
make make it for districts is a problem
and is creating um headaches for
districts and is not adding the the
level of um
extra um Quality I think that is assumed
that it adds so I will end there just to
not take up any more time thank you very
much Drew are there questions for Drew
Klein uh yes represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair thank you very much
um chair Klein for uh for joining us
this morning um uh I'm it's it's pretty
clear from from your discussion that uh
that that you don't have a strong
understanding of what this bill does but
um but I wanted to ask you about one of
the comments you made uh particularly
that uh that you don't want the board to
be seen as burdening districts but I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about that in terms of state board
response about
responsibilities to burdening districts
public um I'm afraid I don't understand
your question there there are
tradeoffs um that that any uh government
makes when you write laws and rules so
if you were to require um you
know let put it this
way in pursuing quote unquote quality
you can easily make perfect be the enemy
of the good so as I've tried to point
out we have districts that are working
around these requirements so I don't I'm
afraid I don't quite understand um
how it how it isn't obvious that
imposing burdens on school systems that
are unreasonable in the marketplace
again there is a shortage of nurses in
New Hampshire um there a shortage of
School nurses in New Hampshire and when
you are um well rep Tanner I mean when
the when the school nurse Association
tells the press that there's a shortage
of nurses and we hear it from districts
um that's the information that I get so
um so I'm afraid
I I just don't quite understand how the
state can think that it can simply
impose a requirement that certain
hurdles be hurdled be junked um and when
there is already a shortage in the state
of nurses and not expect that that will
affect the supply of nurses in schools
so um one of the things I think the
is you you're writing rules that would
positions do you want to set the bar so
high that you make it much more
difficult for districts especially
smaller rural districts
um to to hire for that
position and you create an artificial
shortage is that
better than having um a system where you
can have an entrylevel um person come in
with um requirements that are equal
to hospital or equal to a doctor's
office um I I think that's kind of the
question here is do we want to create a
system where a nurse who can work in the
emergency room and care for your child
who comes in with an emergency or care
for your child uh who gets sick um at a
hospital bed is not qualified to be a
nurse in the school system and that's
what the certification has effectively
done and um I think that's an issue
uh that that the legis legislature ought
to um think about
okay I'm not gonna allow any follow-ups
right now I'm sorry we've run over our
time limit into the next bill um uh if
uh folks have a question uh I'm sure uh
Mr Klein will respond to if you ask the
question to him uh following this
hearing he's over at the Department of
Education he can be
contacted um so with that the I'm
looking at our sheet right here yes we
did have uh some technical support from
the Department available if we need it
but at this time um I don't think we are
there um so I'm going to conclude this
hearing on 349 point of order Mr chair
yes um were there are there additional
people that were signed up to speak for
this I see none on the sheet that I was
provided right here we had that signed
up that I've got from Jen Jennifer at
8:20 or so this morning there were three
people to speak those who have already
spoken the prime sponsor and the two
folks from the nursing
associations uh Drew Klein came in uh
shortly after we started as an attendee
and raised his hand I have not seen
other hands R raised there uh have you
representative Hobson yes we have two
hands raised one is from telephone that
I can't identify and the other one is
representative Tim Lang and one of those
hands just raised yes uh I think rep
Lang was the last one after I had closed
the hearing I I believe so I'm sorry I
it was I was looking at the attendees
list it was after I had closed this
hearing so I am going to um con close
close this
hearing and uh if representative l has
something is that
uh see what we got here yeah repres the
other hand I can't identify who that is
it's just a telephone number yes I
understand that so we're gonna we're
we're gonna close right now and go on to
the next bill which is HB 96 act
inclusion HB 349 we had Mr chair point
of information are are are we not taking
testimony from um from people that are
participating by
phone we are taking testimony but that
request by phone came after I had said
we're closing this meeting down it just
popped up
screen
uh represent Hobson did you see that
prior to my closing down or after
actually uh the phone number has had
their hand raised for quite a while um
there's no way for me to find out who it
is at this point and rep Lang was the
hand that um I just saw go up that's
what I saw go up too so on that
telephone
conversation uh I I will allow that
individual because I believe that may
have been there but the rep line came up
after IID closed so um okay so I can
allow them to talk without U promoting
them to panelists would you like me to
do that yes go ahead okay okay so um the
person with the telephone that ends in
890 I'm going to unmute you uh if you
could just identify
please okay the caller needs to unmute
on their end by pressing star six oh
Jen hi this is representative Leah
kushman hi
okay thank you for taking my my uh call
and uh letting me speak uh Mr chairman
my name is representative Leah kushman I
represent wear and Dearing um I'm a
registered nurse a recent best back
laurate degree program graduate um I had
my RN for six years as an associate
degree R RN prior to that um I just want
to I'm I'm a little unclear on um the
the discrepancy about the borate
requirement um but I'll just speak
briefly um um in support of this bill uh
I think this bill will help reduce the
shortage of School nurses by reducing um
kind of sloppy requirements that have
all kinds of loopholes and we'll just
open it up um to anyone any registered
nurse uh to serve as a school
nurse um without having to be certified
through the Department of Education RNs
who work for staffing agencies with
associate degrees are filling in at
schools now without certification and
without prior experience I know because
I received the alerts from staffing
agencies that I work for uh putting
calls out for nurses to pick up these
shifts um and I will say the only
difference between a borate degree
nursing program and associate degree
program is the level of Community Health
that is taught and it's really just
rather redundant if you go through
nursing school and an associate degree
program you do your general education
courses over two or three years as
prerequisites before you can start the
two-year nursing
courses um and in a borate degree
program nursing students do their
general education courses in the first
two years of their four-year program
followed by two years of core nursing
courses associate degrees are um the the
most common Avenue that RNs get their
licensure both Avenues um include
extensive clinical training in
facilities and labs and both nurses both
um Associates degree and borate degree
RN take the exact same RN lure exam the
enlex and they they both do um
generational intergenerational nursing
that includes Pediatrics and there's no
reason that I see that um the any RMS
need to be certified to be School nurses
so that's all I'll say today thank you
for taking my
testimony thank you very much
representative are there questions for
the
representative point of order Mr chair
yes please uh I have a message uh
representative Lang had said that he had
signed up to speak and has been trying
to speak I just uh want to make sure
that that uh that is understood he is a
co-sponsor thank you oh I'm sorry
okay um uh Jen are you
there yes I'm trying to look at the um
that is a problem with the system that
people can continue to register after we
relay the results to the chairs
349 yeah this this needs to be somehow
resolved seeing that we're trying to
build um a schedule as we're going
through these hearings that's not
necessarily uh applicable to every
hearing because a different number of
people trying to testify this particular
situation when you see few people
signing up you allow more time for
individuals to speak um then when we
have others piling on then it starts to
give us a this Crunch at the end so yes
representative vad my record shows that
he registered to speak at 9:54 this
morning
yes okay um of course that's that's
after the start of this particular
hearing um so um if uh if the
representative is there and wants to
speak I will allow him you know a few
moments but I really got to get on to
the next hearing
here okay he's he's permitted to speak
go ahead representative Lang thank you
uh chairman thank you committee members
for taking my testimony I apologize I
hadn't intend to speak and just sign
support the testimony I was hearing
maybe want to speak um and I'll be real
brief I want to make sure we're clear
that a a vote to uh OTP this bill is not
a vote against nurses that I think our
nurses do a great job and I think that
the only differential here is is the
regulatory requirement we've placed
within the Board of Education reflective
of the medical care that our students
are receiving and I'm I'm saying no uh
and that that's why I supported this
bill is that in a time when we're
talking about getting every every
squeezing every nickel so we can get the
best value out of out of that nickel for
our education system this borous
regulatory requirement that serves no
real new function as we've heard these
nurses can serve in there emergency
rooms and our hospitals and our doctor's
offices but some reason they can't serve
in our school system so I again I want
to make sure we're when we're talking
we're talking about the regulatory
burden that we've applied to schools in
hiring and not the quality of care that
are our students are getting I apologize
for uh being in coming in late but I
just wanted after hearing some of the
testimony I wanted to make sure again
we're not talking about the quality of
care our students get because I think in
RN again we've heard takes the same test
regardless of where they work and that
if our requirement is an RN that should
be our requirement let the medical
professionals determine medical care but
the educational professionals worry
about teaching thank you that's all I
have to say thank you very much
representative uh with that uh I'm not
going to ask the representa take
questions uh we will conclude this
hearing
um I had on the sheet that I had
received earlier just so we can get that
done supporting was 10 opposed 12 and
neutral zero obviously we've had a few
people come in speaking um presenting to
us so that the count that I just
mentioned does not is not inclusive of
them so uh in conclusion we are
finishing are closing this hearing on
349 and opening up the hearing on House
Bill
96 96 is establishing the office of
School counseling and psychology
establishing the position of school
counselor coordinator and making an
appropriation
therefore and the prime sponsor is
representative
Cornell good morning and thank you for
allowing me to present this and first I
want to say that this bill was first
presented last session by then
representative Dave dhy who I believe
has signed up to speak after me so
hopefully I will just briefly introduce
this and we'll allow representative DH
to be the next speaker to take more
questions and give more background on
this bill um the intent of the bill is
to establish the position of school
counselor coordinator in the Department
of Education and the Coordinator would
work and give assistance to school
counselors career counselors School
psychologists and school social workers
and insist in developing school programs
during the pandemic that's going on now
and afterwards schools will be dealing
with and are dealing with numerous
issues with students staff families and
I think those Personnel need a liaison
and the Department of Education to
assist them in referrals with help of
what to do program to do um the position
was previously funded and filled but
it's been completely vacant since I
think
2018 this bill passed in 2018 came out
of our committee I think
18-2 went to finance who finance took
the money out and recommended to the
commissioner to put it in his budget for
the next year um and then covid happened
and this bill was one of the ones that
just got
lost so I think it's really important
that we have a coordinator at the
Department of Education to help with
on that's
all thank you very much uh
representative Cornell and I will then
go right on to the honorable uh dhy uh
represent dhy here who worked with this
bill last year and um um I would I would
welcome him to the committee if he's
Hobson yes I've promoted him he should
he should be in any
minute
okay good morning Mr chairman can you
hear me all right yeah I can I hope your
NASCAR driver is going to do well this
year I hope so
too if he needs a little more support So
if you if you want to hop on you're
welcome so thank you uh Mr chairman and
esteemed colleagues it's good to see uh
good to see you all this
morning um my name is David dhy I live
in
Pembroke um I uh I was a member of the
education committee the last two terms
and as such I did introduce this bill
last term I apolog oliz to those of you
who have heard this before but I know
there are some new
members um I spent 38 years as a high
school counselor 30 of those years were
in New Hampshire I was in one private
school and two Public Schools finished
my last 19 years at penbroke
Academy I was also excuse me president
of the uh what was then called the New
Hampshire guidance Directors Association
from 2005 to 2008 when I
retired um this this is a very important
position it's been around for a while it
started uh back in the 60s and 70s it
was fully funded by the state as were
many other things in those days um for
those of you who are familiar at all
with with counseling um Jim Carr and
Joanne hlip were the the two Originators
of this position and during the 70s and
80s they were very active in terms of
helping counselors around the
state um after they left the position
was vacant for about 10 years and then
since then it's been kind of up and down
sometimes it's been a full-time position
sometimes it's been a part-time position
sometimes it's been funded by the state
sometimes from federal resources or
grants sometimes a combination of both
it's been very era
as representative Cornell indicated
since um 2018 June of 2018 the position
has been
vacant and um so um this is the reason
that I introduced this bill last year
because I felt this was a position that
needed to be
reintroduced um over the years
counselors have been asked to do more
and more counselors exist in all levels
of Education in the state K to 12 um
very important to students very
important to staff to have competent and
experienced counselors in the building
and but there's no advocate for for
counselors in the Department of
Education and there really should be uh
counselor duties have expanded they're
very different depending on the area um
in the school that the counselors work
in depends on if you know if they're in
an Urban school or suburban school the
socioeconomic background the types of
students and as representative Cornell
indicated since the pandemic pandemic um
this is um more and more reason that
counselors need support and help and
guidance of for themselves and this is
what this position can
provide
um all teachers all counselors all
Personnel working in school need all
kinds of support they need financial
support they need emotional
support um and uh I think this position
can provide that one of the uh things
that happened last year when I
introduced this bill uh representative
lad asked me if I would include some
Workforce Development as part of this uh
responsibility ility of this coordinator
so that we could make this a bipartisan
bill I was happy to do that I think it's
important uh I've been a advocate for
Workforce Development for CTE
education um I have no problem with that
and that's one of the reasons why it had
such strong bipartisan support from the
education committee last time
unfortunately there just wasn't enough
money in the budget to be able to fund
this position so I'm certainly hoping
that's going to
change go ahead well thank you very much
rep honorable Dave
dhy forly honorable and formly
representative
um are there some questions for repres
Dave dhy um uh we we do have h h a
number of people that have indicated
desire to speak to this uh I see on my
sheet and I don't know if it's the
current sheet based upon the last bill
but we have one two three four five six
seven people up uh or in on Deck so um
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Dy
welcome again good to see you and hear
from you uh Dave I just had a question
when you were talking about Workforce
Development I'm looking at line 15 of
the page two of the bill it talks about
Bureau of career development using that
as the same uh notation is that the same
language I think that's I think that's
correct representative
Woodcock um it's all part of the same
package I think uh you know councelors
do a lot of different jobs and one of
them uh is to help kids not only look at
postsecondary education but look at post
educ
postsecondary career choices and um I
think that u a coordinator in the
Department of Education can certainly
bring together some other aspects of
educ of Educators in the department to
work on further developing uh um career
opportunities for students I hope that
answers your question it does thank you
very much uh representative thank you Mr
lad always happy to see you both of you
um with that I because we have to move
on to some others I want to thank uh
representative dhy for coming on today
um let's go to is uh Ron Hopson back or
is Jen still in
charge well Jen's always in charge but
I'm back okay who's next on the docket
here Karen uh looks like well I haven't
scanned to see if we have uh
Representatives here um in order of
importance would you say uh Karen Merill
I I see uh Mary Heath is in the
queue um okay and she has
testimony couple minutes worth
okay okay Mary I have uh moved you up to
now there you are thank you Mr chair and
and um nice to see the committee uh
thank you for letting me testify today
um for the record my name is Mary San
Heath and I represent district 14 in
Manchester and um I just will speak very
briefly and I certainly am in support of
House Bill
96 um and as a former um employee of the
New Hampshire Department of Ed I worked
consistently with the person formally in
that position and saw the good results
um it gave us the ability to coordinate
across the state with guidance
counselors but I want to talk about my
role um in division two um in the
finance committee um when the bill came
to the finance it the house passed the
bill uh fully um and I actually think it
might have been on the consent agenda um
but when it got to division 2 in finance
um we knew at that point point in time
we did not have enough money in the
budget to pass it and at that point in
time we actually amended the bill um and
asked that the department include this
position in their budget request coming
forward to us um now that was a a a
bipartisan unanimous vote coming out of
the house uh coming out of house finance
division to then Co happened and and it
lost its way um and didn't end up in in
any of the Omnibus bills um that came
back to us from the Senate so um I just
want to speak um that we really need
this position of the Department of Ed
and I hope that the uh committee will um
vote to a to pass thank you very much
I'm complete thank you very much
representative Heath are there questions
of Representative
Heath not seeing thank you very much and
have a good day
[Music]
hson representative Hopson you're
muted thank you I could have been
talking all
day we have um Karen Merill anel and she
had her hand raised as well so I'm not
sure uh she's speaking as well as a
question so I I believe I had requested
to testify is this my do that's what
you're doing yeah okay perfect all right
so I want to thank you for your
willingness to listen my name is Karen
Merill anel I'm currently an employed
school counselor and member of both the
New Hampshire School counseling
Association and the American School
counseling Association in an attempt to
come in under approximated time I shall
read prepared testimony
near the turn of the century school
counselors did not only replace guidance
counselors in name but in job
description as well simplistically
expressed guidance counselors of old who
we all had based on our age in part were
responsive when students presented a
need in stark contrast and decades later
school counselors by definition now are
still responsive as needed but also
proactive with all students and I under
under line all the profession has grown
in depth breadth and
responsibility K through2 school
counselors work with all students
equitably in three domains academic
social emotional and career ready we
designed developmentally appropriate
programming deliver it in a systematic
manner with the outcome-based goal of
improving the achievement attendance and
discipline of all students with this
context set it is perhaps most important
for this Gathering to understand that
school counselors are the profession in
our educational system that has its eye
first to students as people and to
people as students this Bears repeating
school counselors are charged first to
work intentionally and holistically with
each individual child and each
individual student each child charged
with learning who is actually each
student charged with navigating their
developmental growth as human
beings while of course all Educators
work with students as people the lens
with which we enter the building is
necessarily different simplistically
administrators are charged with systems
and Personnel nurses focus on physical
health first teachers with academic
success special Educators with learning
Challenge and Specialists with targeted
Focus the school counselor is a
professional that keep keeps its eye
each moment of each day to each student
as a person and each person as a student
indeed as the inevitable pedul of
Education swings and we know it does the
school counselor Works to steady its
impact on students never diminishing one
domain for the other when an increase in
graduation rate is the state's Focus we
rally the troops while still providing
social emotional programming in career
exploration when the state shines the
light on Mental Health Health we
continue career exploration and
facilitate achievement toward graduation
and when the pendulum swings toward
revitalizing New Hampshire's Workforce
we jump on board without taking our eye
off academic achievement and while still
beating the mental health drum to this
end it is undeniably crucial that just
as our students need the role of the
school counselor in the schools school
counselors need their voice represented
at the discussion and decision-making
table at the New Hampshire doe further
it is critical that our students
graduate as healthy individuals prepared
to be positive contributing members of
our society in order to do this we must
the students must develop tenacity and
confidence they must have the fortitude
to feel all their layered and evolving
emotions and self-regulate and display
behaviors appropriate to changing
situations they must be able to problem
solve collaborate and navigate
challenging relationships and they must
be able to set and Achieve short and
long-term goals they must be able to
self reflect articulate and self-
Advocate and develop and practice the
soft skills every eventual employer
demands even during a pandemic and as
you know this is just a a partial list
of what we need from our New Hampshire
graduates students have teachers that
typically are with them for one year and
our New Hampshire teachers do amazing
with our students in classrooms weaving
these skills into their work with
students however this work is too
important to leave its acquisition to
chance most often counselors are with
the same student year after year after
year supporting their developmental
growth not only that does this allow for
consistency and accountability and
programming but relationship building
between counselor and student as well
strong relationships after all are the
true foundation for any lasting growth
decisions that impact our youth in
public schools should not be made
without considering the lens of the
school counselor any decision made on
behalf of the Youth of our great state
should be done in consultation with the
rep representative voice of the
profession that works with the whole
child for the long term excuse
representative voice of the school if
you're just reading please could you
summarize so that we you know if
everybody takes 10 15 minutes we're
going to be here all day yep I timed it
with a stopwatch and I was at 50:7 and I
requested five minutes so my last
sentence which I was going to read says
the New Hampshire's youth will be better
served if the lens of the school
counselor is articulated and considered
as decisions that the doe are made
please help us best serve our New
Hampshire students by including our
voice at the table thank you thank thank
you very much other questions yes gson
and
Moffett uh thank you Mr chair thank you
uh M Mar for your uh testimony very
quickly maybe one of the co-sponsors
would would know this I'm just curious
you mentioned you're in several uh
associations um do does every state have
this type of positioned you know or or
not uh just I have no idea would this be
peculiar to New Hampshire or are we like
the only state that does not have this
uh that that's my my
question so we have school counselors
are in every state and whether they have
a position at the board level I would
assume so but I don't know that the
American School counsel Association is
across the state but I do believe from
my experience that every professional in
the school has a representative voice
and their doe but somebody may be able
better representative Shaw do you have a
question uh yes I would like um to know
if uh uh Karen Merill antil could uh
submit that
testimony via email since it's prepared
and if you could send it to the
committee I can print it out it' be a
lot
simpler I would happy to to do that
thank you you very much point that we
all should uh try to adhere to and I've
heard every chair that I've uh when I
since attending the education committee
for the last uh 13 years indicate if you
can summarize your written testimony
provide the clerk the written testimony
summarize so that it will expedite our
hearing process are there any further
questions for um for uh Karen
thank one more one more statement uh
representative lad um several of these
people that have spoken this morning
have submitted written testimony already
so um I I just would like you to mention
uh when they speak that if they have
already submitted written testimony to
summarize thank you very much I will do
that thank you you're welcome uh not
hearing any more questions or seeing any
more hands for for Karen thank you very
much and we will move uh rson Hobson to
the next
person okay I have promoted uh Laura
donica from the New Hampshire School
counseling
Association
okay there she is hi so I would like to
thank you for letting me H testify in
front of you today uh my name is Laura
donica I'm a middle school counselor in
our state and I'm the sitting
president-elect for the New Hampshire
School counseling
Association uh first of all I'd like to
say happy National School counseling
week this week we all take time in our
states across the United States to
advocate for our profession and today I
come to advocate for a position at the
department of Ed that hears our
voices we as school counselors have
unique position in the school we serve
all students social emotional
vocational um and educational
needs we are neither teachers nor are we
special Educators but often we get uh
categorized with teachers and special ed
Educators currently at our state
department of Ed uh when we call we
would talk to someone in the student
services
department uh unlike most positions in
the student services department we are
uh care for all students in our
school most professions that operate
under student services only service a
small percentage of students in school
before the co epidemic school counselors
were at the Forefront of our state
mental health care
crisis as the pandemic has grown school
counselors have stood with families and
students as the Mental Health crisis
intensifies
school counselors have been called upon
to help students remotely and in person
cope with the daily struggles of life in
the everyday of the
pandemic in my own experience the daily
job this year has been so much
harder it's hard to watch a child you
know um who has an intensive Mental
Health Care crisis with her while they
bed it also I have also watched this
this year as families
disintegrated as a seventh and eighth
grade school counselor I've had to sit
with students in grief over the loss of
social connections and Independence they
thought they would gain in eighth grade
and seventh
grade also during this critical time
while I'm dealing with Children's Mental
Health
needs I have had to also make seven
Master
schedules and coordinate the niwa and
SAS the reality is there's I only have
so much time and I have to prioritize
undone at the end of the day when you
reach out to the Department of Ed in our
state often our questions are left
unanswered and that silence is deafening
and
disheartening
we uh it's not surprising that the
person can't answer our questions as
student services is a wide variety of
professions and they probably can't
possibly know the ethics and laws under
each
profession the importance of having this
position at the department of
Ed will help school counselors feel
heard but also that person will know the
unique needs of our students and school
counselors and can voice those needs to
the
department they can help school
counselors interpret laws of our state
all of our students and school
counselors deserve a voice um I thank
you for allowing me to speak today uh
and I hope you create uh I hope you vote
to create that voice for us at the
you rip lad you're
muted think you're muted repl I was
muted that's right thank you very much
Laura for your testimony today uh I
don't see any other hands up of
questions so I I appreciate you're
coming on board today and providing of
us this
information uh repon Hobson who is next
here as I look at my sheet looks like
there's several people yet to speak uh
yes let's see I was looking for uh Julia
Nan but I don't see her do you see her
um
day
um what about uh emry Banfield I don't
see yeah okay um yep I'll unmute and
Marie
committee and Marie are you there unmute
your good
morning okay thank you I hope you can
hear me now I'll be very brief I know
that you are are tied tied on time so my
name is Amar Banfield I'm an advocate
for parental rights and academic EXC
excellence and education today I
actually come here in opposition of HB
96 so why would someone who supports
parental rights and excellence and
education oppose funding for
establishing a school counselor
coordinator for the office of School
counseling and
psychology primarily because there are
more important mental health needs that
children have and I want to share that
with you
today mental health needs of children
are probably more important today than
at any other time Co shutdowns of
schools and the lack of socialization
are having a terrible impact on many
children throughout New Hampshire I
interact with New Hampshire parents
daily whose children are having mental
breakdowns because of the isolation from
school closures it is important to
mention that there are some who are
still thriving but that is not the case
for many of the children in our state
and fortunate fortunately many of these
cases do not rise to the level of
desperation but I'm here to talk about
the ones that do when children suffer
emotionally sometimes that results in
depression anger and even worse suicidal
attempts Health Care Professionals are
the ones who have to deal with those
situations and often times the first
responder is the local emergency room
once those children are admitted there
is a call the Hamstead Hospital the only
Treatment Facility in New Hampshire that
admits
adolescence it would be nice to report
to you that when this happens children
are admitted immediately and treated by
a specialist in mental health
unfortunately that is not the case if
there is no space available the child
can sit in the hospital your local
hospital for days and sometimes a week
or longer can you imagine the cost to
the state when day after day these kids
are sitting in the local hospital
untreated by a mental health
professional HB 96 creates a new
bureaucratic position within the
Department of Education this position
does not in any way meet the
psychological needs of children that
require Services right now it does not
Elevate the wait time alleviate the wait
time that would offer some relief to the
taxpayers and it certainly does not
offer relief to Children Sitting In
Limbo so I share the concerns that
everyone has expressed so far but I
believe that there are better ways to
allocate These funds to address the much
needed issues of treating the mental
health of children who need that right
now so I ask you to ex vote to
inexpedient to legislate and then look
at ways to address the desperate need
for accessibility Hamstead Hospital how
can we work to meet the needs of
children so that they do not end up in
the ER how can we provide immediate care
and allocate funding to cover those
costs in the end it would save the state
money if children have immediate access
to ham Hospital instead of sitting in
our local hospital waiting room or
waiting for a room let's prioritize
spending on mental health for children
adding another bureaucratic position at
the Department of Education may be a
nice want but there are too many needs
right now to move this legislation
forward and I'll just add that speaking
personally on a personal um personal
issue with a friend whose son did end up
in the hospital for a suicide attempt
just a short time ago um I I believe
there was 58 people in front in line
waiting to get into Hamstead hospital
before that before he could be admitted
uh and if they're speaking with um
Hamstead Hospital a representative there
I mean that that differs from day to day
but I just think that when I look at
this position and and I know that the
school counselors are doing their best
and and I think you know we are hearing
from some that are that are doing you
know phenomenal work I just see this as
I'm thinking these kids are sitting in
the hospital sometimes for a week I
can't even even imagine what the cost is
so anyway I want to thank you for taking
my testimony I don't mean to be the only
person who you know opposes something
good but I just think that we need to
prioritize and I think that this is
something that the the funds could be
used in a better way so thank you thank
you very much amarie are there any
questions for amarie
Banfield not seeing any hands there
represent LE do you have your hand up or
you okay or just holding your head
up thank you very much anarie um uh and
have a good afternoon uh repon Hobson do
we have anybody on that list I see uh
Moren and Julia however um do you have
them sign still waiting there in the
waiting room to to speak I do not see
them uh listed in the in the attendees
so I'm not sure not sure where they are
oh okay if they're if they're not there
and if they're not we're just we're
going to have to move on so at this
point in time looking at HB
96 there were 156 signed up in support
five to oppose and one
neutral um the total number that had
signed up to testify was seven so we'll
close down HB 96 and move on to hb26
ative lad I I missed the numbers I'm
sorry okay representative Cornell I'll
read them again for you thank you
support was 156
156 oppose was
five neutral was one and the total
number that had signed up to testify was
seven thank you you're more than
welcome uh H so this this hearing is now
closed and we will go into h B
278 this is relative to use of unused
Schools okay okay is representative Hill
uh
Hill good morning uh host education
committee um thank you for welcoming me
back for the record I am representative
Greg Hill um still serving the town of
uh Northfield and one-third of the
city of Manchester I'm sorry of uh
Franklin um Manchester wouldn't be happy
about that I don't think um I am uh here
today to introduce uh House Bill
287 which um has been called a right of
first refusal for Charter Schools um to
representative Tanner this too must seem
like a groundhog day bill um it has uh
been before us before in fact it passed
both the house and the Senate uh before
and then the Senate did some of their um
their uh interesting tricks by adding uh
this popular Bill to another bill in
order to have the house um approve both
of them and uh and the house didn't take
the bait and non-c concurred and so uh
this this was the victim um this is a
bill um actually charter schools have
have had quite a long history I'll give
you a brief background originally
Charter Schools were not allowed to
incur long-term debt to um to have their
own facility um that was signed by
Governor Lynch and changed and uh then
we went to governor sonunu who changed
it further um and allowed uh them to
have long-term debt without having to uh
go first through their fiveyear
certification program and um and now uh
this is a bill to um increase the um the
efficiency of taxpayer money um this is
uh to allow charter schools to utilize
some of that funding that they currently
get uh to um either purchase or lease um
unused school
facilities from directly from the uh
school
district and to allow them um to have a
uh better suited building for them um
and and not have to rely on items like
uh renting space in in Supermarket malls
or anything like that um at at some
point here we have only uh 30 three of
our 30 Charter Schools currently have
their own building that's uh my current
belief um most lease or rent space from
other public school districts or
for-profit
landlords um an important point is that
a significant amount of per pupil dollar
goes to building expenses and additional
money is often used to make the property
suitable for Charter School students as
a learning
environment um not only do they pay for
the um if they go to a for-profit
landlord some of their money would
actually be going towards real estate
taxes in fact so um our goal here um is
to provide um charter schools and and um
public school districts the ability to
be married together and create a willing
seller willing buyer um scenario the
only thing there's two things that are
different in this legislation uh versus
what the house education has seen in the
past and that's uh to address um um
objectives uh or objections from um uh
our Democrat colleagues in the past one
um there is an amendment that I have had
drafted I think it's amendment
0199 that should be in your in your box
somewhere there um and that deals with
um page two line 11 I think um where it
talks about
91a um I too thought the original
drafting of this bill was a little
confusing um this is dealing when two
Charter Schools both are applying for
the same
property um what we were hoping to do
was have the um the criteria that the
school district would use to determine
which charter school should have the
right of first refusal we wanted that
criteria discussion to be public we did
not want the
individual um discussion of any of the
details of the of the two applicants to
be made public so we don't need to talk
about their bank statements or anything
like that in public session but in in
Prior language it it mentioned 91a and
it said it was not subject to 91a and to
me anytime in information is public that
makes it subject to 91a so I've had um
OS scrub that section on um 91a
adherence and so the the sentence would
end at um public
information then uh the second item that
I had uh removed or changed in this
legislation um we had originally uh
asked individual School District
when they had property that was
available for lease or for sale we had
asked them to uh that they would have to
contact each Charter School by
registered letter um notifying them that
they had this property available and and
our Democrat colleagues correctly
pointed out that was an honorous task
and perhaps uh violated
28a I agree so um the only thing that we
have changed here is to require the
districts to contact UM the doe once um
with the uh that information and the
charter school coordinator would be the
one that would contact each of the um of
the charter schools making them aware of
the availability of this property um and
with that I think um I will just pretty
much say that uh for the the mail that I
received uh from taxpayers um who
question why their child is on a charge
of school waiting list um and uh and
can't find suitable property to um to
handle more children um meanwhile their
neighborhood school is empty and and
their tax money is going to maintain an
empty building um they seem slightly
confused and um and so I think this
would uh I think this would be a um a
good step in the direction of uh of
being more efficient and as a financial
advisor I'm always looking for financial
efficiency um with that I'll end my
testimony I'm happy to answer any
questions and I appreciate your time
thank thank you very much uh
representative Hill um when you you
referenced Amendment
0199 uh was that forwarded to uh leg
from legislative services to to you know
the folks upstairs in the L that could
is it has that been sent out to all
committee members do you know um I just
received it while I was listening to
your prior hearing uh chairman lad um
okay I can't tell from
this who it was sent to um it came from
ask
um and it looks like it was sent at 8:39
202-0199
H
yeah but I can't tell beyond that I'm
sorry okay thank thank you very much we
were just trying to get a system set up
where amendments would go out to
committee members as well to expedite
this whole process sounds great so thank
you very much are there questions for
representative
Hill yes represent luno thank you very
much Mr chair um so uh so thanks for
bringing this um this forward um
representative Hill um so are you aware
that um that several local school boards
have already leased or sold um School
District property to uh to Charter
Schools um I am aware of at least one um
I I think that's a great idea um I have
no no problem with the with the process
uh working when it works that way um my
understanding from um from others is
that uh it doesn't always work that way
so follow up on that yes um uh so you
use the um the term this would allow uh
those sorts of transactions to um to
take place is is using that term
somewhat
misleading um if if you would like to um
change that and and formulate it your
own way I'm happy to let you do that
well what you really meant is require
require local school boards not allow
local school boards is that
correct
um I am I am requiring districts to make
sure that the property is listed um I'm
not
forcing um charter schools and a public
school to to make the transaction happen
happen I'm I'm merely um requiring the
district to um to list the property um
available thank thank you very much um
are are there further
questions thank you very much
representative Hill uh represent my
pleasure can we uh go to the top of the
docket here and invite the others that
please I I I show uh I'm sorry I had
myself muted I promoted uh Carl lad from
the New Hampshire administrator
Association thank
[Music]
you good morning Mr chairman good
morning members of House Ed for the rec
my name is Carl lad I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
administrators Association thank you for
taking the time to take my testimony
today um we are um oh in representative
Shaw just so that you know I did uh
forward my written testimony uh to the
committee
members I am uh speaking today on uh
behalf of the members of nhsaa to oppose
uh 278 uh in its current form uh we
certainly appreciate uh representative
Hill's interest in securing facilities
to house students and provide
educational opportunities for them we
find the legislation to be troubling
however uh in that it really erodes
local control um and can create an
additional burden on local taxpayers for
students who do not necessarily live in
that community and imposes state
requirements where a local community
should have the opportunity uh for
self-determination there already exists
as representative luno mentioned uh
opportunities in a pathway for a local
school district to sponsor Charter
Schools or to lease or sell uh property
uh as they see fit um but there are many
districts who are either planning or
have uh accomplished repurposing school
facilities for other community use
sometimes they're used as community
centers senior centers uh this proposal
would seem to Omit that uh as an an
option um several other districts have
sold their school district property to
bring about taxpayer relief uh so this
would also seem to Omit that
possibility um all of the building
purchases and subsequent maintenance
were made with local taxpayer dollars
and approval should be the local um
community that determines the use of the
property uh that they've been uh pouring
into we uh we frequently hear that
Charter Schools uh speak of a wide
catchment area of students who they
attract yet when they're all gathered
Under One Roof can create a tax impact
on the community where they're located
um demands for goods and services from
the local police fire or general
services are
impacted requiring communities to accept
Charter Schools um and their leases uh
or purchases uh could impose an
additional tax burden on local
taxpayers they should be allowed to have
a voice and accepting that additional
expense and not be told that they shall
accept those
schools to force communities to accept
lease or P proposals purchase proposals
um is simply wrong um and not in a
community's best interest uh local
citizens should be allowed to make the
determination of what happens with their
buildings um through existing Pathways
uh and the preservation of local control
uh and with that U Mr chairman I know
you're pressed for time I'd be glad to
take any questions uh thank you very
much Dr Lad um are there questions for
the school administrators
association yes representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Mr lad for um uh for being
with us this morning um is it possible
that that some School District property
may be subject to um to covenants um
particularly if um if the if maybe the
land that the school was on was was
donated to the district by a
family thank you representative luno
that's a great question because um I
know of several school districts uh that
do have schools uh that are um on land
that is owned by a private family
foundation in fact Stratford
Public School uh in Stratford New
Hampshire um is owned by the Baldwin
family um and that property is under a
covenant um and it is only to be used
for uh public education purposes uh
certainly an argument could be made that
uh New Hampshire charter schools are
public schools uh but there may be other
usage for other
questions thank you very much Dr Lad
thank you Mr
chairman uh I see on the list uh coming
up here we'll have Barrett Christina
come up next yep he has been promoted he
should be you should be in yep there you
are great uh good morning thank you
chairman lad uh good morning members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to speak um again for the record Barett
Christina executive director of the New
Hampshire school Wards Association we
are opposed to House Bill uh 278 um
first we certainly Echo um the comments
made by the school administrators
Association about you know these were
local buildings paid for by local um
taxpayers seems that the local voters
should have a say in what happens with
their facility um but policy aspect
aside um the the language of the bill is
concerning because in a lot of places I
just I think it's too vague and doesn't
make a lot of sense um you know first
when we're talking about unused facility
in which 10% of the square footage of
the building is you is is is being used
I I don't know how many buildings we
have statewide in which less than 10% of
the of the building is being used for
direct um student instruction maybe the
Department of Education has some numbers
on that but I mean if we're talking
about less than 10% full my experience
is that that building has been shuttered
long ago um you know also um direct
student instruction I don't know what
that necessarily means um in conjunction
with the phrase unus facility I mean
does that include a gymnasium an
auditorium um office space for
administrators custodial closets um I
just you know the auditorium in the
gymnasium at times may be used for some
student instruction and at other times
not used for student instruction so I'm
not sure how we're going to calculate
the square footage requirement um also
the second criteria um says for which
the school district has no school board
approv approved written plan for future
use um if that's going to be the Lynch
pin you know nhba can certainly Advocate
to our school boards if they have any of
these facilities to develop a plan um
between now and and July 1st of of
2021 um and also the date this is on
page one of the bill line 10 this bill
becomes effective July 1st
2021 um many if not all of our schools
across the state have had a lot of
unused um school um uh square footage
this past year um as kidss have been
either home or remote or a hybrid
capacity so I'm not sure if this bill
were to pass and become effective I'm
not sure how we're going to get through
calculating um that uh that that 10% of
unused square footage um and the last
point that I'll make that I I think is a
little unclear on page two lines 22
through
24 um during the term of a lease a
Charter Public School shall be
responsible for direct expenses I don't
know what that means um related to the
facility um or any part of the facility
least including utilities Insurance
maintenance property taxes and repairs I
guess my question is what would happen
if the if the school district has to
take out a bond for repairs to to the
facility um whether or not that's a a
new roof or an HVAC system or perhaps a
new Wing or something significantly
substantial um is the charter school
then responsible for part of those Bond
payments I mean I suppose you could put
that in a in a contract or a lease or
whatnot but the way the way the language
is written all it says is direct
expenses and without clarifying exactly
what that means um we think that's
significantly vague and it's only going
to cause you know further problems down
the line um so with that uh that
concludes my testimony again nhba is
opposed to House Bill uh 278 the the
language is vague I'm not sure um how
workable it really is and I'm not sure
how many schools actually have have less
than 10% of their square footage
actually being used and with that I'm
happy to answer any questions from the
committee thank you thank you very much
uh Barrett are there questions for the
school boards Association uh
representative Moffett thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Christina um I'm just
G to pass on a question that just came
to me from a former uh Manchester School
Board member uh and she just wanted us
to ask uh she points out the city of
Manchester owns uh the schools in
Manchester but in the event of closure
the cities can sell the the uh the
school properties and the schools and
realize a profit so her question is why
shouldn't charter schools have the first
opportunity to purchase an existing
school and keep the schools in the
education business as opposed to uh
something
else thank you for the question
representative Moffet I mean I certainly
can't speak to every facility issue
that's occurred in the State the last
number of years um the schools that I
know that have closed down um and I I I
understand this may not be pertinent to
Manchester I understand they're going
through a review of looking at their
their spacing and their high schools and
perhaps consolidation um I suppose you
know to the point earlier nothing would
stop the school district from
approaching a charter school to see if
if if they wanted to lease or perhaps
purchase um a facility but mandating it
is a completely is completely different
issue a completely different question um
you know so long as there can be that
collaboration you know ideally that
would be wonderful um but again back to
the other issue the the the I'm thinking
of one school in my area that closed
about 10 years ago um it wasn't because
the school was empty it was because the
fire chiefs said we're not allowing
children in that building anymore so you
know I think a lot of these get to do
with the age of our facilities you know
I think I read a report the other day
the average age of a facility a school
facility in New Hampshire is like 60 or
70 years old at some point it just
doesn't become safe anymore at some
point um you know the repairs that would
be needed to keep that school up to code
and keep children safe it doesn't it
doesn't become financially possible to
do that and I guess the bigger issue is
um you know I understand that the
charter schools May from time to time
have trouble finding um finding space
perhaps the answer is re-implementation
of a building
um program in New Hampshire rather than
mandating that local school districts
sell their facilities to educate
children from other
communities thank you sir thank you very
much Barrett uh are there further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much and have a good afternoon thank you
you as well you're welcome uh I'd like
to invite uh Matt sutherton from the
Charter School
Association hey good morning thank you
for having me uh forther record my name
is Matt suton I'm president of New
Hampshire Alliance for public charter
schools we're nonprofit nonpartisan
organizations supporting public charter
schools and charter school applicants
let me see if I can share my screen here
oh you need to be
to no worries I can I can summarize my
testimony
inen not a problem I know you all are
gonna have a very busy day so I won't
take too much of your time
uh we we truly believe that this is a
common sense bill for New Hampshire we
believe that it would benefit both
Public Schools uh public charter schools
and school districts that maintain
public facility space that's unoccupied
or no longer in
use uh as you've as you've heard before
if this bill is passed it would give New
Hampshire Charter Schools the right of
first refusal in the event that a public
school district elects we're not forcing
anyone if they elect to sell or lease on
unused schools district facility
space uh Public Schools they're unique
entities they're unique structures and
uh they're dear to all of us Public
Schools were built using public funds
with the intention of educating public
school
students uh their public school
buildings are uniquely configured making
them most suited to function as public
schools we therefore believe that if an
unused school facility is destined to be
leased or sold that it only makes sense
that it should go to well it should go
first to a public school such as a
charter school or even another public
school that is interested um Charter
Schools struggle struggle to access F
facility space because unlike your
traditional public school they do not
receive uh financial assistance to
purchase or build facility space uh I
think I'd like to take a moment to
address some of the issues that that I
heard brought up uh with regard to
districts
offering lease space I'm only aware of
three charter schools that were
offered School District lease space uh
one of those being SEO charter school
and that was that school was
actually um removed from their
facility uh and they had to find Space
of their own I'm only aware of three
charter schools in New Hampshire that
own their own facility space and none of
those schools purchased the facility
space from the district so I'm not sure
what Charter what other Charter Schools
lease facility space from the districts
or and I'm certainly not aware of any
charter schools that purchase facility
space from
districts um in terms of what would
happen should a charter school lease a
facility and uh certain expenses come up
I imagine that it would be the
same as what would happen with any other
lease all of those expenses would be um
contained within the terms and
conditions of a contract as would be the
same case with any other leasy and I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you very much uh Mr
questions I'm not seeing any hands up uh
thank you very much Matt thank you more
welcome uh rson Hobson do we have any
other folks that are signed up or in the
queue to testify not that I know of we
are we should
be pardon me we should be all set thank
you yeah okay um so in conclusion we had
that I had submitted to me by that 820
825 period of time supporting 20
opposing 25 neutral was Zero those
testified we had four signed up to do so
so in conclusion uh this uh wraps up uh
HB 278 we're closing this hearing and
we're going to break for lunch the next
hearing starts at
12:45 HB 110 at that time so that should
give you approximately 50 minutes here
for 50 so minutes for 55 minutes for
lunch any
questions well have a good lunch raid
up no okay good yes it'll continue
running all you need to do is mute your
much
hi hi represent Vlad and represent
Hobson I just wanted to let you know
that I
am um trying to update the list for hb20
you
so how many do you have on your list
2300 it's more
now I have a question are we gonna do
Bill
110 yes okay just making sure yeah we
got
[Music]
to
I'll be right back getting some tea
yeah
for
can you hear me Rick yes I can they're
not letting me share anything here I'm
trying to I was trying to get my video
going but it's
saying but I can't must be because it's
still on lunch break or something J are
you I I see you representative Shaw can
can represent Shaw you know have those
privileges so that she can talk with
people oh yeah I can undo this
the Good your video is working represent
sha okay it's not necessary that he see
me I just wanted to talk to
him so um all of these people are saying
they're going to testify yes yes yes
well if they've already sent in their
testimony um I don't understand why they
need to to because I recognize a lot of
these names on here as because I wrote
down every single name last night that I
had testimony of on
my so I don't know it's gonna be well
whatever I'll do my best to expedite
this as much as we can uh we're not
going to have anybody repeating what has
been said by somebody else they can say
they support what the other person has
said but there's no need to just repeat
repeat repeat repeat uh we all will be
here
forever um and so um it's also we will
be careful with the amount of time that
we allow um there will be some
situations where we need to spend a
little bit more time on but uh uh we we
need to get away from you all the
storytelling and we need to get down to
addressing specifics within the
bill
right I will I will mention that at the
beginning of of the
hearing yeah we don't need somebody's
life
history exactly you don't need to hear
another nurse's report for 15 minutes
either right yeah that's what I meant
it's not just that any any particular
person it's all the people that we we're
we're going to try to just state that
stay to the content the intent of this
bill re respond to the bill uh and the
language within the bill and I think we
will be able to move this thing along
and we don't need to go into the history
of all the folks that are you know
testifying here so that that just
absorbs time and really doesn't net us
anything that's going to help us in
deciding where to go with the the
bill can we just want the facts ma'am
the facts is what we want yes can we
limit them can we Rec they stay between
three to five minutes um I would prefer
as the chair has that discretion we have
some folks which will have that'll be
technical advice for us which have
specifics and new factual information
and um those people may need uh a little
bit more time the prime sponsors us need
a little bit more time to get the thing
initiated I figured that I blocked off
six hours and uh so I'll Stick Around
Colonel you got it right put a tie on
Rick so we're trying I'm elevating our
game here yes yeah I I changed tie
seeing that you know I had a little bit
of dessert on the other one I put a blue
tie on and and there's nothing wrong
with a blue tie
yeah well I managed not to spill
anything on
mine okay folks yeah just the two
Colonels are
speaking okay uh liutenant Colonel and
fall bird
colonel um all right uh we're we're at
uh
12:45 so uh it's
12:45 uh folks uh welcome back committee
members we are now going to move forward
with the continuance of today's um
hearing calendar
and we're going to be addressing HB 110
HB 110 is relative to the distribution
of an adquate education adequate
education grants the prime sponsor being
uh representative Stephen Smith uh Deb H
rbson Hobson do you have Miss uh
representative
Smith available I do not see him on this
list uh let me just
quickly
scan if someone else knows something
that I don't is there another sponsor
here oh rep Judy Aon is
here you have uh Judy Aaron Al
balero represent love uh I have Judy
Aaron here can I promote
her if she's willing to just what we
need to do is we need to have somebody
just to introduce the bill we've that
many times committee before where we've
had a person from the committee get up
there now she is a I see rep Smith just
came in okay okay good so we'll have her
introduce the bill I'm sorry this is
Stephen Smith he just he just got here
introducing okay you just have to unmute
representative
Smith okay how's that good afternoon
representative are you
there thank you Mr chair my apologies
for being late I was plowing and just
about made it back in time I am
Representative Steven Smith Sullivan
County District 11 aworth Charlestown
Goan langden lempster and
Washington uh this bill is a simple
transparency Bill shouldn't cost anybody
any money and it resolves some
transparency and trust issues so when
adequacy payments are sent to towns they
don't get sent to towns they go to the
school District the school district
takes account of the grants that they've
received and then the town gets a bill
for the
balance you may be surprised to know
that there are some municipalities that
have a contentious relationship with the
school districts and this isn't helping
um so it's an unnecessary situation
here's a practical application Mr chair
let's say that you retained me to
provide some services for you and I go
okay your bill representative lad's
going to be
$100,000 and then it comes time to pay
the bill and I go good news I got some
grants so your Bill's only going to be
$80,000 you're happy you may not request
any documentation but then the following
year I go yeah you know those grants
didn't come in as a matter of fact they
tacked on some fees and now you're going
to have to pay me
$110,000 knowing you as I do Mr chair
your head will explode and you're going
to demand documentation from me and
rightfully so so you have the
municipality and a school district which
might not be getting along and the
municipality is dependent on the
district to tell them what money came in
how much they owe um so it causes some
problems this bill will send the
adequacy payments to the municipality
the municipality will receive a bill
from the district for the full amount of
whatever it is they're supposed to pay
and then they just write the check like
they always do but it'll be the full
amount and they will know exactly what
their state aid is is in the town will
be able to easily see it go up down is
what whatever we do this year you know
without having to rely on a third person
that's all I all I hope to accomplish
with this bill and I hope that it get
gets the uh committee's support thank
you for listening thank you very much
representative Smith are you willing to
take questions absolutely are there any
questions from the
committee representa luno thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you very much
representative Smith for bringing this
one forward this afternoon um what you
just said um um the the the the up what
is the town adjusting here what do they
have
um discretionary
um or discretion to
adjust oh no I think you misunderstood
me the the town doesn't adjust anything
the district does okay so what what is
the district adjusting then what's the
discretion right so there's the the
adequacy payment that's in statute and
then as as you know sometimes we send
them some money back or there are some
other grants uh there was actually a
fairly substantial one a couple years
ago and the town only sees the net not
the process so that's what the district
does on a regular basis the um here
where I live the uh we're subject to
these stabilization Grant reductions
which you would think would be a set
amount every year but that number
bounces all over the place due to
adjustments made by the state and the
town doesn't understand it this way they
would just see hey my check's lower and
rather than fight with the district ask
me how come they got less money and take
that whole you know uh relationship
thing out of it so follow up on that yes
thank you very much Mr chair so um so
the T if I've got this right the um um
the town collects the local education
property tax and the state property tax
is that correct yes and the state
Education okay correct so
so all of that collected money on behalf
of the school district which is the
political subdivision is due to the
school district is it
not oh
sure so I I guess I don't see what the
um what the what the what the mystery is
here well you would think it would be
that simple but um districts report it
to the towns in all different manners
sometimes it's just a typed up statement
sheet and the town is not always aware
of the adjustments that happened if
instead we sent the money to the town
they would be aware of it it would be
more
transparent DOA said that Department of
Education sorry I've got an act ISM itis
they uh they said that this is actually
save will save them a little overhead as
well okay let's any other questions from
the committee to uh representative
Smith not seeing any we will move on to
the next person who has to
testify representative Tanner uh
representative lad representative Tanner
um is waving yeah I see that
okay go ahead represent Tanner thank you
Mr chair thank you representative Smith
for taking my question um I I guess I'm
a little confused too because um I serve
on both the the budget committees for
the town and the school district in
Sunapee and I don't understand
how it seems like what you're saying is
the school district somehow Alters the
money that they spend or need and then
the town has
no indication of why or how that happens
and so we should give all the money to
the town so that they can figure
out where the school is spending it is
that is that what you're saying I'm I'm
really confused by it too nope I'm
saying that we the legislature changed
the amount of money that is sent out
right so the stabilization grants are on
a steady progression decreased the
impact of Charles toown is $100,000 a
year I can tell you that it has never
been $100,000 a year it's usually a
little less and nobody ever Knows Why um
and they they take their word for it so
no the district isn't like making up
numbers that is absolutely not what I'm
saying I'm saying that we make up
numbers based on the legislation that we
pass and that that isn't a bad thing we
are trying to help in most cases now if
we're successful and there have been
reductions and the reduction if you
follow that all along if we're we're
ever in a position where we can't do
that all of a sudden the bill will go up
and the municipality will probably think
the district did it or they'll call you
or they'll call me and by the time they
dial that phone they're angry um I don't
know if you know about the Charlestown
withdrawal process that just happened
neighbor turning on neighbor um the
biggest issue was of transparency
because when they said well how much did
the state send the answer is ask Jim Fen
the um Chief Financial Officer for the
district that's not helpful because some
of these folks view them as the enemy
and they shouldn't he's an accountant so
I'm trying to get away from all that the
uh if the town's mad it's because
they'll literally see the check go down
uh may I have a followup Mr chair yes so
I taught at kir sge which is also a
district that you know
has um seven towns in it and I remember
when I was teaching that there were a
couple of instances
where some of the towns delayed the
payment that they were that they were
supposed to give to the school
district is this kind of what's
Happening that that there's a delayment
of delayment delay of
payment um from the town to the school
district of money that's actually theirs
because the they think the school
district is uh withholding some of the
money that um I I know that has happened
I'm hope that this bill alleviates that
because I know in our case it was based
on a misunderstanding of what the
district had received and the town does
still have money that they pay the
district they can withhold that check
right now and the process is it goes to
court and then the town pays the money
it would be nice if that never happened
anymore and if we can make this process
more transparent and decrease the
misunderstanding my sincere hope is that
it doesn't get to that um that instead
the towns are dialing our phones and
yelling at us one more followup well can
we we do have several other folks uh
perhaps uh represent Tanner if you have
a followup to that you might be asking
one of the other uh persons that's
coming up on Deck
here um I'd like to move ahead if
there's no more te uh questions from
other reps to uh representative Smith
I'd like to call next um Carl lad Dr Lad
Association morning Mr chairman or good
afternoon Mr chairman I didn't get a
chance to have lunch because I was
shoveling my driveway but um great to
see everyone thank you than you very
much um the I understand the the
concerns that the representative uh
brings forward but I think there are a
few uh concerns here with this
particular bill um Cooperative school
districts um have especially with
multi um multi- communities within their
Cooperative school district for example
conal has upwards of a dozen um and many
others have uh multiple towns in which
they deal um they would have to try to
get payments from each one of these
towns
individually and send out a payment
rather than get one uh check from the
state to their Cooperative School
District That Could That Could seriously
impact uh their ability uh to have a
decent cash flow uh in order to pay
bills you know a lot of small districts
they have very very limited Town Offices
they may be in once or twice a month in
order to process uh payments um or to
collect checks uh this could um this
could really um impact the uh the time
frame uh for districts to get their
funds um I'm not sure that this bill
solves the problem that the sponsor is
looking to solve um it's sounds as
though it's a it's a communication issue
um between a particular school district
and a particular Community um I I just
think it adds an additional bureaucratic
layer um that really isn't
necessary um so with that um Mr chairman
I know you've got bigger fish to fry
this afternoon so um I will uh stop
there and um be certainly be open to any
questions uh thank you uh Dr Lad are
there any questions questions from the
Tanner thank you Mr chair thank you um
Dr
lad uh so my question that I was going
to follow up on the last one I'll follow
up with you so at karge like I explained
with our seven towns some of them quite
small one town uh decided they weren't
going to give us payment I on several
different occasions this happened and as
uh representative Smith had said you
know then they go to court and it delays
payment and there's a whole lot of
problems with the school functioning
keep functioning do you think that this
bill would make that situation even
worse because the all the money now is
going to go to the town so if one town
just decided to you know yank the chain
of the public school they could with
withhold the funds and all the funds
that come to them and then it would the
school would have to go to court to get
the funds yes absolutely I think that
that's um that's certainly a possibility
and it is certainly something that that
could happen hopefully it wouldn't um
but it's you know just in my community
here in in gron uh when I was
superintendent you know the the town
really had to struggle at times
especially when the mill Clos in order
to send those payments um but they did
do it um the school district is its own
political sub entity um and it does uh
does have the force of law uh behind it
and payments have to be made and I think
that um I again I think that this just
adds another layer of bureaucracy that's
not
necessary thank you very much uh again
uh rep uh Dr Lad and representative
Tanner uh further
questions thank you uh we'll go on to
the thank you very much thanks Mr
chairman we'll go on to the next person
that's testifying it'll be uh baric
Christina from the school boards
Association thank you again chairman lad
good afternoon um members of the
committee again bar Christina from the
New Hampshire school boards Association
um we're opposed to House Bill 110 um my
initial opposition was because I wasn't
quite sure what the what the purpose was
so thank representative Smith for Le
sharing why this bill was brought forth
um two concerns that nhba has most of
them have already been addressed if if
there's an issue between a school
district in a town relative to
allegations of transparency I I that's a
local issue and there needs to be there
needs to be communication between the
school district and the town and the
taxpayers um and second um the original
point I was going to make representative
Tanner you brought it up about towns
delaying payment under RSA 198 colon 5
um those are your local payments your
the money raised through local taxes to
support the school district not your
Statewide education property tax but um
in any given year nsba gets phone calls
from two three sometimes four or five um
school districts saying the town is
refusing to hand over the money the town
is handing to refuse over the money
despite the language being you know
shall and being a directive so the
school dist test to get on the BN with
their attorney the attorney has to write
a strongly worded letter they send it
over to the town and then eventually the
payment gets PA made but um at times
it's a lot of rigoll it's a lot of
unnecessary hassle for the school
district to have to go sort of Chase
down this money that is legally and
rightfully there as per the statute um
and we would have concerns that um that
could certainly be um maybe Amplified if
if this bill were going to go were to go
through so um those are my comments
happy to answer any question questions
but again we're we're in opposition to
House Bill 110 thank you very much
Barrett uh are there any questions of
the school boards association yes
us are you unmuted I am now um it took
me a bit to get back on I would have
liked to have asked this previously but
my question is since we are looking for
um dislike whatever between the school
board the school and the municipality
I'm wondering if rather than sending
them money to the municipality if we
just send a uh notification of how much
money um then there wouldn't be this
well why is it this or whatever they
would get that report sure thank thank
you for the question representative um
yeah I mean certainly forwarding some
notice from either Department of Revenue
Administration or the Department of
Education to the the town or the
municipality that wouldn't hurt um
they're they public records anyway you
know obviously if the doe is sending
something like that to the to the local
school district I mean that's going to
be a public record and and just to the
transparency piece I I want to be
careful with that word you know school
boards are accountable for every dime
that they raise and that they and that
they spend I understand there may be
questions or concerns and sometimes you
know members of community might not
understand how the taxes work or where
the money goes and flows in that's not
so much a transparency issue um so as
much as maybe just a a misunderstanding
as to how the system works because let's
face it it's complex it's not that easy
um but um
so I guess that would be my answer to
that representative thank you thank you
very much uh Barrett um I have uh
Caitlyn Davis of the Department of
Education hanging m in case we have some
questions I do have a question for
Caitlyn so thank you very much Barrett
I'd like to ask uh representa Hobson if
done oh she's in yep all
set I hope good afternoon Caitlyn
wherever you be I don't see your face
either oh I'm sorry something
happened
okay Caitlyn can you hear us I can can
everybody hear me yes that's fine great
my question to you Caitlyn is that
currently you send quarterly payments
out to the school districts uh in in
forms of 20% 20% 30%
30% um does that how soon after you that
is released does the school district or
the district have a possession of that
dollar uh could you please explain that
and also there have been some questions
regarding is it more effective to send
the money via the municipality and then
to the
districts um so as far as your first
question how quickly do the school
districts have the money in their
possession assuming a school district
has signed up for a payments from the
treasury Department um they have the
money in their bank account that day um
the treasury just processes um the
payment what our processes is we send
the information to treasury about two
weeks early they process the payment and
have the a remitted on the day that is
in law that the payment is due um school
districts that have elected to get a
papercheck obviously have a little bit
of a de delay there's maybe about 10 of
those across the state um because they
have to deal with the traditional US
Mail system um so but they have the
payment on the days that are due that
which are September 1st November 1st
January 1 and April 1st those are the
days that are in law that the payment is
required um as far as Administration um
from the Department's perspective um pay
the school district or paying a
municipality um there is no difference
um because it's just a field in the way
that we pull the data as far as um
Effectiveness or efficiency um the
department doesn't have any opinion on
that thank thank you very much uh while
we have uh Miss Davis on the on on the
horn here on the screen are there any
other questions from the
committee uh represent
luno
you're
muted thank you Mr chair I should know
better than that um and thank you thank
you Miss Davis for joining us this
afternoon um are are there are there any
uh instances where the um where the
where the state treasury is remitting
the um the the portion of the adequacy
grant due to a school district remitting
that directly to the um the member towns
instead we pay that money to a school
district so a school district could in
theory elect that a Fiscal Agent for the
school district be the be a town um but
we wouldn't have that information at the
Department of
Education okay and um and yeah followup
thanks thanks Mr chair and um and
how so so going back to to what we look
at you know money that goes to operate
schools comes from the state property
tax collected by the um municipalities
yes local education property tax
collected by the municipalities yes um
uh any remaining education grant dollars
coming from the
state and federal um federal dollars and
um and do those flow through where how
do those flow to the district so um
adequacy goes to to the district which
this bill obviously would change um the
local tax dollars go through the local
municipalities um as we've discussed
federal grants um assuming so federal
grants for the most part go directly to
the school district because the
recipient of the Federal grant per the
federal law is in fact the school
district not a municipality um so some
federal grants could certainly be
changed but the majority of our large
federal grants that we receive and
process on a regular basis like idea
Title One um all of the new s money
specifically says in the federal law
that it should be allocated to a school
district and that's why the funding goes
directly to a school district okay okay
uh thank you thank you very much Miss
Davis thank you very much uh uh
represent
tanor thank you chairman thank you
chairman lad um thank you uh Miss Davis
um just to make sure that I heard it
right that the federal funds actually go
to the doe and that the doe then
distributes those federal funds to the
directly to the school districts is that
what I understood um I mean in
technically speaking the treasury is
actually the person that cuts the check
the Department of Education doesn't have
any cut check check cutting Authority um
so similar to adequacy but the the
treasury is processing the payments um
as directed by the Department of
Education so we are directing that the
treasury process the payments to a
school district for the purposes of
adequacy and for federal grants may I
have a followup on that yes you may
thank you so when you say process it uh
that means that you kind of take in the
money and then decide uh based on the
criteria that the of the local school
district how that's going to go to the
treasury and then to the local school
district yes so for example for the
process of adequacy so the funding
formula is in law so we collect the data
and processes as as needed so we
determine how much um adequacy that we
are going to pay for each school
district and then school districts and
all vendors in the state of New
Hampshire whether it's a municipality a
school district a private contractor um
work with the treasury Department and
they have vendor codes and the vendor
codes that the Department of Education
codes and bills to are in fact who the
treasury will disperse the money to um
so so in order to um accommodate this
change as proposed in this bill the
Department of Education would just
change the vendor codes um for the for
the payments for this process thank you
uh I have one followup question for you
Caitlyn before you disappear um uh the
this bill speaks spe specifically to
adequacy Grant
distribution yes um so it would not be
uh uh controlling how Federal grant
money is distributed that would be done
in accordance with federal law working
through the Department of Education so
the grants would be coming down whenever
that money
arrives Esser money for
example um so the other question is when
we're talking adequacy education grant
are we talking about the fiscal capacity
disparity Aid as well which is a
separate Grant above them Beyond
adequacy um it is the Department's
understanding that this would be
everything that would be coming through
the grant so this would mean
stabilization this would mean fiscal
capacity this would mean the cost of an
adequate education um everything through
the um RSA 198 38 through 42 would be
the distribution that we would be
talking about and I do want to I do want
to clarify just based on your statement
previously um our understanding is that
this bill would not affect any federal
funding and it would not affect other
state aid as well so catastrophic Aid
and building aid for example uh career
and Tech education funding large state
aid funds those would be distributed as
they are normally distributed this would
only change the distribution of adequate
education grants thank you for the
clarification uh are there any other
questions of the
department thank thank you very much uh
Miss
Davis um we are I I've got three people
that have asked to speak on this or four
four people do we have another person
yes it looks like uh when uh yeah the
the superintendent I believe or kirar
Regional School District yep um I've
panelist WN Winfred fenberg Winfred
fenberg afternoon can you hear me yes
okay well thank you very much for taking
my testimony I will not take your time
because I know you have a a big hearing
this afternoon um the points that I
wanted to make were made by others
before me I think as a superintendent I
just did the numbers quickly after
talking with my business administrator
and essentially where we currently have
four uh transactions four times during
the fiscal year we get uh the payments
from the Department of Education uh that
would be replaced by really 56 um
transactions they go to seven towns in
our districts and then seven towns have
to process the checks and bring them to
us might not seem as much effort in the
electronic age but I think what Barry
Christina was saying I share that
concern as well that um even if there's
just a delay of of a month or or a few
weeks or um to process the check that
comes from the towns to the school it
requires our business administrator to
devote time and attention to that I do
not see any improvement over the current
practice um and I would ask to oppose
the bill and and not put that forward uh
thank you very much for your time um I
appreciate the the input you taken uh
thank you very much for your testimony
Winfred uh I don't see any
uh superintendent uh thank you very much
for your testimony I appreciate it thank
you you're
welcome uh do we have anybody else on
the attendees list uh uh representa
kobson or J actually we did have um
someone raised their hand from the
attendees uh looks like Timothy the
Burge um would you like to take that oh
gosh four just popped
up um would you like do we have time to
take those um
yes we do have a huge bill coming up so
uh I would ask that you bring them up uh
but let's cut it off where it is right
now
okay I see five there uh we have five
yes let's start at the top okay I'm just
gonna um allow them to talk I'm not
going to promote them to panelist and I
would also ask that they please don't
repeat something that's already been
stated either by the school schol
administrators school boards Association
winred all the any other person that's
given testimony
today okay go ahead Mr theur
or I guess based on that I have nothing
to add other than it's creating another
layer of inefficiency to a system where
it's not needed and there's no advantage
to the districts to the towns or to the
students Mr T Burge could you please uh
give are you speaking for yourself are
you a superintendent of schools or from
a particular community uh I live in
Hancock I'm speaking for myself uh as
I'm not authorized to speak on behalf of
the board but I am also a member of the
conval school district uh school board
thank you very
O'Neal hi there can you hear me yes I
apologize I wasn't able to attend
earlier and if it's starting to sound
like I'm repeating points others have
made uh give me some sort of signal if
you would but my name is Paul O'Neal I
represent myself as a resident of
stratum New Hampshire uh 32 years um I
oppose House Bill 20 in all efforts to
direct taxpayer funds intended for
public education to private educational
institutions Mr
O'Neal this is not bill
hb20 I am sorry started at 1:5 or so
yeah we're trying to get
there you have an estimate of when when
that might happen we're done these two
folks right here we'll be into it oh got
by
okay all right uh Carolyn maish maik
name can she
speak
okay Carolyn go ahead I'm sorry I
thought this was hp20 as well okay
should we just log out and then log back
in NOP you can stay right there um we do
have a list of people already set up for
hb20 so it could be
sometime yeah okay uh and Shana Kelly
I'm not sure I I don't know understand
ahead I'm also here for hb20 okay all
right I guess I guess we are
done okay so we have no further uh folks
to testify on HB 110 so I'll call this
hearing or close this hearing um in in
summary uh the sheet which I have
remember this was 8:20 this morning uh
supporting this bill there were six
opposing this bill 29 neutral um we we
had uh support from the Department that
was a neutral
presentation um so that that's it for
110 so we'll close this hearing and
we're going to open up
hb20 representative lad yes I just
wanted to bring to your attention that
uh we received an email that a fiscal
note has been uh received or sent to the
um House Education committee or
HB hb20 yep for the bill coming up I
just wanted to let you know that it's uh
it arrived in our inbox all right okay
so I'm sure we can be looking that as we
go through this is it in the inbox of
all committee members that's my
understanding thank
you okay with that we are going to open
up the hearing for HB 20 hb20 is a bill
accounts
and with that I'd like to invite uh
representative Sher Packard speaker of
the
house
Speaker are you unmuted okay great he
is
all set Mr chairman yes we're ready uh
Mr Speaker okay thank
you uh well good afternoon and uh I hope
the rest of your day is going pretty
good um thank you Mr chairman and
members of the
committee uh I'd like to introduce um
House Bill 20 which is the education
savings account uh as most of you know
this was um former speaker
representative hinches uh bill Bill and
with the untimely passing of our former
speaker I took over as the uh Prime
sponsor of the
bill um I'm not going to get into a lot
of the detail Mr chairman um I will
leave that up to somebody that's far
more U educated on the nuances of this
bill than I am at this point all I can
say is that um it's time for New
Hampshire families to
that have paid into the public education
system and under this horrible disease
that were're under
covid-19 uh I firmly believe this is a a
good solution for the families of New
Hampshire to help the in the best way to
educate their children um education
Freedom accounts ensure and support a
high quality flexibility and unique
publicly funded education for all New
Hampshire students and I think that
anybody
in this state that wants to make sure
that our kids have the best education
possible should and I hope will support
this bill uh with that Mr chairman I um
um I'll let you move on and uh I'm sure
there's experts that are far more
knowledgeable on this than I am I just
want to uh let everybody know that uh we
are 100% behind this bill and uh I hope
that we can get this thing p as soon as
possible send it over to Senate and then
to the governor uh with that M with that
Mr chairman go ahead go ahead I'm sorry
well I I just wanted to thank you very
much uh uh representative uh package uh
speaker of the house uh we appreciate
all your work and time and effort you're
doing to try and help the entire State
uh what we'll do is that to go through
the specifics in this bill the contents
and the intent of that bill will hand
the Baton off from uh the speaker to
representative cordelli to walk through
this bill uh Page by page so folks can
uh understand uh a little bit more about
the bill uh are there any questions to
of the
speaker not seeing any oh yes there's
one question from representative
Woodcock thank you um Mr chairman Mr
speaker thank you for taking my question
just just a statement you made you said
uh
just right now that this guarantees high
quality education for all New Hampshire
that well representative I feel that the
more avenues that our children have the
get thank you Mr speaker repesent luno
thank you very much Mr chair m M uh yeah
uh uh Mr chairman I uh I think that at
this point I'll
[Music]
decline okay so the speaker has declined
uh further questioning I think the
questions that are being asked can very
much be asked of Representative cordelli
which is going to uh explain the bill at
this point in
time representative
cordelli uh thank you Mr chairman uh for
the record uh I am Glenn cordelli and I
represent Tuftonboro molten Boro and
sandwich in the beautiful Lakes
Region uh
hb20 as the speaker mentioned is the
Richard Dick Hench education Freedom
accounts Bill and is named after our
late former speaker he championed this
legislation he wanted all New Hampshire
children to have the opportunity for the
best possible
education and that's what this bill
about the
kids today you will hear from lobbyists
from people who have studied the subject
and from parents you'll hear facts
misinformation and
emotion those watching can come to their
own
decisions but the 20 of us on the
committee will have to come to our own
decision and then we'll have to vote on
this legislation and I'll start by going
through uh the bill
um I hope um maybe the committee members
have it in front of them and uh
hopefully it will be uh somewhat clear
to everyone else uh
watching um hb20 starts with the
definitions and probably the most
important one to touch on is the
eligible
student and any child who is a resident
of this state who is eligible to enroll
in a public school qualifies for an
education Freedom
account and that includes but is not
limited
to students who are in a school now that
is in either remote or hybrid learning
mode uh we've heard stories about the
impact of remote learning on uh many of
our students and we will hear more from
parents I'm sure also included in this
uh subset are children who are in a
school with uh an assessment proficiency
below
40% uh siblings of children who have
education Freedom
accounts and uh just note that um
students in the Special School District
to the Department of Corrections are not
eligible for these
accounts uh going on to the uh
discussion of the program
itself um as was briefly discussed in
the last uh Bill uh the treasurer is the
person who will transfer
money from um the treasury based on the
adequate education grant amount and any
differentiated Aid uh for which the
child would uh normally uh be eligible
and would be currently going to the
public school uh
District uh there's a reference there to
an RSA um which basically indicates that
the payments are made on a quarterly
basis
uh excuse me um parents of the student
agree to a number of different things
and they
include um excuse me they first touch on
the expenses the qualifying expenses
that the parents agree to uh adhere to
and those include uh tuition and fees at
a private school tuition or fees at a
nonpublic learning program uh tutoring
Services textbooks curriculum
instructional material could be computer
hardware or internet connectivity which
is so important these days uh education
soft Ware uh fees for a national uh
assessment tuition or fees at uh Career
Technical School Educational Services
therapies which could be occupational
therapy Physical Therapy even Equine
Therapy uh
also uh fees for transportation if
student parents are allowed to make uh
payments for any of these um
expenses that are not covered by the uh
EFA the EFA the education Freedom
account remains in effect until the
parent withdraws from the program until
the student graduates from high school
or the EFA is closed because of Any
misuse of funds
uh next I wanted to touch on the
application
process um the parent would apply to the
scholarship
organization uh to open an
account and the scholarship approves uh
the uh application uh if the parent
agrees
to provide the education for the student
and the core knowledge domains of math
Etc the parent agrees to use the funds
just for those qualifying expenses that
used the uh going down on page four the
EFA student may choose to stop receiving
an EFA funding and enroll fulltime in a
public
school uh just underneath that um you'll
see that enrolling in a full-time excuse
me enrolling as a full-time student in a
resident District Public School requires
suspension of the uh account and um
there was a little wording left out in
that um section and that the
intent is that student may enroll in a
outof district public school and use
their EFA funds to do that uh but cannot
enroll in their resident School District
using those EFA
funds uh as we mentioned before the
scholarship organization will manage um
the uh student accounts and they have a
number of
responsibilities uh that are outlined in
the bill as well um and that's uh
including an updated list of eligible
education service providers uh providing
parents with information on what the
allowable uses of their account
is or
are um they the scholarship organization
shall ensure also that parents of
students with disabilities receive
notice uh about the program and what the
uh laws are related to uh for instance
parental placement
uh in a in a private school um there are
federal regulations involved in uh a
child leaving the public school um and
uh those um we can talk about um along
the way and there'll be others
testifying about that as
well uh the scholarship organization um
in conjunction with the Department uh
determines what the uh qual ification of
the student are for uh any
differentiated
Aid
um the for the
services the or scholarship
organization uh will receive a maximum
of 10% for uh the administration of the
program uh the scholarship organization
from those funds will Implement an
electronic system system to provide for
uh use of the
funds and we'll be hearing more about
that later in the testimony as well uh
the scholarship organization is also
required uh to do an annual
audit
um and if the scholarship
organization uh finds any intentional
and substantial misuse of funds uh they
have the authority
uh to um make the parent or student
ineligible as well as um it's mandated
uh that if they do find that misuse they
report that to the department and also
to the Attorney General's
office
um the uh scholarship organization shall
also um uh if they find that uh a
service provider has failed to live up
to the promises of the services that are
to be provided they may bar that service
program uh going on um the uh
scholarship
organization and any contractors all
would agree to provide excuse me to um
Pro
um to comply with that's the word I was
trying to think of thank you uh comply
with the uh state and federal laws
regarding uh student
privacy uh the student the scholarship
organization has the
responsibility also to provide an annual
report to the legislature and the
legislation outlines um a number of the
uh items that are to be included in the
report and that one of them on one di
menion U is a survey of uh eligible
parents who are controlling those
accounts for their children um and uh we
have seen uh information from our own
tax scholarship program and from Esa
programs around the country um about uh
that parental uh satisfaction
information um unfortunately we don't
see that for uh other schools in New
Hampshire um also established in this
legislation is a uh parental advisory
commission that will um discuss and go
over uh improvements to the program uh
and there will be uh members of the
legislature um as well as parents
included in that however legislative
members um are not to be voting members
of that Commission
um there are requirements for anyone who
signs up to provide services to uh
children with EFA
accounts um they are detailed in the
bill uh however uh it is specified that
they will remain
um any requirement that they adhere to
um other uh government um
regulations
um there is the one other thing I wanted
to mention a legislative oversight
committee uh that is
established um so there is legislative
review on an ongoing basis uh to monitor
the program and recommend any uh changes
to the program um that are needed and I
just just wanted to um that's pretty
much the bill um but since I won't be
able to um question other um
participants I just want to mention two
things U
independently um we've had a number of
uh emails uh talking about increases in
local taxes because of this uh bill um
but I'll point out that it's Pro Ed that
over the next 10
years enrollment is going to decline by
over 20,000 students this bill aside so
schools are going to have to learn to
adjust
um will tax increases be made based on
the normal um enrollment uh decline um
it seems though with bills like this
suddenly all costs are fixed when there
is a decline due to a choice bill um and
secondly
um we've heard the argument that private
schools discriminate while public
schools have to accept all students but
it's not true it's not
true
um kids in Manchester cannot go to
school in Bedford there's zip code
discrimination uh many families can't
for to live in molten Boro for instance
there's wealth
discrimination uh we have an open
enrollment School statute that says
specifically it's
194d schools May select pupils on the
basis of aptitude acade or academic
achievement and finally I've been
working with a a mother who's not even
in my district who has a special needs
child who was
bullied uh severely in her school uh
because of her disability called names
um after repeated attempts to resolve
the problem the school board under the
best interest manifest education
hardship said go ahead find another
public school to
attend she was denied access to two
local public school systems denied
access and her child struggling with
remote learning where she is is and
afraid to go back to her resident public
school because of the bullying has
started to cut herself and has talked
about
suicide so the fact that public schools
accept all children it's not true it's
not true um and I think um the testimony
that we'll have from parents will be
very telling this afternoon and with
that I'd be glad to take any questions
thank you very much uh representative
cordelli are there any questions
representative Miler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr represent
cordelli for taking my questions uh
let's be real clear here the intent of
this hearing is to get
clarification of this particular bill it
is not the intent of the hearing to
debate the bill at this point in time
that will come forward when we deal with
it in executive session so I want to
just be clear on that as we go
forward this bill on uh will probably be
one of the most significant bills that
this committee will look at uh this year
so Mr chairman I I I've got numerous
questions here but I want to just focus
on three questions at this point in
time uh representative cordelli um this
bill basically takes taxpayer dollars
and provides for vouchers for parents as
unlike the deferred business tax program
that we have and another program where
kids can get scholarships from that
that's not taxpayer money this is
taxpayer
money so would you concur that I as I
look at this
bill I checked with
ECS which is the education Commission of
the state which is a non-party
nonpartisan group that basically tracks
education
policies and I found that there are
about about 12 States that have voucher
programs but each of these states has a
qualifier might be the student might
have to have an IEP maybe a disability
maybe from an impoverished community may
have a problem and struggling with h
with the school but there's a
qualifier very similar to the qualifiers
that were in Senate Bill
193 now if I understand this right
representative cordelli this bill has no
qualifier
whatsoever and as a result of that this
would be the first
Universal Voucher Program if if adopted
this would be the first Universal
Voucher Program without any
qualifications in the country would you
would agree with
that thank you for the question and a
couple of points uh first of all um this
is an education savings account bill
it's there areow no vouchers provided
for in this bill so I think you have to
compare it to the five states with
education savings accounts bills we're
not talking vouchers here even though
that's uh a term that uh opponents like
to throw around uh there are five states
with education savings account bill as I
mentioned um and it would be the
broadest of of any of those um there are
approximately 15 other states currently
that have
legislation um related to providing uh
funding to follow the child um rather
than go to directly to the school system
I have not looked at all of those and I
do not know what the qualifications are
u in those uh current pieces of
legislation thank you well we you know I
you can call it whatever you want to but
for me if it walks like a duck quacks
like a duck it's a duck and I'm going to
continue to I'm going to continue call
it a voucher the second question is this
and this is very serious question oh
actually all my questions are serious
but uh but this bill doesn't have any
anti-discrimination language in it
whatsoever so if for example I had a
child if I wanted to send my child to
let's say a Christian
school but my child was gay or
transgender it's my understanding that
my child with that kind of designation
would not be able to attend a Christian
School if in fact they had policies
around uh gender identity is that
correct um excuse me um uh first of all
um the uh there are federal
anti-discrimination laws that apply to
private schools as as well as public
schools so there are discrimination laws
that do apply um in terms of uh I know
I've talked to um Catholic School
Headmasters and I think um we'll hear
from some uh today uh about that um but
uh I believe that they all try to take
uh children um uh of all uh races uh
Creeds um I do not know of uh any
instances um for discrimination about uh
um gay students um and you know perhaps
you do but but I do not yeah well
currently there are there are there is a
history of of transgender and gay
students being denied from particular
schools so the next question I have and
this will be the final one then I'll let
others ask questions is it correct that
once the treasurer has to OS ited the
state funds into the student account and
then those funds are allocated to the
education institution of choice that the
state has no further obligation to
ensure that the student is receiving an
adequate education according to the
state laws and standards that we have
and there's no obligation for the
student to take any uh Statewide
assessment test that other students take
in public schools that basically track
student performance is that
correct um once the money is deposited
in the account it does not have to be
spent at any particular school it can be
used as a a vehicle to customize the uh
education of a child uh there is no
requirement to take a state assessment
um in this bill um it has better means
of assessment and that's uh uh that's
parental
um
accountability a par a parent uh can
walk take their dollars with them if
their child is not getting the proper
education I think that's a better means
of accountability than it we have in the
public schools where and for the most
part uh parents are unable to leave if
they're child is not getting uh
satisfactory
education the scre so the so the answer
answer can I continue could I finish
sure thank you um if in a public school
if the uh school is not
performing the only accountability is
that they get more
money so I think that there is a a large
myth around the subject of
accountability I'm I'm sorry to
interrupt you I thought you were I
thought you had includ that's okay so so
the answer to my question is yes
that that although the state is
responsible so to provide an adequate
education for students in the state an
individual who chooses to do this the
state then has no further obligation nor
tracking of where that student is that
the answer to that question is yes then
correct the um scholar yes or no
question uh I don't think it's a yes or
no question the scholarship organization
tracks that student tracks the expenses
uh of that student and reports back to
the uh State on an annual basis that the
accountability is with the parents as it
should be for child's education I yield
my time thank
you thank you very much uh
representative cordelli further
questions representative Woodcock thank
you Mr chairman uh represent Celli thank
you for taking my questions I have a
couple of them that you spurred by
listening to your talk I have hard time
falling on my computer and the the uh
committee hasn't provided any hard
copies which I I sent to you and your
chairman three times now but beyond that
if I could resp if I could answer that I
we we did get an email um or I'm not
sure about an email but I know I've had
conversations they have had delays with
the printing of the bills um but they
are trying as best they can to get bills
out to everybody well that's that's
irrelevant to everybody let's try to sck
to the Bill and and do Mr chairman thank
you in in your dialogue a few minutes
ago you mentioned that that some of the
therapies is that correct yes okay so if
if I can follow that up with this so do
the therapies have to be predicated
early on by having a an IEP or some
other some other program in the public
school that said that they need
thies uh the bills um specifies
therapies um including occupational
Physical Therapy therapies like that I
understand that was my question my
question was do I have to have had any
any prior recommendation of therapies
out of an IEP or anything no so if I am
a parent and I have a hyperactive child
for say and I believe that they could
use um mediation meditation therapy or
yoga therapy or swimming therapy I think
he said equin when I heard it so I could
enroll my students my child in any of
these programs to help them with a high
activity if I thought that might work on
taxpayers from this account um I think
if um a uh
School excuse me has a child who has uh
suffered from hyperactivity or things
like that they might try uh various
remedies themselves I think uh in this
case the parent can look at remedies
also so my qu so the answer to my
question is if a parent thinks the child
is hyperactive and they're involved in
this program then they can they can have
them do any program they feel is
adequate
um I don't know if I'd agree about any
program but certainly from the allowable
expenses yes and they will be uh ongoing
monitoring um of those allowable
expenses and report by expense well okay
if I may just a follow so I don't waste
everybody else's time um just the
question you you indicated I want to
make sure I'm clear you said that under
these funding a student could be in a
public school and exit the public school
uh receive these funds and then reenroll
in a different Public School using the
fund if they chose to is that correct
understand what you said not reenroll
but they could enroll in an out of
District school okay gu a minute so my
question goes back to actually some of
your bullying pieces there does the
other public school is our district are
youngster excuse me um I I think um with
within reason um and within space
limitations um they should be uh taking
that that child um uh if someone moves
into your District
now um there is no provision for not
enrolling them in the school so with
within space limitations I think they
they should be
enrolled if I may just for so Mr reell
so your answer is no because there's no
you're saying they should they may they
possibly the reality is there's no
requirement for them to go to another
school district and be accepted there
there's nothing in the says that is that
correct even though you just said that
they could um there are several inst
several locations in the bill where we
have to um uh have clarifying language
about um enrolling in and out of
District uh public
school okay so the answer is
no okay so my my final question the
final question at this point for me
representative representative how many
questions you gonna have because we got
set three Mr chairman well from now on
we're going to keep everything to two
Okay a followup and that's it so that we
can share the wealth okay well this is a
pretty important bill uh Mr chairman um
brother just just my own my own learn
identification I'm reading about the
scholarship
organization that is going to be
overseeing the distribution and the
accountability of the distribution not
necessarily the accountability of the
economic success but the accountability
of the distribution of the funds as they
align with the requirements of the bill
um so and I think I I read that or that
it was a they have up an up to and I
don't know what the minimum is but up to
a 10% uh cut back on that for the
administrative cost to do that so is
that is that am I right so far yes okay
so my question is then this since this
if this bill goes through and this is
going to this is going to be uh huge
money so is it going to be an open
opportunity for for other vendors to
petition to get a chance at this this
grant to oversee this to oversee this
funding piece um within the state are
other are other uh private uh wealth
management people uh meets the
requirements or this just a closed op
close shop uh scholarship
organizations um are validated by the
Department of Revenue uh under current
statute I understand that I'm saying but
since it's a new organization does it
guess the question is I there's no
there's no restriction in this bill on
um the number of scholarship
organizations um or anything like that
thank you Mr chairman I I yield after my
three questions there appreciate your
questions repr none no no
noes thank you Mr chair um I have two
questions uh my first question to you
and thank you representative cordelli
for taking these questions sure um does
this bill include students who are
currently being
homeschooled yes um and under this bill
could a homeschool
parent apply for the voucher um receive
the voucher uh homeschool the child and
then decide that it things aren't
working well send them back send them to
the sunding
district uh but that money that's in the
voucher this the fund the voucher fund
never gets replaced to the school is
that correct it gets held with the
parent um the account suspended but if
the parent wants to use that future uh
time they can with the same child is
that true um with the education safe
savings account um a homeschooler um
would be eligible for funds um we'll
probably have discussion about it um a
little later but um it's it's really a a
new category they're the EFA student um
and they are eligible to use those funds
um how they wish which would include um
enrolling um in a public school but use
those funds um for the tuition at that
public school
and that would be monitored by the
department just just a clarifying I
asked if if they re if that homeschooler
went to their sending district and
didn't actually go to an an another
District but uh the parent let's say in
Newport decided that they couldn't
handle the homeschooling and decide even
after they received this voucher and
then decided to send the child to the
Newport school system which has already
lost the money uh that was given to the
through the voucher uh but that money
never comes back to Newport schools it
remains in the account so that the
parent if they choose to take them back
out of Newport school for some reason um
and homeschool them again they can use
that money that's in that account is
that true if if the student was
homeschooling in the Newport area um the
district wouldn't lose any money for
that uh student because they wouldn't be
receiving any money for that student
since they're hom school they're not in
enrolled in that
school but would they I'm I'm sorry but
would they receive if the student then
enrolled for a short period of time
let's say four months because the
homeschooling wasn't working
out um then they that account would
still be in the parents purview and uh
could be used let's say for summer
school if when that that school year was
over um I believe so if I understand
your question correctly
Mullen thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative cordelli for taking
my questions um I am looking at the
section of the bill towards the end that
is entitled independence of Education
Service
Providers there are two statements in
that section that um I I I want to get
some clarification
on one is uh section two that says
Education Service Providers shall be
given maximum freedom to provide for the
educational needs of educ EFA students
without governmental control and I'm
wondering if you could Define for me
what you mean or what the bill means not
that you're the author of the bill but
uh what the bill means by governmental
control
um uh I think the intent there is um uh
not to over regulate uh Education
Service Providers um whether that is a
uh a tutor or a private uh education
institution so when you talk about so
just for clarity sake um governmental
control
meaning state laws law that kind of
thing well um if if there are federal
laws um related to or state laws related
to the service that they're providing um
this is not a um get out of jail free
card in terms of abiding by those laws
as we talked about with uh State uh
privacy laws for instance for
students is there could if I could uh
representative is there a mechanism in
the bill to delineate between those
state and federal laws that somebody
would have to follow and those state and
federal laws that somebody
wouldn't I I don't think that there is
anything in the bill saying that there
are any state and federal laws um that
uh you do not have to AB abide
by okay yeah that was my that that was
my own personal interpretation of
without governmental control my second
uh the second statement that I uh was if
I could if I could just follow up I I
think it's more in terms of Regulation
rather than uh state or federal law at
that
point okay well I'm sure we'll there'll
be much more discussion about that as
the bill moves forward uh section five
of that same uh that same area no
education service provider shall be
required to alter its Creed practices
admissions policy or curriculum in order
to accept payment
from the
EFA um I was struck by your discussion
about
eligibility because it sounds to me like
this section of the independence of Ed
service providers
um allows these Educational Service
Providers to determine who they're going
to admit and not admit and I'm wondering
if you could explain to me what role
somebody's Creed would have in whether
or not um a student was eligible or
enrolled in their
program for instance a religious school
is not going to have to um uh change
their um their whole concept or uh uh
way of doing business or um uh religious
views um based on uh accepting a student
um with an EFA account
um they have they will maintain their
religious freedoms for instance and
their uh religious
viewpoints and um excuse me um how many
questions are we going here for an
individual how many are you on now
repres that was two section two section
five that was just number two Mr Mr
chairman and I and I I I am holding true
to what I said I uh I will not be go
beyond this I'm just curious about uh
non-discrimination and how uh that
dovetails with this section that's all
thank you go ahead that that was it
representative cordelli how do you see
non-discrimination laws dovetailing with
this
section um non-discrimination laws um
remain in effect
um and uh should be uh abided by by any
educational service
provider thank you very much thank you
very much uh further
questions representative lad yes it's uh
we're expecting the commissioner to come
on yes this is where you know the the
commissioner just has a few moments in
his schedule today to speak and he was
going to speak to some fiscal
matters associated with this so what I'd
like to do is take a a break from
representative cordelli go to the
commissioner and then if you somebody
has a few more questions ask of
Representative cordelli we can come back
to that is that that okay with folks out
there okay let's go to it uh do you have
uh representative edbl available I am
looking for him um maybe he's calling in
by phone I'm wondering if he could put
his hand up
um that would be star go well underneath
up uh that's his administrative
assistant oh okay so Angela Adams is the
oh okay sorry about
Louise okay let's try that um
commissioner edel blue welcome to the
education
committee you are muted I believe oh
there y
welcome uh good afternoon everyone and
thank you for um allowing me to join you
for a few moments here to uh share some
thoughts about this bill as well as if
we have time respond to a few questions
um I apologize it was difficult to find
me as Angela Adams but I am for the
record Frank edbl the commissioner of
the Department of Education um in New
Hampshire um I expect that you will have
a h a thorough and uh and a very
spirited um Committee hearing today and
get lots of good input into this um I
encourage everyone to uh consider that
we share a common goal of Bright Futures
for all of our students so whatever your
perspective is on this particular piece
of legislation we all know that we want
all New Hampshire students to be able to
succeed in life and grow up to be strong
New Hampshire
citizens I just will share a couple of
thoughts um before if you want I can
switch into some questions but I think
it's important um for everyone to
understand the context for this uh this
P particular piece of legislation so we
we've got RSA 1931 which is our truancy
law and that enumerates that students or
children in the state of New Hampshire
between the ages of six and 18 are
required to be enrolled in an education
program here in New Hampshire today we
have three such education programs we
have our public school system and that
includes our traditional Public Schools
as well as our Charter Public Schools
we have non-public schools and those are
non-public schools that are
programmatically approved by the
department or they're approved for
attendance and we have a third category
of home education student a student
today between ages of six and 18 is
required to be enrolled in one of these
types of education programs and by doing
so they are not considered
truant as I understand this particular
piece of legislation you are creating a
fourth category of Education option for
a student and that is an education
Freedom account student and I think it's
important to understand that context
because it really becomes responsive to
many of the questions that I have heard
um you know out there and individuals
who have reached out to me because of a
lack of understanding of this governance
structure around the education system we
ask questions that really are not gerine
to the bill itself because the way that
this is structured many of our laws then
cover those areas that are otherwise
areas of
concern I would now just as well like to
spend a little bit of time the
department put out a fiscal analysis
relative to this bill uh the conclusion
ion of that fiscal analysis is that
there is significant cost savings to New
Hampshire taxpayers as a result of the
enactment of this particular piece of
legislation now at a very high level and
really in a in a simplified version of
trying to understand how it could be
that New Hampshire taxpayers would
benefit from the passage of this bill we
need to understand that a typical the
the cost of educating a typical student
today is about
$20,000 per year an EFA student on the
other hand order Mr
chair what's what's your question point
of order um if if we're GNA be going
through a um a fiscal note shouldn't
that be presented by the um legislative
budget
assistant we're going to have in this
particular situation that done through
the department the department is the one
who developed
the financial reports which go over to
the LBA so the department is responsible
for providing the information the
commissioner is providing go ahead Mr
commissioner thank you um so again just
to reiterate the typical cost to educate
a student in New Hampshire is about
$20,000 per year an EFA student when a
parent chooses this option for their
children will crost approximately $5,000
per year so again on a simplified basis
every student currently attending a
public school who adopts an EFA the
taxpayers have the opportunity to save
$155,000 per student now I recognize
that that is a highlevel uh analysis but
it is a simple way to kind of wrap our
heads around the idea that taxpayers can
be the beneficiaries of an Innovative
program like this in the analysis that
we released there were a number of
different assumptions and I would like
to just uh explain or weigh in on a
couple of those um one of the first key
assumptions that we have really is that
when a student leaves uh the public
school they know the school itself no
longer has the obligation to educate
that child it does not mean that um
immediately uh everybody is going to be
able to uh change their budgets and so
we have balanced that because that's one
of the objections that we often hear
simply because a student leaves a
traditional public school doesn't mean
that the uh school system has the
ability to immediately adjust its budget
so in our analys we have afforded
schools generous amounts of time up to
three years to be able to adjust their
cost structures to reflect the fact that
some students may decide that they want
to adopt one of these uh education
Freedom
accounts another key driver in the model
is really how many of our students might
actually adopt these types of programs
uh there is a an argument that is made
that I think does a disservice to our
strong public schools here in New
Hampshire and that argument is that
there will be students fleeing from our
systems when in fact this is not what we
anticipate to be the case because our
traditional Public Schools our public
charter schools offer students many
opportunities to receive an excellent
education so when we modeled this
program what we did is we went out to a
state that had the most similar program
Arizona and we used their adoption rates
in terms of how their program played out
when it was first adopted um and
sometimes when you look at those numbers
it it seems contradictory um I had one
person ask me about the adoption rates
well why wouldn't more students adopt an
EFA and in fact I think this is a very
important sociological question why
wouldn't someone take advantage of some
perceived benefit that is being offered
to them and why indeed if we take a look
in at uh one of our snap programs
nationally only 29% of eligible
participants in their lowest benefit
level
participate if I take for example my
temporary Aid to needy families or my
TANF on a national level we only have
25% participation and these are cash
benefit programs if I look at all of the
uh Choice programs across the state
there are 21 million students who are
eligible to participate in these very
various Choice programs in if in other
states and yet only 1.3 million students
or 6% ultimately participate and you
have to understand that these are
programs that have been around in many
cases for decades and then if I look
closer to home here in New Hampshire in
our scholarship program which has been
in place since
2012 we have 48,000 students who are
eligible to participate in that program
and yet we have around 500 students who
parti ipate in that program and so I
think it's important to consider that we
in the process of debating this bill we
don't disparage our public schools by
indicating that somehow because we
create an option for students who For
Whom the current system is not meeting
their needs are going to see significant
losses we offer a strong education
system here in New Hampshire and this is
a program that will help meet the needs
of of students for whom that system is
not working and there's another factor
that I just want to uh mention here and
I see representative luno and
representative Miler on the call and uh
both of these gentlemen were involved in
much of the work around the school
funding commission and one of the themes
that came out of that commission was for
the state to play a greater role in
contributing to the cost of Education
and provide local property taxpayers
relief and in fact that is a concentric
circle and a overlap relative to this
program where you will see the state
leaning in and providing support to
public education for our students here
in New Hampshire and providing broad
really taxpayer savings um at the local
property tax level and so I think that
we should look at at all of the
activities that are taking place in the
state how these various initiatives are
contributing and uh moving in some of
the same directions maybe not everything
exactly alignment but there is certainly
uh overlap there that's important to
consider so again I thank you for
allowing me to join you today I know
that you will be receiving much
testimony today from a lot of different
individuals um and I hope that you are
able to get all of the information that
you need so that again we can continue
forward with our shared common goal of
making sure that we offer all of our
students here in New Hampshire Bright
Futures and so thank you representative
lad for allowing me to come and spend
some time with you thank you very much
commissioner are there any questions for
the commissioner uh represent
lean uh thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you Mr commissioner for coming to
speak to us um before you join the call
there was a question on what happens if
a student returns to their local public
school and I didn't know if you might
provide any guidance on how quickly the
adequacy funds would return to that
school for the
student um certainly so um if a student
my understanding of the way that this
bill is structured if a student elects
to have an education Freedom account at
the department we would be required to
fund that using the same schule that we
fund our adequacy payments to our
traditional public schools and that
means that we make four payments during
the year so if a student were to elect
an education Freedom account and they
were to leave partway through that year
so they don't finish out the year and
then my understanding is that those
education Freedom account dollars would
be returned to the education trust fund
to be able to be used for other
educational options that student who
returns to the public school school what
we have to understand is when a student
adop we pay in AAR for students in our
public education system so if a student
is attending a public school in year one
and in year two they adopt an EFA during
year two this public school is being
paid for that student even though they
are not responsible for the education of
that student when that student leaves
and takes an EFA in that next and then
and then they reenroll then in that
subsequent year they would again be paid
for that student because we pay iners it
would only be if they stayed out for the
entire period uh that the school would
not receive funding for
them thank you very much uh are there
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
and thank you commissioner um uh first
of all uh make no mistake that that this
voucher Bill does not flow from the
findings nor the recommendations of the
school funding commission so I think
that has to be U stated right up front
and any sort of representation that this
is this is a result of that work would
be uh would be totally inaccurate so um
my uh my my first question to you um Mr
commissioner is um is where does New
Hampshire stand right now in terms of
nationally in terms of uh student
outcomes yeah so let me just clarify my
point representative luno I was not
stating in the beginning that the school
funding commission itself was either
making a statement about this bill or
endorsing it but simply observing having
read both documents that there are
similarities in terms of the objectives
whether it is through the school funding
commission or through this bill and I
just was pointing out that overlap
between those two items well I want to
get to those objectives in a minute but
but um but let let's start with where
New Hampshire stands right now
nationally in terms of student outcomes
if we could yeah so I will I'm happy to
weigh in on that so New Hampshire is one
of the stronger
performing education systems there are a
number of different measures but we
generally rank in three to five in terms
of the the status of what we see but New
Hampshire also has what is a troubling
development and a troubling Trend that
is not just unique to New Hampshire but
is unique across the country it has been
observed in States across the country as
well as in the BAGI and the nape
assessment and what you find is that our
high performing students are increasing
in their educational attainment so that
may be the top 10% or the top quartile
and the students at the bottom quartile
are F falling further behind so what we
are doing is we're creating an education
Gap and it is principally driven around
those the students ability to perform
and what we know from the research in
particular is that economically
disadvantaged students are falling
further behind in New Hampshire but we
also know from research that when we
create alternative Pathways for
education for those students they have
an opportunity to close those
educational attainment gaps and so when
I look at this particular Bill what I
see is an opportunity to create options
for those students to find to seek out
to find an educational environment in
which they can Thrive and in which they
can succeed and that will allow us and
help us to close this disparity Gap that
we see growing in New Hampshire and
should be troubling for all of
us so uh follow I've got there's a few
that are all connected here Mr chair
thanks so in that bottom quartile that
you referenced Mr commissioner where
would the largest um um group of those
um students um be coming from I mean
you've seen the student outcome data so
right so when you say grouping I just
want to make sure that I
understand um so at the state we report
what we call subgroup information um and
is that the type of information no
talking about school district in terms
of school districts what the group is
outcome right yeah so what you find is
it's not a school district phenomena in
fact what you will find is that there is
very little
correlation um relative to the school
district so much as educational
attainment is correlated to economic
status principally in New Hampshire what
we find is that our economically
disadvantaged students perform less well
if in our education system and that is
true for a student that is in the in a
wealthy District or a student in a not
wealthy District the common factor the
common theme is that students who come
from economically disadvantaged
circumstances have difficulty accessing
the education system as we have
architected
it thank you very much commissioner are
I'm Mr chair no I I would like to see
some other questions Mr chair the the
the commissioner actually specifically
me because both of
you good work you did in the and and you
know and obviously where I'm where I'm
going with this is um is the um
District
there I'm here representative I I I
don't hear repr
luno yeah yeah so sorry my connection's
cutting in and
out
so so my my question is is what is this
program going to be doing for the 13,000
students that attend the Manchester
School District which is among the
lowest performing student outcomes in
the state and um highest um uh highest
uh free and reduced price lunch
eligibility in the state which is
obviously a proxy for um for low um
economic means and uh and some of the
lowest um uh per student um um uh school
funding in the state what what is this
going to do for those 13,000 kids yes so
thank you for that question
representative luno and I think even in
your question you point out the issue so
it is true that we have over 13,000
students in Manchester some of whom are
thriving and some of whom are performing
very well and reaching really strong
educational attainment through their
efforts in that school system and
they're receiving an excellent education
but we also know that there are a number
of economically disadvantaged students
in that system and as you point out in
your question M you've I think you if
I'm articulating this correctly you
described manchest Manchester as one of
the lowest performing academically uh in
the state and having the highest you
know economically disadvantaged student
ratio and so what I would tell you is
that that is the factor it's not the
geography of Manchester it is the
economically disadvantaged factor that
affects it but there if you take that
same economically disadvantaged student
and you place them in Bedford they too
will struggle with the current
educational system that we have and so
what this program will do is where those
students are not able to attain success
in Manchester we are allowing them the
option to be able to seek out an
educational setting in which they can
succeed and in which they can Thrive and
that is really again going back back to
my first statement about the common goal
that we all share about Bright Futures
for our students so that is really how
this will help those students to be able
to reach those
attainments thank thank you very much
commissioner uh commissioner I
understand that you had a 230
appointment I do thank you yes and we're
we're hammering in on that so um I I
think that we'll say thank you very much
for taking the time out to work with us
today today and have a a good rest of
the afternoon thank you yeah uh is
representative cordelli still there and
uh representative cordelli we you are
still in that uh testifying mode I'm
just returning to in case there's
committee members that have some
questions ask of you if not we have a
long Docket in front of
us uh representative Ellison uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for taking qu I have two questions that
I think will be answered very quickly uh
one relates to the separation of church
and state uh will a constitutional
amendment to the New Hampshire
Constitution have to be in place in
order for funds from an EFA to go to a
religious school uh thank you for the
question uh no is the answer uh in June
there was a US Supreme Court case
Espinosa versus Montana Department of
Revenue uh which settled that question
and basically
invalidated uh State um no Aid or Blain
amendments as they are called and you'll
be having further testimony from an
expert on that I do
believe second question this is a
hypothetical if a family's earning
$300,000 a year they have a student at
Philip Philips exitor Academy where the
tuition is $58,000 a year are they
eligible for the $5,000 Grant under this
program um would be eligible the
question is whether they're going to be
bothered taking it I think in all the
programs you've seen around the country
um it is not U the wealthy families but
the lower and middle inome families that
are taking advantage of these programs
because of their
need followup Mr chairman yes so if they
requested the money they would get
it uh there would be nothing um to uh
prevent that thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much Mr Ellis represent Ellison uh
represent LE thank you Mr chairman and
uh thank you representative cordelli for
taking the questions before I proceed I
just want to State my Declaration of
intent which is that I do intend to
participate in the discussion on
hb20 as based upon uh my compliance with
the ethics committee's informal
resolution of complaint 2019 d
02 thank you um I have just the
questions are very specific here and
it's just a small two or three of them
that's it um on lines 28 to 29 on page
six um I think it states that the um
scholarship organization can accept
gifts and grants Etc and um I don't
believe there's any restriction on that
is is that
correct correct okay thank you um and
then on page eight lines six and seven
it states that the scholarship
organization um May approve Education
Service Providers on its own initiative
so does the scholarship organization
then am I reading it correctly that they
are the organization that approves of an
education service
provider uh
yes uh but there are uh reviews on that
and uh if there is any um uh misuse
um funds for instance um they would be
reported to the department and the
Attorney General right but just to just
to clarify um is there anybody else
involved in the decision as to whether
or not an education Service Pro provider
is an eligible ESP under this program is
it just simply in the hands of the
scholarship organization uh within the
constraints of the bill it is within
their hands and then just one other
question then so given that um they can
accept gifts and grants grants including
gifts and grants from potential esps who
are in front of the organization
applying um is there provision is there
any provision for an independent audit
of the scholarship organization not an
audit done by the scholarship
organization but an independent audit
yes there is a independent audit
so if you want to go on to the next
question no that's actually it that's
all I had that's all I had it was just
wanted to know where that was that's
all so perhaps uh representative
cordellia can be finding that so we can
you know
respond a little later thank you you're
welcome uh are there any other questions
of yes representative
Cornell hey thank you chairman thank you
representative cordelli for taking my
question just one under qualifying
expenses on page three line one it says
tuition and fears fees at an institution
of higher
education does that mean a community
college or colleges or what's the
definition of higher education it could
be like a a running start or a a dual
enrollment type of program along those
lines okay thank you
further questions from the
committee thank you very much uh
representative cordelli uh will if I
could pardon me Mr chair if I could on
the bottom of page five um it talks
about the audit thank you thank you page
five the bottom okay y thank you very
much you're
welcome okay uh we will proceed on down
the list of those that are you know
request requesting the opportunity to
speak uh uh representative Hobson um
take us down that list boy okay so we're
looking
Clark
here thank you can you hear me
yes do we have video too or is it just
audio we are looking at your
photo great I can't can't see me but
hello chairman and representatives thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak today my name is Jenny Clark I am
the mother of five children four of whom
currently utilize an Arizona empowerment
scholarship account and have for three
years this program has been in place in
Arizona for 10 years I've been home
educating my children for seven years
and I'm absolutely thrilled at the
chance to share with you just how this
program has changed our children 's
lives and why efas are the educational
opportunity that families so desperately
need a little over four years ago after
realizing that our oldest son Scout was
struggling more than typical children
his age we got him evaluated in our
local school district we had our Second
Son Brooks evaluated at the same time
now Brooks had already been in private
speech and occupational therapy for
years at our expense even though our
insurance did not cover most of his
therapy at after many meetings with the
district and through independent
evaluation our oldest two boys were
actually diagnosed with severe dyslexia
and disg graphia among other things now
our district which is one of the best in
the state told us that Unfortunately
they did not offer the specific
structured literacy dyslexia remediation
programs that our children would need
now these programs must be done several
days a week and the curriculum is not
that expensive for a school still there
were no options you can probably guessed
that there were no options for disg
graphia remediation either how is a
child supposed to learn when they cannot
read or write but thankfully we learned
about Esa similar to efas this program
allows parents like me to direct the
funding that is allocated for our
child's education to the curriculums
programs tutors and therapists that we
as parents decide are best for our child
the best way to describe this program is
life changing our family was no longer
limited by our finances or Insurance
when it came to important educational in
interventions that we couldn't
effectively get in our local school we
now had the resources to get new
educational evaluations hired the best
tutors purchased specific dyslexia
curriculum Math Science Social Studies
and more that worked for our kids we
even had the flexibility to utilize
online learning platforms like
keyboarding without tears and other
dyslexia your
resources further families like ours and
thousands of others were able to better
weather the educational challenges that
came as a result of covid we were able
to effectively add new programs and new
classes during covid when other schools
were closed and zoom was the only option
efas do not conflict with existing
options like homeschooling they simply
add a new option for the families that
choose them based on the needs and
desires of their family no one just like
in Arizona is forced to apply or even
accept one in a time when so many
families and students are struggling
everywhere let's give them more options
so that all students have access to the
educational environment in which they
can Thrive without this scholarship I
know my kids would still be struggling
and thankfully that is not the case they
love learning they love trying new
things and they love the educational
opportunities they have because of this
scholarship ship they aren't limited by
our income or their zip code it is with
all the sincerity I can share as a mom
that this program will change the lives
of New Hampshire kids in ways that may
be hard to even imagine right now this
could be such a historic vote for the
lives of students and one that crosses
party lines and social divides I've
certainly seen that as a parent with the
parents that are involved in our program
because it puts our kids first thank you
so so much for your time and if anyone
has any questions about the esa program
and how it's worked in Arizona more
specifically I would be happy to answer
those are there any questions from
members of the
committee thank you thank you very much
have a good
day uh do we have uh rson Hobson
somebody on on the list next that's uh
okay uh go ahead
Elizabeth hello I don't know if can you
hear me yes okay I don't know if my
video is here because I've dialed in so
it's not okay so you can just hear my
voice yeah I apologize you can't see my
picture um so my name is Elizabeth
tentis and I am here in support of the
[Music]
sorry
where did she
yourself oh there we go sorry okay oh it
now oh okay so my name is Elizabeth
tentis and I am here in support of the
educa um of the education Freedom
account I am a parent of a child with
with a disability and also I am a
special education teacher in Manchester
New Hampshire if the bill passes the
freedom education account program could
open the door to so many beneficial
opportunities to families and children
disability as a parent living with a
child who has a disability things have
not always been easy however given my
profession as a special education
teacher that made the process a little
less stressful can you imagine the
families that feel lost and have no clue
where to begin let alone know the
resources that are available able to
them and their
children EFA can help with additional
Services supplies tutoring online
resources Etc this is
huge public versus private school I
chose to send my child to a private
school knowing he had a disability and
it honestly has been one of the best
decisions I have made my son is
supported he receives services and is so
happy to go to school each and every day
my son also attends private spee therapy
session sessions once a week and has for
four and a half
years our insurance only allots certain
amount of sessions per year in the rest
of those sessions we are responsible for
paying out of pocket with this EFA
account we could be using these funds to
pay for extra speech and uh Speech
Therapy Services which would be
huge and I'll let you know that some of
those session well every session is $100
out of pocket so this would be huge um
and speaking just for my family but
there are several families that have to
pay for speech and OT or several
Services um depending on the certain
disability of their children or CH child
um so with that being said I really hope
that everyone listens to the testimonies
of each and every person speaking
because truly it comes from parents that
are living in this and not just people
that don't know the full story so I want
those people to take into consideration
that if you do not have a special ed
child to think about all the certain
things that we are speaking on um
services and additional supports because
it can be extremely difficult if there's
nothing um and let alone just living in
the pandemic has been
hard thank you very much Elizabeth um
are there any questions for Miss
ttis not seeing any questions uh uh
represent Hobson uh the next person
chers could I ask a question um I've had
some Representatives that are in the
participant room asking about whether or
not um there's a specific order of
selection or where they are on the on
the
list uh representa Hopson if we have
Representatives on that list we should
really try to address the
representatives first in case they have
to go to some other meeting uh so
they're not hanging here the whole time
I understand that's the same thing for a
member of the public too but that's the
courtesy we've always operated upon okay
um that's that's fine thank you and
apologies for my interrupting no that's
okay thank you for
interrupting thank you okay so I there
is
question go ahead uh get the next person
person on
board uh so I there are a lot of
Representatives here um I I guess I will
just choose one uh representative Megan
panelist um yes I don't actually have a
question I wasn't registered to ask one
okay okay thank
um how about uh
um I wonder um representative lad could
we take a three minute break uh there
are are so many people here talking uh
or or who are attendees and there's 414
people on the call I would like this to
be efficient yeah there's a lot of hands
up but unfortunately go to to the
hand okay um on the attendee list okay
so representative Susan Newman um I've
given you the ability to speak and you
yourself so I will move on to the next
person
uh John
tutel uh well I don't see any reps with
their hands raised
um oh there's cat McGee wh cat McGee
speak there you are you're given
permission to speak thank you very much
I appreciate it uh thank you Mr chair
chairman and members of the education
committee I'm representative cat McGee
from Hillsboro 27 uh Hollis and I come
to you today to testify against the
establishment of the dick hinch Freedom
education account program as outlined in
hb20 in my town and in the three others
I have had the honor to serve taxpayer
money is a very precious commodity at
school meetings um we see Property
Owners being pitted against their local
schools in a competition for those ever
Rising property tax dollars and I am I
am concerned that this bill will raise
those taxes by siphoning more money away
from struggling Community Schools so I
see this as a lose lose proposition I am
very aware of the issues that have been
brought up so far in terms of uh parents
having choice and having other
opportunities in terms of Education
Innovation I just look at this bill and
the way that it's been written and the
way that it appears to be uh implemented
as being uh not the right solution
certainly at this
time uh hb20 says that property taxes
will not only be used for public school
but that those scarce dollars will now
follow the student out of the building
and this bill lets our tax dollars be
used for previously uncovered forms of
Education when we are we just finished a
report that said that adequacy funding
for public education was inadequate so
my question is where does that money
come
from we always had school choice but we
never pretended that our tax dollars
could support both public and non-public
education at the same time that was
never the deal and I don't think we have
any more money than we did before so
this bill changes the deal in a
dangerous way because our local schools
do have fixed costs and if our public
schools close because our taxes are
being scattered to the Four Winds then
school choice becomes less not more the
bill removes moves accountability from
the use of taxpayer dollars by
increasing inequality in special ed
Transportation required subjects for an
adequate education and even grade level
achievement
standards this bill raises property
taxes while lowering support for public
schools and creates a hodgepodge of
accountability and tracking so that New
Hampshire will lose its reputation and
possibly even Federal
funding this race to the bottom means we
will also lose our best people over time
because lack of support for public
schools has a domino effect and when
schools close property values plummet so
this bill has implications for our
economy as well uh it asks us to pay for
destabilizing a system that we paid to
build without a plan for what comes next
U we need local control of our schools
and this bill really does the opposite
we uh have no auditing mechanisms to say
how well or how poorly those T those
precious tax dollars are going to be
spent to educate our children so it
appears to be a a giveaway of taxpayer
dollars to private companies that will
then have an intersection here in our
public education system without um
measures for the outcome or assurances
of benefits so I ask you to vote no on
hb20 our schools our communities and our
property taxpayers deserve better thank
you thank you very much Miss represent
McGee um are there any questions for the
representative not seeing any hands
thank you very much thank you uh
representa Hobson do we have um any
other Representatives waiting uh yes we
do we have quite a few actually
um I ask that anybody that's listening
to us out there that um uh that if you
have questions about the bill uh you can
say whether you support or against it if
you have specific questions dealing with
a page and a line number as we've heard
some of the Reps on the committee
address line and uh page number that
will greatly help us understand um where
where we're going with this um rather
than you know saying well I'm just
oppositional and it's your your position
to say that but it'd be great to have a
little bit more in
specifics okay represent can we make
sure that the presenters State their
name who they represent and and where
they're um that's that's fine the record
thank you y okay uh representative
bville um were you intending to speak or
in okay we will move on and Hobson we
were given a list this morning which
showed those that want to speak do we
have from that list now let's just go
back to that list because that list
shows a whole slug of people that want
to testify yeah and those are not
Representatives I have I have um several
lists and the lists are not
alphabetical um so that leaves me at a
disadvantage so what we we need to do is
just start whittling down through it
those that support those that don't
support and sort of bang it back and
forth um and integrate uh
any that have technical understandings
bill in there and that's how we'll do it
okay well I'm going to need everyone
who's got their hand raised right now to
take their hand and uh lower it so that
I can go by the list and only the
speaker that I call is able to speak
before we go forward uh one one other
point I'd like to make uh uh chairman uh
lad we did have an individual from
Arizona speak uh in favor based upon her
experience there are also is a person in
our attendee list a Charles Syer s i l r
who also is from Arizona who I believe
can give a contrary perspective to the
Arizona experience so I would hope that
at some point in time Mr chairman you
would call on Mr Syler so he can also
provide a contrary look to the Arizona
experience thank you thank you I think
that's fair we'll look down through that
list and and find that individual he
will have to raise his hand yeah and
then he'll shoot right to the top the
list is really hug here he is I think uh
all okay you should be you should be all
set you have to unmute yourself
fantastic thank you so much all right
looks like everybody can hear me so with
that Mr chairman members of the Comm
committee I appreciate you all having me
my name is Charles Syer and I actually
come to you from Arizona but uh as a
former proa voucher lobbyist I actually
helped defend uh the esas in Florida I
helped pitch some of the esas in
Tennessee Nevada uh expansions that
we've had in Arizona I've worked with
folks in Mississippi I used to work at
the Goldwater Institute uh where esas as
a concept were developed uh which would
also be kind of like a Josiah Bartlett
kind of equivalent um but I left there
because I saw that the real impact that
these vouchers and other programs are
having to the communities that I lived
in and uh since then I've committed to
working to make policy makers aware of
the pitfalls of these Concepts and so
for all of you this presently is a
conceptual like idea and I assume
everybody has the best intentions so
I've seen the reality and I'm pretty
well positioned to give you guys some
practical Insight so the Arizona
legislature passed the universal voucher
program so after having small
incremental uh expansions of it we
eventually went to a universal one that
had more oversight transparency and
controls than hb20 does and this was
back in
2017 that Universal voucher Bill led to
a massive public Uprising that forced
the bill to be placed on a ballot in
Arizona where it was rejected by voters
by more than a 2 to1 margin and in its
wake it created a pro-public education
ground swell that led to the state
shifting blue and its federal Offices
and it diminished our Republican
majority in the legislature and has led
to Citizens further passing tax
increases directed uh towards Public
Schools as well as just being mobilized
generally in the political process so
all of that is in uh some ways great for
the political engagement but um but has
definitely shifted uh the balance in
Arizona uh I've also seen statements
about like whether or not this will cost
taxpayers more or less um there's uh
there's different things to consider so
for your State uh the state of New
Hampshire pays about what $3,600 I
believe per student and a vast majority
of those funds uh for the students are
made up then by property taxes but for
the state it will definitely cost the
state budget extra because you're going
to be paying for current private school
and homeschool students uh the program
is open to all of them also uh it will
cost new hampster taxpayers for each
voucher student as uh none of those
students will be eligible for any
Federal funding talking about your title
one any uh uh pre and reduced uh school
lunch monies any other Federal funding
so what that means is that New Hampshire
taxpayers are going to continue paying
those taxes to DC but those tax dollars
won't be coming back to invest in New
Hampshire's infrastructure so that's
going to disproportionately impact Rural
and property poor communities also we've
recently seen a push in other states to
start levying property taxes to help
fund and boost uh Esa voucher expenses
so you you might see that um on the
horizon for your EFA but what really is
scary about your bill hb20 it's the most
extreme bill that I've seen in the
entire country when it comes to these
vouchers is that the allowable expenses
in hb20 are so broad someone could
legally pay for Netflix and Disney plus
is uh technological services or
educational software and applications to
meet educational needs they could also
buy big screen TVs iPads um Arizona's
auditor general we've uncovered hundreds
of thousands of dollars of fraud in our
ESA program which serves just 1% of our
students and those audits have only
examined a small portion of the accounts
they found like jet skis TVs which
aren't allowed here iPads which would
aren't allowed here uh they've even
found someone paid for an abortion with
those funds and regardless of your
stance on abortion I think that all of
us can agree that we don't want our
Public School tax dollars paying for
that um but also since there's no
restriction on out ofate private schools
or services in hb20 you could have New
Hampshire taxpayers paying to fund
private schools or tutors in Switzerland
or Orlando Florida and with the
allowable Transportation expenses
parents could then play to fly their
kids down to Orlando maybe they take a
trip to Disney World um and use their
EFA to pay for it meet a tutor down
there and then spend the rest of the
time um going on rides and eating lots
of food um so these things happen all
the time we see that even if they spend
the money unwisely unfortunately that
comes to an expense of the child's
learning the state won't know about it
because there's no metric for measuring
students academic process in hb20 so if
you want parents to be the last stop of
accountability really generally most
people would expect that they would pay
for it if the public is expected to pay
then you would expect that the public
would hold the program accountable um so
really one of the other problems for
students besides the disincentive for
sometimes for parents to abuse this
program is that um students might be
able to take their backpack full of cash
but then what do they leave behind when
they do that parents are going to wave
their idea rights so that's Federal
protections for students with
disabilities and because private
institutions aren't interested in
educating costly students which is the
main reason voucher programs exacerbate
discrimination gender race and other
reasons um where are those protections I
don't see any of that in the bill in
Arizona we do have some excellent
private schools and some that even serve
um disabled students we have a great
autism school here but I also personally
know multiple special needs families and
students have been denied access to
private schools and some have even been
kicked out and really uh what we see
these vouchers aren't so much school
choice programs as much as they are
school's choice so again this is the
most extreme version I've seen of any
kind of Bill like this in the country
and it really will stain the legacy of
anyone who helps pass this bill
especially when the light starts to
shine on the fraud misspending
discrimination and other failures of
this program and so with that I'd be
happy to take any questions from you Mr
chair or the rest of the
committee uh thank you the chair has
stepped away for a moment so uh I'll ask
if there are any questions from uh the
committee members representative leay uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh for
taking my question um you stated that
there have been audits now done on some
of these uh expenditures according to
the bill here um in front of us it
states the scholarship organization
shall have authority to conduct or
contract for the auditing of individual
efas shall at a minimum conduct random
independent of efas um so there's no
obviously clear uh requirement of audits
just that they might happen and can
happen um what was the situation in
Arizona were there audits from the start
of these uh uh of the vouchers or
esas not when were they implemented and
what did they find yes Mr chair and
members of the committee um excellent
question um so we do have auditing from
an auditor general and there is some
oversight of the program from our
department of education and it's
actually um not a very robust auditing
program and it's actually been um
underfunded by our legislature
intentionally uh the these programs I
know from having worked on the inside
are intentionally designed to be um uh
opaque and not have a lot of scrutiny
some of it is this a spirit of not in
government fingers in private
institutions like trying to um impose
government regulations on private
institutions um but unfortunately when
you're spending public dollars you
really want to know what it's been used
for um so one of the scariest parts of
this bill is an absolute lack of
accountability and a huge conflict of
interest in the small accountability
measure that you do have so um one is
that uh you have a required audit um and
it's supposed to be annual in hb20 and
it's performed by the private
scholarship organization but it doesn't
uh specify what percentage of accounts
or anything to be randomly audited so
they could legitimately pick one or two
accounts to audit per year and be in
compliance with the bill and since the
uh scholarship organization takes a 10%
cut uh up to a 10% cut of every EFA they
also have a direct Financial incentive
to keep as many parents and students in
the program and not uncover misuse um so
each student they kick out they could
lose anywhere between 340 to $850 is
dollar um and I would even say that um
the 10% is a pretty incredulous amount
um uh one uh moving this program's
Administration to a private organization
makes transparency even harder and so it
would be really difficult for people to
foil the program because it's a private
institution so it's even less
transparent than a normal Voucher
Program would be but also 10% is
incredibly High especially since there
aren't really any accountability
measures so don't have to expend a lot
of um uh resources to provide that
service in Arizona we allow the
Department of Education who administers
our um uh voucher program to have 5% by
law but it's only ever been funded at
about half that for about two and a half
percent so we take a quarter of what
you're offering to administer the
program and we do a lot more with that
Administration so the I would definitely
say that the scary thing is the conflict
of interest and also that this is kind
of like an attack on local control as
much as it is an attack on public
education because it consolidates all
the management and oversight of this
program that's publicly funded but with
a private entity so your taxpayers
aren't going like it's not something
that's going to be governed by local
school board or have input through their
um representative um it really takes
this about as far away from the public
as possible thank
you thank you very much Charles uh are
there any
questions yes representative
Tanner thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Mr Siller for taking my question um
our last um education tax scholarships
uh went 85% to uh religious schools and
I was wondering if you had an idea of
how what percentage of the um Arizona um
voucher system went to the monies went
to religious schools
uh Mr chair members of the committee I
honestly don't have information about
how much money has gone to private
schools from our program because as I
had briefly mentioned a moment ago these
programs are designed intentionally to
be opaque and so it is very difficult to
get data on them but one thing we have
seen and it is interesting I I heard a
point made to the contrary uh before but
uh looking at all of these programs
across the country it's almost
universally wealthier families who
utilize them because uh uh unless a
program has a strict income cap in place
which this does not um wealthy families
are the ones that can afford to pay the
gap between the vouchers and the expense
of the tuition or whatever Education
Service they're utilizing but even more
critically than that um they usually
have the time and luxury and resources
to search out for programs like this and
for the educational options that are
before them if you have a family where
both parents are working uh two jobs
they don't have a lot of time to look
into different public programs they
don't have a lot of time to explore what
schools may be around and whether or not
those schools provide the services that
would best suit their kid or even um
look at other options as well beyond
that so we see about 75% of the usage in
Arizona is uh uh higher income uh
families using the program and that's
pretty consistent with Esa and uh
voucher programs that would mirror what
you have here in hb20 so I would expect
to see something similar in your state
thank you very much uh further
questions yes representative luno thank
you very much Mr chair and thanks very
much Mr Syler for for joining us this
afternoon um in the fiscal note that
that came over uh this morning on House
Bill 20 the um legislative budget
assistant um estimates there's there's
approximately
16,000 new your students um uh attending
private schools so would would you know
seeing that these these students
according to representative cordelli are
are eligible for this program um would
would I guess you expect there to be a
be a fairly High takeup rate um U from
these families U Mr chair members of the
committee um I imagine that you would
see an almost immediate rush uh of
families to to uh utilize this program
who are already either homeschooling or
in a private school situation as it is
uh I mean uh subsidizing their education
by a few thousand do means they get to
keep a few thousand dolls more and while
there may be a a few families a handful
of families in New Hampshire where a
couple thousand dollars is is absolutely
meaningless to them um I am quite
confident that that would uh be a very
small
percentage uh and so um yeah I we see in
every situation that we've uh
encountered uh where a voucher program
or an Esa program has the opportunity
for a uh a family to um utilize the
subsidy uh they do in Arizona we don't
have that because we have a requirement
that students have to have attended um
Public School beforehand and a number of
other uh of these Esa programs have a
provision that's similar uh written into
their bills as
well thank you very much uh further
questions thank you very much uh Charles
and have a good day out there in Arizona
thank you so much have a great one no
snow huh no we had
some okay great have a good one uh uh
person I'm muted uh next person on the
bedrick sorry my computer froze
please are you there Jason yes I'm
here Jason thank you it's good to be
back sort of in New Hampshire I was
actually just there last week visiting
my father father for his 70th birthday
uh I'm Jason bedrick director of policy
at Ed choice we are a national nonprofit
organization that works to advance
educational Choice all across the
country uh I got my start on this issue
actually Back in the New Hampshire house
uh I was I served in 2007 and 2008 uh
and now I live in Arizona uh so we have
a trifect of Arizona residents today I
actually I submitted uh testimony that I
emailed to the committee
so I'm not just going to read it word
for word uh you have all that uh what I
would like to do is actually address uh
some of the questions that were raised
before and some of the issues that were
raised uh by the previous uh gentleman
uh one of the questions that was raised
before was about what if a student were
to uh enroll in the esa or EFA program
as you call it in Arizona sorry in New
Hampshire if they were to take an
education Freedom account uh and then
they were to leave it and return to
their Public School uh so the EFA
accounts uh the the treasurer makes
deposits on a quarterly basis uh and the
online version I have doesn't have page
numbers uh but there is a section uh
that says that uh the EFA shall remain
in force and any unused funds roll over
from quarter to quarter and from year to
year until the parent withdraws from the
EFA withdraws the EFA student from the
EFA program or until the EFA student
graduates from high school unless the EA
is closed because of a substantial
misuse of funds and then here's the key
part any unused fund shall revert to the
State Treasury and be allocated to fund
other efas so if a student were to leave
the program those funds do end up
reverting back to the
state uh now I want to address there
were a number of issues that were were
raised by the previous gentleman who who
did not actually identify himself as a a
lobbyist for a union funded anti-school
Choice group out here in Arizona called
save our schools uh and you know he was
talking about local control the the most
local form of control is actually the
family and what this bill recognizes is
that there is no one school that best
meets the needs of every single child
who just happens to live nearby and it
is
properly moving the locus of control uh
from the state or from other elected
officials to families to uh customize
their child's education based on their
intimate personal knowledge of their
child's specific uh educational needs
and uh interests and aptitude uh now he
he he talked about the auditor General's
report uh of course yes he says you know
there were jet skis and all sorts of
things uh the auditor General's report
which I included a link to it uh in my
testimony found that
99% of the funds were spent for
appropriate eligible uses about 1% of
the funds uh in Arizona were spent for
inappropriate uses uh now how did that
happen well what they have in Arizona is
they they were using uh debit cards now
if the program had been large enough
they could have used product codes but
because it wasn't they were using vendor
codes with the vendor codes you know you
just you can't take it and R to Disney
world or Caesar's Palace you can only
use the card at a vendor that sells
approved products and services uh and
then you have to submit your quarterly
receipts you cannot get your next
quarter's allocation of funding until
you have submitted your receipts the
vast majority of the misspending was
actually just uh families who were new
to the program that were a little bit
confused that purchase things like uh
pens paper uh consumable you know
educational products that the department
then had to tell them no you know that's
not an eligible expense they then had to
refund that money back into the account
and they couldn't get their next
dispersement until they did that there
were however some cases that's where you
get the jet ski the jet ski stories
where a card had been lost or stolen or
or otherwise compromised uh some in some
cases from hackers that break into the
uh the card readers uh and in those
cases there were people who were able to
purch
inappropriate items uh in many of those
cases they were able to track those
people down and they were accused of uh
you know of theft and fraud uh as is
appropriate but again uh that's fewer
than 1% far actually fewer than 1% uh
were were the the cases of actual
outright fraud compare this by the way
to other government programs that
according to uh the the US general
accountability office there's about a
five rate 5% rate of of misspending
across government programs uh and and
some of the most beloved programs like
the uh school lunch and School breakfast
program have a fraud and misspending
rates uh you know that are about 16 and
23% respectively uh Arizona though has
also learned from their experience with
the cards they are now moving to a
system called class wallet which is an
online portal and the only way that you
can make purchases
is through the online portal the only uh
vendors that are in the online portal
are vendors that have that are selling
approved goods and services and that's
all you can purchase through the online
portal so this new class wallet system
which is very similar to things like
benefit wallet and whatnot that you
might use for your health savings
account uh this should be taking fraud
basically down to zero so this is
actually a far more accountable program
and when we're talking about
accountability really the best form form
of
accountability is directly to the people
who bear the consequences of your
performance so when it comes to we can
break down accountability into two parts
Financial accountability and academic
accountability Financial accountability
that's where the state has to ensure
that these funds are used for the
purpose for which they were allocated uh
the online portal system accomplishes
that goal uh secondly the academic
accountability is appropriately uh to
the parents and this is something I
think we've lost sight of which is that
uh in many cases uh the Local District
school is is really not uh directly
accountable to parents it's accountable
to elected officials it's accountabil
it's accountable to unelected
bureaucrats but not directly to the
parents and we do this as a sort of
second best form of accountability
because especially for uh lowincome
areas where they can't afford to move to
a better District uh or to pay for
private school tuition then they're not
directly accountable to the parents uh
over time we have come to confuse these
sorts of government regulations uh with
accountability but the real
accountability is when you have a family
with multiple options and they are
empowered with the ability to choose
among those options so if something is
not working for their child they can
leave now yes Arizona New Hampshire does
have some great schools on the product
of both uh New Hampshire's uh public
school system I spent eight years in in
a public school that I loved and I'm
glad that my parents were able to afford
to live in Windham uh we didn't have a
high school and I'm glad that they were
uh able to afford to send me to Bishop
girton Catholic High School uh which by
the way I'm a Jewish student uh or I was
I am Jewish and I was a student at a
Catholic High School uh uh some of my
friends were gay uh there was a teacher
there that I had who everybody knew was
gay they uh were very warm and welcoming
to all people uh so on this question of
discrimination uh yes there will be some
schools that are going to say uh we are
open only to members of our particular
faith community and you have to adhere
to uh our particular uh ideas and
beliefs but there are also schools that
are open to everyone uh there are there
was also a case I can send the committee
a recent story that came out of Florida
where there was a gay student who was
horrifically bullied in his public
school which failed to uh adequately
protect him he was then able to take a
scholarship through the state's tax
credit scholarship program similar to
what you have in New Hampshire and find
a private school where he is thriving uh
so uh there are there's no system that's
going to open every single option up to
everybody but what this bill does is it
opens so many doors for so many children
the idea is you want to maximize the
ability of families to have as many
options as they possibly can uh one last
note uh this idea of uh wealthy families
it's simply inaccurate uh there is no
data in Arizona they're not collecting
income data but what we can say is that
when you look at the districts that
they're coming from uh the participants
in the esa program are coming from
higher and lower poverty districts uh
areas in in similar proportion to the
public school students and actually the
uh the 10 districts that have the
highest concentrations of Esa students
actually also have some of the highest
child poverty rates in the state and uh
I was a part of a a group that did a
survey uh of the program in its first
year uh the students that entered the
program uh when they were asked about
their previous Public School uh fewer
than half said that they uh were
satisfied with the education they
received at the previous public school
and it was the lowest income quintile
that expressed the most
dissatisfaction however uh when we asked
them about the uh education they were
able to acquire for their their child
through the esa program uh there was
actually Universal um uh support uh
satisfaction and it was the lowest
income quintile that said that they were
the they were the most likely to say
that they were very satisfied 9 out of
10 said that they were very satisfied so
it was the lowest income families in
other words those that are the most
Choice deprived that had the most to
gain from access to expanded choice I
thank the committee for your
time
thank you very much Jason are there any
Tanner are you on
mute uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Mr bedrick um I have a question do do
you work through the children's
scholarship fund no I do not I work for
a group called Ed choice we're nonprofit
based in Indiana I'm sorry not you
personally but but oh the
Arizona um scholarship is that through
the children's scholarship fund out of
New York
City uh no it is not uh in Arizona the
program is run out of the Department of
Education in some other states the esa
program is run out of the treasurer's
office or Department of Revenue uh and
then in Florida which right now has the
largest education savings account
program uh and they're actually in the
process of of converting their tax
credit scholarship into an Esa uh that
is run out of a scholarship organization
called Step Up For Students similar to
Children's scholarship fund uh here um
in New Hampshire thank
you thank you very much uh Mr bedrick uh
further
Ellison no yes no I'm fine thank you
fine thank you're welcome representive
uh
[Music]
luno thank you Mr chair and um and thank
you very much Mr bedrick for uh joining
us this afternoon um could you tell us a
little bit about the provisions in the
Arizona law that um that are that are so
you know strong at uh at at uh
uncovering um um I guess misuse of um of
of these voucher
funds yeah the esa funds in AR Iona uh
have to be audited on a regular basis uh
and they are audited by the department
and also by the auditor General's office
who audits not only the department
itself uh sorry not only the the
accounts but the department itself and
how it is managing uh the the
program okay so that's in statute that
is in statute okay do you see is there
anything like that in in House Bill 20
uh no there is not okay thank
you thank you very much represent Miler
uh thank you uh Mr chairman uh and thank
you for being here Mr bedrick uh
question for you uh New Hampshire ranks
in the top three top five in student
achievement in the nation are you aware
of uh Arizona's
rank I I don't have Arizona's ranking
Arizona is a middling state right now uh
although I would say over the last two
decades Arizona has had the greatest um
leaps in terms of of uh growth uh so uh
in both the 2015 and
2017 nape that's the national assessment
of educational progress Arizona had the
most gains uh Arizona also if you look
at just Arizona's Charter School sector
Arizona's Charter School sector is
number one in the country compared to
any other state uh so what we have found
in Arizona is that Arizona went from
near the bottom uh to Middle
uh and that we think is to a great
extent because of uh the uh the variety
of uh educational options that you here
that you have here in Arizona the the
last I saw on US News and World Report
is that Arizona ranked 40th in the
nation thank you very
much not on the nape uh and and part of
what Newsweek uh sorry uh US News and
World Report does is that uh they look
at a lot of inputs as well and not just
output puts and so I think it's more
important both to look at outputs and
also to look at trajectory because a
part of the idea of educational choice
is that over time you are going to have
improvements uh that is certainly what
we've seen with uh there's been about 30
studies um by top universities in the
country that have looked at the effect
of educational Choice programs uh on on
the performance of public school
students uh in other words the the
students who remain in the public school
system uh all but one of them uh found
uh neutral to positive effects actually
the vast majority found small but
statistically significant positive
effects uh there were few that did not
find any effect and only one that found
a negative effect uh and that was in
Florida but there were several other
studies in Florida that had detected
positive effects uh so what we do see is
that over time the um availability of
multiple choices for families actually
uh creates an incentive for the entire
system to improve thank you very much uh
Mr bedrick uh are there further
questions if not see any thank you very
much and have a good
afternoon thank you very much for your
Hopson Megan Tuttle from the
you
you should be on
Megan I'm sorry I apologize for that my
computer just cut out for a moment sorry
about that um for the record my name is
Megan Tuttle I'm president of Nea New
Hampshire representing approximately
17,000 Educators across the state um I
do have testimony that was submitted and
because of the number of people who have
signed up for this I'm just going to go
over the last part of it with you if
that's okay um we are are incomplete
opposition to House Bill 20 public
school funding is open and transparent
voucher spendings private and shrouded
in secrecy uh public schools are owned
operated and managed by the public while
the private scholarship companies are
designed to make a profit no laws or
limit there aren't any right now that
prevent parents from choosing to send
their children to a private religious
school or to homeschool them every
family is free to make that choice that
choice should never diminish another
child's education or obligate any other
family to help pay for their tuition
House Bill 20 is an intrusion into the
futures of public school children and
the imposition of a financial burden on
taxpayers across the state this bill has
no place in the granite state three
years ago this committee sent a similar
Bill onto the finance committee that
contain so many issues the finance
committee simply could not fix them I
urge the members of this committee not
to do the same thing again and
respectfully ask that you find House
Bill 20 and expedient to
legislate and if you I I know I
submitted some testimony but um I just
there representative lad you're
muted I am muted aren't iting a sweet
roll my wife's cooking bread in the
kitchen I tell you you all all to come
over um thank you very much Megan I
appreciate your uh testimony are there
any questions for Miss
Tuttle not seeing any thank you very
much uh next
person representative Heath is has her
hand up in the
participant
line can you not see that yeah yeah I I
see that we've been trying to bounce
back and forth between one and the other
so okay um I just know you did rep so
yeah uh who's the next one up and then
we'll do repent of Heath uh the next one
up is shalomar oops I'm sorry I just
lost
is
shalomar en Carion in yes thank
you
hello good afternoon and thank you for
taking my testimony today I'm glad we're
doing Zoom it would have been difficult
out there and all this snow my name is
shelmer caneso and I'm a mom from
Manchester and I'm in support of Bill
hb20 I am the co-chair of the Manchester
NAACP education committee but I am here
representing myself as a Hispanic leader
of color in my community I've seen
firsthand how many of our communities
don't have equal access to educational
resources this is about leveling the
playing field and making the best
education accessible to everyone in this
day and age we talk a lot about
diversity you know equity and inclusion
and those need to be the goals in our
educational system as well it's clear to
me that education Freedom accounts are a
huge step forward that would help
achieve these goals this is about
removing barriers to help our kids reach
their potential this is about individual
New Hampshire students to succeed
academically by allowing resources to
help meet their individual learning my
path for parent advocacy in this area
started when my children were having
difficulty in school though all three of
my children have had childhood ill
illnesses such as multiple sclerosis and
cancer I want to talk about my youngest
his name is Angel who incidentally just
happens to also have dark skin Angel was
always struggling he's very high
functioning on the Autism Spectrum which
went un un diagnosed until 9 years of
age he's also ADHD as well and he's
prone to severe migraines he started
with an individualized education plan in
third grade and was later downgraded to
a 504 plan in high school in sixth grade
he was having lots of difficulty at our
local public school when he started at
the middle school we did tell him about
the situation and ask him if they could
accommodate him but they said no to a
lot of our requests and they refused
many of the ideas that would align with
his IEP repeatedly he would always end
up having problems with the teachers and
the environment and stress would trigger
his migraines and cause him lots of
anxiety and would have him just acting
out of sorts to which the school's
repeated response was to put him to in
in-house suspensions so we pulled him
from that school and we were able to put
him at St cmir thanks to the scholarship
from the children's scholarship fund he
was there all of eighth grade and he did
amazing it was to the point where the
teachers were just saying they didn't
even see what was it that was in his
file that had come over from the school
he was at it was basically night and day
for him he begged says to never send
them back to the public school but after
his father took on a new job with a
higher income we no longer qualified for
the amount of scholarship Monies to make
it possible to move them into the
private high school if the education
Freedom account were around then we
would have been able to use these funds
to make up the difference to send them
to a high school that would meet his
needs today Angel is back in the public
school system and he's repeating his
senior year and he's still
struggling I like saying that these
things don't have to be looked at as an
either or we should look for the
solution from a both and perspective
Public Schools don't work for everyone
the same way private schools don't work
for everyone we do have to look at it as
from a both and perspective everywhere
you turn there's so many choices yet K
through2 education isn't one of them we
should make it possible for the parents
to choose what works best for their
child after all don't the parents know
their children's need more than anyone
else I've spoken with multiple families
who say that education Freedom accounts
would help them a lot I know families
that are paying for school out of pocket
who don't qualify for Scholarships in
many instances any bit helps and
education Freedom accounts go a long way
I did hear earlier that somebody
mentioned well if a family is earning
300,000 then would they still be able to
apply well yes they would but really how
many families do you know earn 300,000 I
don't uh so basically this is mostly the
parents that probably earn in the low um
hundreds or higher double
digits this is for the children that
and we have to remember that that this
is for the individual child don't be
mistaken this is about equity and
inclusion for all especially for
students from communities of color and
that lens should be used as well when
determining the outcome for this Bill
thank you thank you very much shmer I
think I met Angel one day up in the
you so you met him well are there any
questions for
shalomar thank you very much for taking
the time this afternoon and have a good
afternoon you too thank you you're
welcome uh can we please have the next
person uh to testify yep the next person
is representative Mary Heath and
representative Heath I'm sorry I didn't
recognize you uh I was looking for
people with the rep in front of their
name so if you're in go ahead and speak
I am in and I thank you Mr chair thank
you for recognizing me and um thank you
representative Cornell for pointing me
out in the list um I'm for the record my
name is Mary Sullivan Heath and I
represent district 14 um in Manchester
New Hampshire um I'm speaking against
House Bill 20 I believe it undermines
our public school system I also am
deeply troubled by the fact that it
takes money from our public schools now
we are already have a source of revenue
for children who are seeking scholarship
programs let's look at how we can Shore
that up but don't take money from our
Public School System our dollars are so
scarce as it is just on the simple
calculations that I've done just sitting
here and
listening homeschoolers are eligible for
this program private school students are
eligible so we have 6,000 homeschoolers
and that's a low number 16,000 private
school students that's the potential of
22,000 students so that's about $77
million that would be new dollars added
to our tax burden for the state but I
want to go to my city of Manchester so
my city of Manchester if we take 100
students away from our public
schools that will be about
$550,000 now we already have are seen a
huge drop in enrollment due to covid
plus we have a number of charter schools
in our city so our numbers have dwindled
by a thousand plus the costs that go
along with um services for students with
disabilities within those Charter
Schools that's probably about another
million dollars so those are the the
major Financial concerns I have and I
just briefly want to talk to the
financial note the fiscal note rather
now when I looked at the fiscal
note the dollars were looked at by the
total amount per student and then the
adequacy amount was subtracted and the
leftover was considered that would
benefit the local taxpayers when in fact
that really isn't the way it works and I
just with all due respect to the
commissioner I think his thinking is a
little bit flawed on this and I have to
say I am so
disappointed that in fact we would take
the number of dollars away from our
public schools that would be considered
coming out of this bill especially I was
a member of the school um uh Finance
funding committee from this Summer that
we worked on we saw the inequities
across our state that our school
districts are faced with with the co the
effects of covid with the effects of of
what we're seeing with
inequities adding the burden of
hb20 to our taxpayers base is just
unconscionable and I would ask from the
bottom of my heart that you please itl
this seriously seriously flawed bill I
thank you for allowing me to
testify thank you very much
representative Heath uh are there are
there questions for the representative
thank
you uh next uh indiv oh wait a minute
wait a minute represent Leon you have a
question um yes thank you Mr chair I did
have a question for you representative
Heath um I know that you spoke to the
challenges that Manchester is facing
right now with the declining enrollments
uh is there an issue about not being
able to address the um the fixed costs
because it seems that the declining
student enrollment is an ongoing issue
that the taxpayers are going to need to
face
agree and is the I guess um as as we
looked to the analysis I actually looked
at the Department of Education white
paper that they had provided and gone
through um have you looked at it and
seen that if the schools take three
years in order to decrease the amount of
spending that they have per student I
apologize for my helper um if they spend
three years it decrease the amount of
time that they have per the amount
they're spending per student that this
actually will save taxpayers over 10
years appro local taxpayers
approximately $274 million it is my
belief that it will seriously undermine
public education further in the city of
Manchester I am sorry but I don't agree
with your
analysis I'm looking for equity for
these children I appreciate your your
Insight thank you thank thank you very
much any further
questions represent Hopson next
speak next individual is Erica Smith
from The Institute of Justice thank
you welcome Erica thank you Mr chair
thank you for having me my name is Erica
Smith and I'm a senior Attorney At The
Institute for justice we are a national
nonprofit organization and one of my
areas of expertise is the
constitutionality of school choice
programs uh I was also one of the lead
attorneys on the US Supreme Court court
case that was mentioned earlier espanosa
versus Montana Department of Revenue and
I could talk about that uh today I could
testify that there are no constitutional
issues with hb20 either under the
Federal Constitution or the State
Constitution and this is especially true
after the Espinosa
decision in previous sessions there has
been some concern that article 83 in the
New Hampshire Constitution would operate
as a bar to a publicly funded school
choice program uh what article 83 pretty
much says is that public funds can't go
to religious schools now we would argue
that there are no public funds going to
religious schools under this program
instead all the public funds are going
to is to parents and not a drop of money
winds up at any religious School absent
the free and independent choice of
families uh but in case there is any
doubt about article 83 that doubt has
now been resed olved with the Espinosa
decision and what Espinosa says is that
you cannot interpret a state
constitutional provision including the
Blain Amendment like in New Hampshire's
Constitution to exclude religious
schools in a school choice program now
if some of you here are a little
familiar with that decision I can just
go into a little more detail on that so
Espinosa all started with one woman and
that was a mom named Kendra Espinosa
she's one of the strongest women that I
know uh a few years ago she was
homeschooling her two daughters in rural
Montana uh everything was going fine
until her life was turned upside down
when her husband unexpectedly left her
and her daughters uh she lost her house
she lost everything she had to move into
town uh she put her daughters into
public school and things were not going
good her oldest daughter was getting
bullied in school her youngest daughter
was falling behind she wasn't able to
pay attention her classes but Kendra was
barely able to make ends meet she was
cleaning houses just to make her pay her
bills and she had no idea how she could
possibly afford anything besides the
public
school uh but one day just on a whim she
decided to take a a tour of a Stillwater
Christian it was a private school near
her home
and she fell in love with the school and
she desperately wanted her children to
be able to attend um
she she tried to think of whatever she
could to to make extra money to pay the
tuition she took on EX oh I'm apologize
about my phone uh she took on extra jobs
trying to clean houses her daughters
were chipping in mowing lawns shoveling
snow she even had a fundraiser with
handmade quilts to raise the tuition
money and Fin finally after all of this
she was able to raise just enough to
make up half of the tuition uh
fortunately the school was able to pay
for the rest um but and she was able to
put her children into the school but as
Kendra was going to sleep that night
think like thinking how am I going to be
able to afford this every single
semester this is crazy what if my car
breaks down and that's when Montana
passed their first school choice program
and this program was going to be the
Lifesaver for Kendra and so many other
families across the state that didn't
have the money to pay for the private
school that they so desperately wanted
to go to this uh this program was
designed to help exactly those families
but politics got in the way and the
agency that was in charge of
administrating the program decided to
exclude religious schools from the
program uh and they Justified that on
Montana's Blain Amendment which is very
similar to New Hampshire
so we challenged this in court it went
all the way up to the US Supreme Court
and the Court ruled unequivocally that
you cannot interpret Blain amendments uh
whether you're talking about the one in
Montana or in New Hampshire or anywhere
else to exclude religious schools from a
program to do that would violate the
free exercise rights of families and
schools it violates the free exercise
rights of families because you're
putting parents in a position to choose
between following the religious beliefs
on one hand and choosing to obtain a
government benefit and you can't make
parents choose between their beliefs and
a benefit so that's
unconstitutional and it's Al also would
discriminate against religious schools
because you are excluding them from
participating in a program based solely
on their religious status so after
espanosa uh New Hampshire's Blain
amendment can no longer be interpreted
to Bar religious schools from
participating in this program I
encourage you to pass this bill I think
it's an excellent Bill and it would help
thousands of kids across the state so
thank you thank you very much Miss Smith
are there any
questions
yes
represent thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Miss Smith for your testimony
if you don't mind I might ask you a
legal question it sounds like you have
some background in that area um whether
or not some version of this eventually
moves forward or not say something did
move forward uh I think most of us
understand that
Espinosa that precedent uh is going to
eventually negate the article 83 issu
new Hamp but that said uh say something
passed uh at some point along these
lines uh that would not preclude a
lawsuit uh citing article
83 uh it in challenging this measure is
that fair to say that even though
espanosa is is is happened uh there
could very well still be uh a suit
against this in New Hampshire citing
article 83
correct it's certainly possible but that
lawsuit would be frivolous and if that
lawsuit were to occur uh my Law Firm
would step up to help defend the program
we operate free of charge we actually uh
helped protect uh New Hampshire's tax
credit program back in 2014 when that
program was challenged so we would be
there to help defend this program in one
followup yes you may uh so let me ask
you this because you you
know much more than most of us uh if
there was a lawsuit could there be some
sort of an injunction that would uh that
would stall the program while the suit
was being heard I think that would be
extremely unlikely um because to impo
for a court to impose an injunction they
would have to be the court would have to
be going against Supreme Court president
and I don't think any trial court is
going to want to do that uh if in the
unlikely event that were to happen we
would immediately appeal and the
injunction would be very
short-lived thank you very
much thank you very much uh uh uh let me
get this Erica Smith I know my computer
was messing me up Erica appreciate are
there further
questions oh oh yep represent like
us yes am I to understand that if this
bill were to be amended such that um we
disqualified religious schools from it
that it would be unconstitutional at
that point yes that's
correct thank you thank you further
questions yes representative
Tanner uh thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you Miss Smith um usually when a
lobbyist comes before us we get a little
bit of a rundown on um their back the
background of their particular uh lobing
group so I was wondering if you could
give us just um you said you were
nonprofit are you also
nonpartisan um you know how how are you
uh what is your group um sure and I and
I have this in my written testimony uh
we are nonprofit We Are nonpartisan we
have been we are funded entirely by the
uh generosity of our donors we've been
around for 30 years uh and what we are a
constitutional law firm and what we do
is we protect individuals rights from
violation thank you further
questions not seeing any hands thank you
very much for being with us today
uh we'd like to move to the next person
testimony next we'll uh invite
representative
Southworth representative Southworth
you're muted okay yes can you hear me
now y thank you uh thank you Mr chair
and the committee for taking my
testimony I'm representative Tom
Southworth uh in my fourth term present
representing the city of Dover I'll be
speaking in opposition to
hb20 uh I have many issues with the bill
uh but for personal knowledge I want to
speak about the uh discrimination
issue in
2017 a transgender student was expelled
from a local religious school the
student had attended the school since
kindergarten and was on track to
graduate as valedictorian of his class
when he talked to the Headmaster about
some of his issues he was immediately
banned from campus and thrown out um
fortunately he was able to go to a
public high school and graduate and go
on to college this was very upsetting to
me and my constituents and so I followed
up I contacted the uh commissioner's
office I contacted the Dr Dr and so on
and the response was there was nothing
that could be done that there was no
jurisdiction over these schools and that
they could receive uh public funds uh
since
2017 this local religious school has
year so I'm very concerned that schools
that get state aid do not have to follow
any anti-discrimination laws I know that
not all of the private religious schools
uh will discriminate there are many
great schools in both categories um but
I just don't see how we can pass a bill
um that allows schools to discriminate
and give them funds uh previous people
have already mentioned some of the
sections in the bill that seem to
protect religious schools and um I think
it was that line 27 on page eight a
couple of them um but I know uh uh time
is brief so I'll end with that
particular
piece thank you very much uh
representative are there questions of of
Tom Sal
not seeing any thank you very much I
believe we have representative Tim
Baxter in the Q also um Mr chair there's
also the honorable Peter Burling is uh
waiting as well so good we we'll try to
alternate here that's what I'm I'm doing
right now um so is represent Baxter
available yes he is go ahead can you
hear me y thank thank you representative
Hopson and thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to speak on behalf of my
constituents I represent C Brook and
Hampton Falls and I want to speak in
support of
hb20 um you know I've heard Universal
support and it's one of um if not the
issue I've heard the most feedback from
so far um and from all kinds of
different families from families at home
school to public school to private
school and and really what I'm hearing
is this is about the individual child
this isn't about the institution it
isn't about the system of public versus
private but families just want the best
education for their child and in
particular Seabrook New Hampshire which
makes up the brunt of my district is a
disproportionately lowincome community
where really hp20 what it's designed to
do is to provide um equality to provide
inclusion to give um these families and
ultimately these kids um more options um
to pick whatever school choice
whatever system is best for them whether
it is homeschooling private public it
doesn't matter it's about giving them
more options that lowincome students
don't always have in um in CBR New
Hampshire so that's what I've heard from
my community and I just wanted to speak
up on behalf of my constituents and I'm
happy to answer any questions um from
any
representative uh thank you very much uh
representative are there any questions
for representative
Baxter not seeing hands thank you very
much for your testimony thank you I also
see that representative Tim Horgan is in
the
queue
um uh it that that's your choice um
representative lad would you like
to here which we're doing
okay uh okay representative Horgan you
you've been promoted welcome to the
education
committee
are you there you're
muted
okay thank you very much uh Mr chair
thank you very much uh representative uh
res resent Hobson I'm not sure which
what office you're actually holding in
the committee today which is the clerk
whatever anyway so I saw some of this on
YouTube and then I popped on the zoom
right after my own committee Judiciary
finished its hearing so I wish to
testify against hb20 um and I know I'm
kind of jumping the four again you know
the some kind of jumping out of the four
against four against pattern so I um um
this is a repeat as you probably heard
from many people of SB 193 which we
dealt with back in 2007 and 2018 even
though they changed a lot of it it's the
same basic idea it's the same basic uh
bad idea and um actually I should take a
second to say there's actually a good
idea hidden in this which is might not
be a terrible it might would be might
not be a terrible idea to give every
family that's in public or private
school like a uh you know small amount
of money they can use for additional
educational expenses because even if
you're in a public school there's things
uh parents have to pay for which aren't
paid for by the taxpayer but that would
be really expensive like do even if you
gave everybody like a thousand every kid
um you know just $500 a year that's like
$ 87.5 million um that's
obviously terribly huge amount of money
we'd probably even end up with a
broad-based income tax we try to do it
but this and actually the get back to
this idea that's pretty much the same
thing we're doing here we're taking all
this money away from the public school
district
some um so this uh one the biggest
problems this program is is that uh it's
uh what I'm picking on is and I hope
apologize if I'm repeating it's these
two scholarship organizations has
approved into RSA 77g 7 RSA 77g is a
somewhat simpler much different program
than what this uh hb20 envisions and
hb77 forg already offers very little
oversight of these scholarship
organization so they I don't think they
are even covered by the usual
boilerplate language about giving the uh
joint legislative committee on rules
jurisdiction over the rules for it so
these uh you know we these organizations
are pretty much operating totally on
their own which
is uh well it's bad enough just with
this the existing tax redit program but
that's a very tiny program which by the
way entirely goes almost entirely
towards religious schools which I still
think is unconstitutional so those
organization current those organizations
their current form are really not
equipped to run a very complicated
program which that might serve tens of
thousands of families I believe there's
175,000 kids in school I think possibly
a very large percentage of the families
might be interested in that which that
sounds like um to name you know to name
just one of many complications The
Proposal hb20 would
require uh someone and it's not exactly
clear who to issue EBT cards or the
equivalent to every participating family
um and that'll be very similar to
existing um cash benefits and S U SNAP
program or better known as food stamps
which is something that we
occasionally often becomes a controversy
here in conquered or right now virtual
conquered um they're overseen by a whole
at least I assume these people are
working remotely but normally they
there's an entire floor at the DHS
headquarters full of state public
servants who administer that program
there's a whole another floor full a few
blocks away a very nice office which is
a uh contractor which helps administer
the program and then there's federal
employees there like you know there's
probably dozen about hundreds of people
who administer program so uh last time
around far as I could tell and I listen
to lots of testimony um the house
finance committee had many many hearings
about it uh which I sat on on some of
they were apparently planning to account
handle their accounts payable and
receivable function by using intern with
a spreadsheet so if you have a
meaningful program like this that's
going to take a very large uh it's going
to take a very large institution to
oversee that's a very complex process
you know dealing with all the deciding
what's to valid
educational expenditure I mean it is
true that the way this is written just
about any parent could spend this money
just about anything that's like even
remotely an educational expense so
that's uh and uh just reminding what I
said before if we gave every gave us
every child that would be very expensive
and huge program and I think for this to
work it would have to be very expensive
and huge program and uh that would be
one
thing if there was a valid if it was a
good good idea basic idea was a good
behind it but the basic idea behind this
ver this plan is just it's not a bad
idea it's a bad implementation of a bad
idea I think it's totally unsalvageable
so I would U urge you me to find this
real itl as soon as possible and then um
you know when we meet together uh rumors
are it's in February sometime late
February Let's uh let's let's kill it
let's put this idea the you know let's
put it aside for now I'm sure one of
those things that just keeps coming back
every year I'm sure somebody will come
up in another form but like this is just
not worth working I think it's not worth
the education committee's time working
on it certainly isn't worth the second
committee which be financed so I just
think you it's a bad idea it's
unsalvageable and uh it would be way it'
be extremely expensive if you Tred to
try to implement it so those are I'm
going to join and many of those say
please find this inexpedient to
legislate
thanks
I'd answer any questions although you
probably want to you got probably got a
long list of people ahead to you and I
thank the chair for letting me Jump
Ahead into que I think you're muted Mr
chair you're muted
Rick
yeah I know it's getting long uh very
much representative Horan are there any
questions for representative Horgan
thank you very much representative lad
yes could I ask rep Tanner uh what
representative she said was on the was
waiting to speak I can't find a uh rep
she was say Peter Peter Burling a former
rep okay Burling yeah Burling yes I
don't see him on the list but I'll keep
looking okay I would also like to start
getting some of those folks which have
been waiting patiently on the lists that
have submitted their we have
Representatives I can look at some on
the list right there with hands up uh
but I'd like to you know offer members
of the public the opportunity as well
okay um so would you like to
speak um next we had Alison meller would
you like me to go to the list for the
public that's that's fine whomever we
have there on that list we have so many
it's just let's start waiting through
it uh
okay
um okay how about uh David
DH Dave spoken on one build is today
he's um he's welcome that's honorable
dhy uh he was a representative in our
education committee last year okay would
you like me to choose him unmute him
well we um else fine go ahead and get uh
okay okay go ahead Mr DH honorable
DH thank you can you hear me yes we can
thanks uh I I will try to be brief thank
you Mr chairman and again uh honorable
uh members of the committee thank you
for taking my testimony
um I think I'll be uh first say that um
I'll agree with my friend and former
colleague representative Heath and
everything she said and she's much more
eloquent than I am so take that as part
of my
testimony um I'm uh a former School
Board member in in penbroke and I am
currently on the budget committee so I
have a little experience in the area um
but I'm speaking as an individual and I
just want to
take my town as a good example we are
struggling to keep solvent we cannot
afford to lose more money we are losing
about
$800,000 in state revenue over
2122 we are looking at a h tax increase
of right now A little over 8% which is
going to hurt an awful lot of people in
this town and that only came about
because our school uh schools cut
$700,000 out of their proposed
budget we need to focus
on better funding public schools and we
can't afford to be giving money away to
private schools I have nothing against
private schools I'm a product of private
school my my children are graduates of a
private high school I have all due
respect for private schools but I see no
need for this state to be spending money
to support them um we are in trouble in
this state I would much rather see this
committee see our Commissioner of
education and see our governor doing
something to better fund our severely
underfunded Public
Schools
than um than uh taking confidence away
from our citizens in what the public
schools are doing and promoting private
education and that's pretty much all I
have to say I thank you for your
time um and uh I hope uh you're able to
reach the end of this meeting in a in a
timely manner thanks again thank you
very much represent our honorable
DH U yeah uh can we any questions for
for Dave
dhy not seeing any hands let's go to the
next
individual uh repent
Hobson
I'm sorry next We Have Allison
Mueller I'm G to um allow you to speak
Allison do you unless you need once
again we'd like to have folks just as
representative dhy did just now he
explained his name where he lives and
what he what he does School Board Etc
budget committee we' like to have all
future members doing the same if if
you're a parent and parent that's
wonderful and just identify your town as
okay can you hear me yes we can Alison
great um good afternoon thank you for to
the house education committee I don't
know if you can see me um but that's
okay this is hearing me is the most
important thing um I appreciate you
allowing me the opportunity to speak
today um as Representatives have
mentioned my name is Allison Mueller and
I am testifying um on behalf of the
dicese of Manchester Catholic schools in
support of House Bill
20 my role in the dases is that I serve
as the director of marketing enrollment
and development in the office of
Catholic
schools there are over 5,000 students
currently enrolled in Catholic schools
throughout New
Hampshire diois and Catholic schools for
which I am representing enroll over
3,400 which makes us one of the larger
school systems in the
state we currently operate 18 diois
schools from Hillsboro to Coos County
and our mission is to make Catholic
Education accessible available and
affordable to any family that desires
it our schools are culturally and
ethnically
diverse and in many cases at a higher
percentage than the public school
systems in our
State 35% of our students are
non-catholic 14% of our students are
identified as quote non-traditional
Learners and those with special needs
end
quote systemwide as Catholic schools we
awarded families over $3.4 million in
financial aid this year alone and 10% of
our students are currently on
scholarship from the children's
scholarship
fund um I share this information with
you because Catholic schools are and
have always been open to all and serve a
critical need in partnership with
parents and
Guardians this critical need seems to be
more prevalent than ever before and our
schools are filled with stories of
seats if any of you know someone who has
attended or is currently attending a
Catholic School you may know that um
attending one of our schools can be a
lifechanging
experience especially for the
underprivileged underserved and
underresourced
in case after case um we are changing
the learning environment for children of
poverty many times when children and
families come to us they are
desperate you see we do serve kids that
otherwise would have been at risk of
being grown out of school forgotten
unchallenged or even held
back we have a child um in an inter city
Catholic school right now who was placed
um by DC DCF with their grandparents and
the grandparents enrolled them in this
Catholic School saying that quote it was
just the kind of school that my
grandchild needs to come and heal end
quote this student uh now receives
special services from school's in-house
therapist and contracted special
education Professional
Services this is as you might know a not
a standalone story there are many more
like it in our Urban Catholic
schools Catholic schools in Suburban
areas and in our rural Catholic
schools the environment that our
Catholic schools provide make a
difference in the lives of children and
their
families the education Freedom account
would provide children with Equitable
access to educational advantages that
they might not otherwise be able to
receive such as enrollment in Catholic
or private schools tutoring services or
even en enrollment in a public school in
another District the education Freedom
account would Empower children and their
families to seek and Achieve
life-changing educational outcomes and I
thank you for your time
today thank you very much Alison are
there any
questions thank you very much
thank you you're welcome uh we'll go on
[Music]
individual okay
um Mr chair we're going to unmute
Deborah
Nelson for
Testimony can you identify uh your
Association please
yes thank you first of all I'd like to
thank you for allowing me to speak I've
been waiting almost four hours I am not
a lobbyist I have no agenda I am a
citizen of New Hampshire and I am a
parent but my children are in their 30s
they've gone through Public School in
Handover where I live and I thank you
for allowing me this time to speak in
opposition to
hb20 I appreciate that some are eager to
recogn Iz the late speaker dick hinch
but I do not think this is an
appropriate way to do so and I also
think it was disingenuous of the
commissioner to suggest that criticizing
this bill is to criticize public
education in New Hampshire I thought
that was
unfortunate I think we can all agree to
the importance of careful Financial
scrutiny over the dollars we spend and
yet this bill provides absolutely no
oversight or accountability as has been
repeatedly
said I hope we can all agree that a
proud moment in our history was the
establishment of public schools to
educate our nation's children so that
they would be informed
citizens and yet this bill most
certainly dismantles public education in
New Hampshire
and I fear it opens us to National
ridicule we can all agree that parents
absolutely have the right to put their
children into private and religious
schools but that should not be paid for
with taxpayer dollars nor should it
increase the cost of public education
for local
communities because of these significant
problems I urge you to vote against this
bill which I think is better named the
public education dismantling account or
the private school account thank you
very much and I appreciate your time
thank you very much deor Nelson uh are
you willing to take any questions
absolutely are there questions from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much thank you you're welcome you
very much okay okay next we're going to
call Alicia
Alicia is she there Alicia have you
unmuted yourself or
there
problem Houston we have a problem yes oh
my gosh yes we do can you hear me now
yes can okay wonderful I'm so sorry um
so hello and good
afternoon I also do not have an agenda I
am actually calling uh my name is Alicia
Houston and I am a parent in the NASA
School School District in here in New
Hampshire um so I want to start by
saying I appreciate this opportunity to
provide my testimony in support of the
educational Freedom accounts as outlined
in House Bill
20 I have to be honest that I have
learned so much because of this pandemic
but most importantly from the handling
of this pandemic by our Administration
here in NASA our Board of Education and
our Department of Public Health you see
the nsha school district is one of the
only school districts in New Hampshire
in which we have not returned to any
inperson learning capacity since March
of
2020 many of our children teachers
administrators and much of our community
overall have been paused while many
other cities towns and states around us
created plans for implementation to get
the children who needed in person back
into school
our children here in nashaa are at a
significant disadvantage and are now set
apart from their peers as a result of
the public education system now I have
to be honest I'm in full support of the
public education system but because of
the handling of this pandemic the
refusal to reopen the Nashville school
district and those who are not doing
well in remote learning it has given me
a taxpayer the utmost buyer remorse what
exactly did our tax dollars go to this
year in
nashaa after almost a full calendar year
of plans negotiations changes to plans
horrific Board of Education meetings
that I could not even explain to you if
I tried uh no resolutions and an
incredibly difficult time with obtaining
a Buy in from our now former
superintendent among so many other
issues within our public school
education system we have yet to make
forward PR progress and our district is
failing our children yet for months I
have not sorry I have not seen a pathway
that leads my personal family to Hope
here in nasua much of our community has
positioned itself to Value the
preservation of the institution's
reputation and become less focused on
the children yet I have to be honest
with you all as I sit in front of you
today we have not had a choice I know
that I personally have not had a choice
for my
children I have heard so many people
mention accountability and
spending and I have also heard how this
hurts the public school system and in
not many of these statements have I
heard how this entire process and the
lack of choices due to fam's concerns or
inabilities to financially make these
decisions for their children this is
hurting many of our
children as a mother of schoolage
children both of which within the
special education sector the remote
learning only model at least here in
nasua has forced my family and my
children into simply a failed attempt at
a one-size fits-all model but it is also
a cry it is also a far cry from one size
fits most as I stand well Zoom before
for you today I hope that my testimony
will help for some of you to understand
that our world is evolving our children
right now at least here in nasua that I
can speak to directly many are losing a
battle in many places and in many grades
in which we are fighting for their
comprehension knowledge and an overall
suitable education yet it is fiercely
inaccurate to Simply expect that there
will be only one plausible and Financial
option available to our children at
least I feel this way about my own
children I need to clarify I've heard
multiple times today references to RSA
1933 although manifest educational
hardship is a pathway that my family
personally entertained there was a
systemic refusal to approve most by our
former superintendent so again where
were our educational choices for our
children
we have never had a choice here at least
in nashaa not for my family that did not
financially implicate my family other
families and many more I have spoken
with and have shared that
choosing an alternative learning
environment would not be fiscally
realistic for myself or for many others
where is our choice for other learning
models for March to now we have not had
one here in nashaa in fact at a pupil
cost in a public educ education at are
about $20,000 per pupil the city of
nasua lost 860 students that is an
estimated
$17.2 million in loss which could have
potentially been reallocated to follow
the student so that their educational
needs were met as a parent who is aware
that it is my responsibility to research
information assess and review options
for my children's
learning will there
schools that do or do not accept
students yes of course however the
structure of this bill I would challenge
you to view no differently than we would
if this were higher education at the
Collegiate level admissions requirements
academic requirements assessment
requirements and all of those things are
all part of the selection process and
choice options this only gives our
opportunity to use the same model in our
primary education system I need to
caution those in this meeting that even
at the middle school level here in
nashaa I would like to put you into my
shoes on a rotating block schedule our
hours here in nashaa are 9:00 a.m to
1:30 p.m. Monday through Thursday now
block scheduling is an alternating
schedule and Fridays are used for extra
help and office hours so in reality our
only choice here in NASA within our
public school system is two days of
instruction consistently for a subject
and the loss of Fridays as although
they're counted towards instructional
hours you see our district and many like
it have opted to spend money that was
that was previously allocated to our
children within the district that is the
same means in which our children are
failing our taxes increased this year
here in NASA due to education yet I must
remind you or share with you that our
schools remained closed since March of
2020 we still pay tax amounts for the
utilities janitorial services and other
miscellaneous expensive expenses yet our
schools remain closed do we not deserve
to take the money allocated to our
children out of District a district that
is proven to fail them well at least my
children I would be happy to do the
research and choose an alternative model
however we don't have that choice right
now not financially and not for my
family
the money is lost and simply reallocated
to an alternative learning choice would
give me an option to help my children I
want to conclude my testimony by
challenging those in this hearing to
think about the number of times you or
someone that you know has had to
maneuver around red tape for information
from a district the number of times that
you have had to modify a lesson so your
child could comprehend the information
or the Heartbreak inly evident reality
of having to console a crying child
while managing their declining mental
health pushing a child to remain engaged
while they're staring at a computer
screen for over three hours per day I
know for me personally this pandemic and
the lack of choices has shown me that
many educational models lack
transparency why are you teaching this
information or why is this part of the
curriculum there have been so many
unanswered questions and I also feel
that our public education system should
be a you get what you pay for and right
now I have to be honest that I feel like
our educational tax purchase for the
future of my children may have been
better spent elsewhere and I would love
the choice to be able to determine that
the education Freedom accounts in House
Bill 20 would enable me to seek
alternative Pathways among many others
to use children's funds from our
generous state government and I beg you
to please
approve this bill I challenge anyone in
the in this hearing to truly approach
this with an open mind a levelheaded
understanding of how the deficits in the
public education system have been
showcased specifically as we continue
here in
covid-19 and just as a Viewpoint from a
family to regain their right to choose
the best educational model that suits
their children a decision that
truthfully only a parent or guardian or
those respons for their children should
be able to make this bill does not force
those who wish to remain in public
school this does not promote a
solitary private school system this is
merely an alternative a choice to those
families in which the traditional
educational model does not work it gives
the parents back the choice for their
child or their children's educational
model thank you so much for your time
stay safe stay warm and please take a
moment to evaluate put yourself into the
shoes of the parents as we are
navigating this educational system right
now and I beg you please give us our
choice thank you for your
time thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions for
Miss
Houston uh yes representative luno thank
you very much um uh representative
cordelli and thank you very much um Miss
Houston for um uh for joining us this
afternoon for your patience
um just my my question just really is
what what is in in the voucher program
what is your expectation as far as um
special education services go so I have
to be honest with you uh thank you for
your question that's actually a very
good question representative luno um the
public school school system in the way
that it's formatted right now with the
special education needs uh there's a
large deficit um at at at least here in
nashaa with the a availability of means
to provide the accommodations and the
amount of red tape that you have to
encounter in order to have the schools
and the educational system follow those
from what I've seen within
covid-19 it has been my responsibility
as the parent to take the lesson plans
reconformation children will comprehend
them so my expectation would be that it
would be my responsibility to continue
should I make the choice to pursue other
opportunities to educate myself on the
special education process if need be and
to seek out alternative Services there's
lots of services that are available for
free um United Way has really great
services but that would be on me as the
parent while I'm making this choice on
where the tax dollars are being spent in
order to make that decision make that
research so just a quick followup Mr
yeah absolutely just to just to make
sure I I understand this and it sounds
like you do too that that that um that
the NASA School District it should you
um uh enter a EFA Pro Voucher Program um
uh with a with a with a different um
School the nationville school district
would no longer have any respon ibility
for special education services I'm not
quite sure on that answer that's a
really great question um I would assume
I if I can get your email I can actually
find out that information and then I can
respond to you if that would be okay no
that would be fine um um my emails on
you can look me up on the on the general
court
website um but the the the bill I think
says it that um that that that the that
the parent basically has selected uh to
Cho to um um well notice under 20 USC
section
1412 is that the idea the individuals
with disabilities Education Act so I
think that part of what this choice
would do is as communities it would be
kind of our responsibility as those
within the local levels that we would
have to then educate the community on
what is this house bill and is it
something that would fit for you I don't
think that this bill is meant as a one-
siiz fits-all I know that for me
personally the accommodations that I've
found under idea within the public
school system and under the Ada for a
504 plan they have not been sufficient
and I've had to rework the models so
maybe I would probably be not a good
person to ask that representative luno
because I have already made the
determination that I'm going to need to
rework the model for the educational
system in which my children learn so my
expectation would be as a home educator
if that were the pathway that I decided
to go I would be able to then designate
my own learning opportunities and cater
those to my children's learning
styles great thank thanks very much and
uh representative luno I think that
section you referred to uh part of it
address specifically a parental
placement in a private
school right that's correct yeah um I I
see our chairman is back uh maybe
representative Hopson can bring up the
uh next speaker well before we bring up
the next speaker I I'd like to speak to
the whole committee and let them know
where we
are um I I do not know where we are in
terms of all the people on the list but
I can look at all the hands up and in
the air on the on the right hand side of
the attendees I see that I also see all
that have requested to speak on the uh
remote testifying sheet that was handed
us today um if I look at the total
number of people that responded this
bill both supporting and opposing we're
up above th
3,000 uh
people uh that's more than we've
experienced in in bills I think at any
time I've been in house and and so what
we're going to do is we're going to go
through to 5:00 today and we're going to
reconvene this meeting recess this
meeting till Thursday of next week and
start at nine o'clock in the morning on
Thursday of next week with hb20 and take
the entire day we will be limiting time
and I'm going to start limiting time
right now to several minutes a person
and if it's need be based upon what we
got left it could be even a shorter
period of time um that's the only way
we're going to get through this and
we're also going to have to be cognizant
of the fact that some folks now are
repeating and I I think that that's you
know they're telling stories which are
story very personal to them and very
meaningful uh however at this point in
time as a committee that's got a task to
get something out by the
18th of of this month we're going to
have to really start start moving here
so that is the plan of action we're
going to take and from this point
forward today we're limiting no more
than two minutes uh per person I just
had a call with us the clerk of the
house and several others and that was
the advice I was given by the clerk who
is represents both parties Democrat and
Republican so U that's that's our
Direction are there any comments from
the committee regarding this next
Thursday the 11th is it is that that
well um whatever yes is that the ninth
or I don't know i' have let me look the
11th that's the 11th that's right
because the 18th is the day that all
early burs have to be reported that's a
week later that's correct so it would be
the 11th at nine o'clock we're also
meeting next Tuesday to do other early
bills
um but somewhere along the way here
we're going to have to do some exing and
I probably end up hearing these bills
and then have a you know then we'll just
list like we have traditionally done
exec sessions and list all those bills
and just start going through them as an
as a body for discussion and making
taking motions if there's no objections
to that that will be our
plan uh I think that's the only way
we're going to make this work and still
be you know supportive of our public and
opportunity okay let's uh representative
Hobson Let's uh move on with it and what
we're going to do now is a two minutes a
person and uh try not to repeat I will
explain that each time somebody comes
on okay representative lad uh we have
Monica
Hensen uh and I'm going to give her the
ability to speak thank you go
ahead are you there
Monica
yes um it just a second Welcome to our
education committee due to some time
constraints here we're limiting the uh
time available to a speaker from this
point on two minutes for all so I try
not to repeat uh if you've been
listening something been previously said
thank you I have thank you so much and I
appreciate everything that the committee
members do for children of New Hampshire
I live in barn state D and I'm currently
the interim superintendent of schools at
sa44 which are the districts of
Northwood notingham and straford but I
speak today as a professional educator
and not as a representative of my school
boards I am a longtime District Public
School administrator I have also served
as a local and state Charter Public
School administrator in Massachusetts
Connecticut North Carolina Georgia and
Florida my objections to House Bill 20
because I speak in opposition
um stem in large part to the lack of
accountability which has been well
documented by the speakers that preceded
me I also have a significant concern
about the impact on social and economic
stratification of children by subsid
subsidizing affluent families who are
already able to afford private education
the best comparison I can make is a
similar situation that occasionally
plays out with some Charter Public
Schools when a Charter Public School
doesn't provide
transportation doesn't offer School
meals schedules a slightly later than
normal start time these are uh
situations that exclude families who
don't have the luxury of a stay-at-home
parent are being able to set their own
work hours but the school claims to be
open to all and that's not a choice it's
barrier the situation with esas is that
it they are not going to increase school
choice for lowincome families who
arguably need it the most families with
limited financial resources are still
not going to be able to afford private
schooling and the truth is is that these
accounts are a subsidy to affluent
families and in NADA an analysis of zip
code shows that students who live in
house olds with incomes above
$100,000 are much more likely to be
enrolled in an Esa program in that state
than children who come in families with
incomes below
$225,000 and that is not an opportunity
it's a
windfall an opportunity esas actually
are a windfall for families of means
thank you all so much I would be happy
to take questions should the chair
permit yes are there any questions of
Monica n seean thank you very much thank
you all right okay um next uh Mr chair
we have Mikel
Robinson
Mel hello so my name is Mel Roberson I'm
for
14 welcome and welcome to the
legislature um thank you we are we are
at the point in our hearings where we're
allowing people several minutes and
because we have so many people wanting
to testify go
ahead okay so I've struggled with mental
health my whole life my SCH situation
didn't help I've had multiple mental
breakdowns about school the reasons vary
mainly being about the pile up of school
work the challenge of living up to
societies and my own expectations and
complicated relationships with friends
as we try to find
ourselves I'm relatively smart but I
really wasn't doing a whole lot I never
studied because I wasn't interested in
the materials provided I was depressed I
realized that continuing to stay in in
the public school system would be
detrimental to my mental health as early
as 7th grade I started having thoughts
about ending My
Life by the beginning of nth grade my
depression got worse so I started
talking to my mom and therapist coming
to the conclusion that I needed a
change my situation became dire despite
the school's best efforts the student
population was toxic we have a lot of
people in our town who really struggle
to get by a lot of stud students in my
school have really hard lives making
connection with them difficult if I
wanted to thrive I needed to leave the
school I'm lucky enough that my parents
can afford to pay for me to have
resources and guidance outside of school
but it really was a stretch for us hb20
would help our family a lot I've just
begun myself self- directed journey and
already I'm feeling a change in the past
few months I've made more friends than
I've made in years and I've had more fun
too I'm finally star to see a future for
myself thank you for listening to my
story I hope you will support H20 need
more Youth Empowerment especially
considering the current state of the
world hb20 will give that to
us
thank you very much male I appreciate
your your coming and testifying today
are there would you like to take any
questions if we have them um sure are
there questions from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much
male thank you you're welcome thank you
male next we go to Michelle St John are
yes I'm ready to speak thank you um
thank
you uh thank you chairman lad and
members of the committee um it's good to
see all of you here again as former
State Rep I promise to be really brief
you've received my written testimony
already um and I just wanted to re
reiterate a point that I have not heard
um in today's
testimony which is um we are looking to
solve a public education problem with a
voucher program that could potentially
be solved with looking at the research
that's been done um on Aces and early
childhood education in the value of
universal
pre and differentiated learning I hear a
lot of people's talking today struggling
with special education needs
with
um the ability to thrive in an
environment and I believe that we
are looking at the wrong solution and I
encourage I implore uh the committee to
not pass this bill um to dive deeper
into looking at other solutions that
will address all of our students my
other point is I
am very very much concerned about the
level of financial impact to towns
um I represented Hollis New Hampshire in
Hillsboro County District 27 but there
are countless um districts across our
state that would having that state
adequacy funding uh plus the
differentiation depending on what
learner that is removed from those
budgets those budgets have to be made up
because there are fixed costs I'm also
greatly concerned about uh local citizen
petitions that would cap and restrict um
the overall tax rate and contributions
to education um which would lead to
other people you know dismantling the
public education system as we know it so
um please don't um don't pass this bill
take a look at what really needs to be
done and um take a look at the universal
prek Early Education that's where that's
where the impact will make a difference
for those children we have ESL Learners
we have Michelle we're at the end of the
time limit yep but um thank you thank
you so much chairman lad and I'm really
um asking you to not pass this Bill
thank you so
much are there are there any questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
Michelle okay thank you chairman lad
next we have uh jod
arms okay Ben Jesus I had to wait three
hours
next I can't tell H Jody are you
available to speak or
next we will go to Beth scare I think
that's how you say your name go ahead
please
Beth hi y it's Beth scare um thanks for
this opportunity to speak in support of
hb20 um my name yeah and my name is Beth
scare I live in Nashua I'm a mother of
two daughters who were fortunately both
very high academic Achievers but one
daughter had as
adhc and when she attended our local
public schools Elma Street Middle School
in nashille High South um we had we
ended up dealing with some very
difficult
administrators um and in fact at Nash
High South the administration just ended
up at eventually just refusing to
communicate with us um when we tried to
advocate for our daughter and the
guidance counselor wouldn't help her
switch classes when she had teachers who
mistreated her because of her
disability and some of the teachers at
Nashville South were outright
emotionally abusive and it was a rough
situation for all of
us and now as Alicia Houston told you
the kids going to nashille schools
haven't had any in-person schooling
since
March uh the neediest kids in nashwa are
being supervised at the Boys and Girls
Club but they can only accommodate so
many kids especially with the pandemic
um and the spacing issues many of our
neediest kids in Nashville are going to
lose more than a year of
instruction and kids only have one
chance at an educ education there are no
doovers as a mom I want all kids in New
Hampshire to get the best and most
suitable education they can possibly get
if they flourish at a public school that
is
fantastic however if they're struggling
academically or socially like this uh
young woman that just called in a few
minutes ago and the parents don't have
options for them education Freedom
accounts could be a Lifeline out of a
school where the child is
flailing into a school or Educational
Opportunity where the child will
flourish we all want what's best for
these kids let's give them the best
chance at a good life let's Short
Circuit the school to prison
Pipeline and put these kids on a path to
successful life please vote OTP on hb20
you hold the future of New Hampshire's
kids in your hands thank you thank you
very much Beth uh I appreciate your
testimony are there any questions for
Beth not seeing hands thank you very
much and have a good
evening okay
um maybe we could um unmute uh
representative
James
James good afternoon good afternoon
James can you hear
us
no
okay uh Neil Sanford has his hand raised
I'm sorry Neil um if you want to explain
afternoon
sure um I'm a private citizen that lives
in Dublin New Hampshire and despite the
fact that you might think Dublin's a
rich Community our family is a low
income family and so some of these
arguments that uh oh it's only for the
rich uh just really goes out the window
we home educated our five children we
spent 20 20 years my wife invested a lot
of time in them they've been very
successful very proud of them
um and I think but I also teach I teach
in a traditional classroom and so I know
there are advantages and disadvantages
to every form of education and this is
just another opportunity as commissioner
Ute said to add one more option which I
think is a huge positive for children in
our state I also see it as a huge
positive because the key to education is
a motivated student and Studies have
shown and our experience certainly shows
that the more the parents are involved
the more motivation there is our oldest
son teaches history at Manchester
Central and he's repeated how when it
comes to parents night the AP students
all of the parents show up because
they're involved and the low in the
lower classes hardly any of the parents
show up so something that involves
parents is a huge Plus for the education
of those
students I'd also like to uh point out
that there are a lot
of uh families in this state unlike our
family we're lowincome but we had the
opportunities for my wife to work
full-time our my schedule was such that
we could do a lot that other families
couldn't do she didn't have to work
outside the home and so we would like to
see uh families across the state have
the
opportunity to be more involved and to
have other choices in their children's
education so thank you very much Neil
your time is up unfortunately so uh but
we appreciate your
testimony so please approve this bill as
the first
step thank you any questions for Neil
Sanford not seeing it thank you very
much okay next we have uh Cindy Walter
Cindy I'm gonna unmute you if you'd like
to talk let's
see go ahead
please on mute great um yes
hello I'm speaking from 35 years of
experience teaching teachers and working
collaboratively with teachers from
public and private parochial schools um
I am very touched by all the stories of
um children and parents with um special
needs mental health issues and the
import I realize very much the
importance of Parental involvement like
we just heard however nothing in this
bill addresses those
problems in fact it exacerbates them and
as a researcher who's worked with these
and many other more highly qualified
educational researchers um I just took a
quick look at the research literature
and it's very clear from many cities
across the United States several States
significant Studies have been done on
children in voucher systems who have
declined under the voucher systems um a
previous speaker voted talked a little
bit about some some educational research
by University people and all he said was
that the public school kids don't get
harmed well no I'm saying the voucher
kids get harmed parents are not the best
judge all in all cases of whether a kid
is succeeding or meeting all adequate
education
needs I'm I know this I'm a teacher and
I don't know everything my kids are
learning in school so it's very hard for
parents to judge what's really best we
have to improve our Public Schools
especially for those special cases that
I just cited it's a serious and sad
situation but this bill does not address
that please let this bill go put it into
that that category of re redu um serious
redu and instead spend your time
addressing those needs which you heard
plaintively in all those cases which
were for this bill rewrite those cases
and turn them into new bills that
address those situations thank
you thank you very much Cynthia are
there any questions for Cynthia
Walter not seeing any hands thank you
very
[Music]
much I unmuted myself uh next we
have Jodi
lelot Jody are you available to speak
yes I am thank you so much for this
opportunity thank you for the time I
will be brief I did email some comments
um so I'm Jody lelot I am speaking to
you today representing myself um I am a
mom I'm a mental health Advocate and
educator um I'm also an ases uh
certified master trainer and again I'm
speaking for myself with no agenda I
just want to quickly touch on Aces and
those are adverse childhood experiences
we know through the study that was
conducted in the 90s that over 80% of
our most common problems um are
attributable to high a scores and we
know that high a scores are a common
indicator for poverty and homelessness
and that about 78% of drug addiction and
misuse is stemming from Aces we know
that Ace scores High Ace scores are not
a determinant um or they're not a a a
prescription for failure but that they
increase the risk of people struggling
and then moving into poverty and having
issues and we know that protective
factors and positive childhood
experiences can counteract the effects
of ases ases do modify the brain trauma
modifies the brain but positive adult
experiences protective factors can help
to modify this our Public Schools serve
as the first line of defense against
Aces and in helping identify children
who are facing adversity in the home
whether it be abuse neglect or other
factors um and then also helping to
compensate and those positive role
models can have a huge impact on those
children being successful I don't
believe that hb20 as it stands now is
setting children up for the opportunity
to be able to take advantage of these
vouchers and that we're going to be
creating a further Gap in education for
these children um and not being able to
help them overcome the adversity that
they're seeing if we reduce Aces we're
going to be reducing our homelessness
problem our drug addiction problem and
many other health and social problems
and so I believe that we should be
focusing on how we can create
educational changes that are going to
help to reduce Aces to overall boost our
um educational system and our the health
and well-being of our community
and our citizens so I'm imploring you to
please um to not vote for hb20 as it
stands right now we do need a change
absolutely and we do need to support
individuals who um their children don't
do in public school um but I don't
believe that defunding our Public
Schools is the option these schools
struggle to fund as well and some of the
problems we've heard today about
programs not being successful or even
schools remaining virtual are directly
related to the fact that these schools
lack adequate funding to provide for
their students as it is and we have home
owners and property owners who struggle
to pay their taxes and so an increase in
taxes is not going to help as well so
I'll end my comments there because this
has been a very long meeting and I know
more people want to speak but if you
have any questions about Aces um I am
happy to answer them um by any means
thank you very much Jody any questions
from the
committee thank you very much and have a
good afternoon thank you you as well
you're
welcome okay next we're going to uh
unmute Sonia Prince Sonia I know you've
been here all day thank you for waiting
Good
Start thank you hello can you hear me
yeah thank you so much for having me I'm
Sonia Prince from nashille New Hampshire
I have three kids uh two kids in college
and one kid in high school they all went
to Public Schools super successful we're
very fortunate um you know there's been
ups and downs but as a school teacher I
can tell you that um it doesn't matter
what school you go to if there's bul or
social issues it can happen anywhere I
have an African-American son who's now
21 and it didn't matter if we were on
vacation in public at a school um he got
bullied it is what it is it doesn't
matter if I put him in a private school
or or a public school he would have got
bullied wherever he went it is what it
is um there are social issues that
happen but we dealt with them we you
know took care of the problem and moved
on and my kid is very resilient and um
um he spoke at graduation so he's doing
really well at Satan Hall University
also um I am kind of upset I feel like
this is like a a gold card package tax
grab um to give to public to to give to
private institutions to make money I
mean that 10% bothered me for whoever
the scholarship organization takes care
of so they get paid um also I didn't
like that there's no accountability on
the spending so that money can go
anywhere um and again teachers at
private schools or public schools they
all have teaching degrees you may get
better teaching teaching at a high
school than you will at a private school
you just never know so I don't feel like
that's a comparison that they're going
to get better service wherever they go
because it's a private versus public um
I am disappointed for instance in nashwa
years ago when we had mayor loo um they
cut our our gifted program and our after
school program the same year they opened
two charter schools so that was very
disturbing to me because that attracted
all our top students to go there and
then it lowered the test scores for our
Public Schools so it made it appear like
our Public Schools weren't doing so well
and the charter schools were doing great
so I feel like the money is being pushed
around just to get into private hands
and not being accountable it's just
another way to help um people not pay
for private school thank you
thank you very much Sonia for your your
presentation uh are there any questions
for Sonia from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much Sonia and have a good evening
welcome thank you Sonia next we have uh
Victoria Sullivan The
Honorable uh previous uh representative
sorry go ahead Victoria that's okay it's
been a very long day
for good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee as stated I'm
Victoria Sullivan I'm a former state
representative I had the honor of
serving on this committee representing
the city of Manchester there's been a
lot of discussion in this hearing about
discrimination to that point T
Willard fair is President and chief
executive officer of the Urban League of
Greater Miami he is a civil rights
leader who advocates for school choice
he wrote a column for USA Today which
reads in part we know that far too many
black children are sitting in classrooms
where they are not learning we know
their schools have fewer resources we
know expectations for these children are
set lower than the expectations for
students in more affluent Suburban
schools he goes on to say once we were
told where we could live and work play
and pray eat and gather I find it no
more acceptable that today we are told
where our children can go to school if
we are going to have a sincere
discussion about equity and education it
begins with education Freedom education
opportunity is so much more than a k
through 12 education receiving the right
education opens the doors to opportunity
for all children across all walks of
life education Choice can lift children
out of poverty and set them on the path
for Success that would otherwise be out
of reach as I stated I live in
Manchester which is very diverse
Community some of our state
representatives have taken to social
media to discuss this bill they have
boasted about their own private
education and have taken and have had
the audacity to state that only children
that come from families that can afford
a private education should have that
privilege these same people are offended
by the fact that parents would choose a
school other than a traditional public
school and deny that District the state
adequacy funds attributed to that child
however they ignore the fact that their
own families made the same choice they
believe our poorer Families Our Refugee
families and our most vulnerable
students should not have the same
opportunities that they themselves have
had I could not disagree more in fact it
is those children who deserve a hand up
all children deserve the opportunity to
pursue the right education for them if a
child is being challenged and is
supported in their Traditional School
that's wonderful many families benefit
from our traditional public schools and
will continue to do so but some children
do better in less traditional settings
like charter schools montau schools
private schools or homeschools school
choice is about each family finding the
right fit where their children will grow
to be the person God intended them to be
Victoria we're time's
up am I up yep it's up okay all right I
just want to thank you all and I hope
that you vote ought to pass on this very
important piece of legislation thank you
so much and have a great evening you too
it's good to see you right bye bye thank
you Victoria do we have time for more
we're gonna go
a little bit of time left here okay uh
let's see Lisa wit or white are you
available to
speak I am thank you can you hear me
okay thank you for
coming and thank you for this
opportunity uh I'm here uh I'm opposed
to House Bill 20 I did submit written
testimony I won't read that for you I'll
be brief I just have a couple of points
um I agree with representative miler
House Bill 20 describes a voucher
program plain and simple um I also Echo
Mary Heath's representative uh Mary
Heath's concerns regarding the fiscal
note that was provided and I'll give you
a quick example um say you have 20
students uh that take advantage of a
voucher um or you know the esa as it's
called here that's about uh comes out to
just right around
$100,000 um but those 20 students just
because there's 20 students that doesn't
mean that there's a reduction in staff
it's you know the argument has been made
for example under when we were talking
about SP sp13 that 20 students is a
classroom so you should be able to
reduce a teacher but that's not the case
um I'm the superintendent of schools in
the madn Regional School District and
it's entirely possible that 20 students
could represent two students from one
grade two from another two from another
and there would not be a correlating
reduction in staff um I don't understand
the math uh that was presented in the
fiscal note that on average across the
state we St we spend 20,000 per student
we subtract out the
4,603 noted in the fiscal note per
student that would go to the esa and
that results in a $15,000 savings for
taxpayers if we're not reducing
employees we're not reducing bus runs um
I'm not sure how we add that up to a
$15,000 savings to taxpayers um I'd have
to go back and take another look I first
blush that doesn't make a lot of sense
to me I do want to comment also on
students with disabilities and
discrimination um private schools do not
have to follow anti-discrimination laws
or the individuals with disabilities
Education Act other speakers have have
indicated some schools do and perhaps
many do but the fact remains they don't
have to and they can pick and choose who
they choose to accept and there's
nothing you're out of time Lisa I okay
yeah thank you for your
time any questions Lisa not seeing hands
we have time for one more speaker
today okay our representative Spain uh
is anxious to get on he texted me and is
back so can we let him speak yes we can
okay go ahead Representatives
Blain thank you so much for my ability
to speak today I think the the chair and
the
committee um I am one of those people
who lived through this we have going
been going through this in New Hampshire
since uh 1980 at
least my
parents had to go into debt to put me in
a private
school because there was no facility to
take and put me into a different school
from the school that I was in and I will
tell you straight out um I was headed on
a wrong
path I was headed into a a a path of
degeneracy and
whatnot on the public school end of
things when I got into private school
because my parents were able to pay for
it that I was uh totally turned
around
and I think that uh you need to you need
to look at the fact that any argument
that this is defunding the public
schools is absolutely ridiculous what
we're doing is taking students who are
no longer in those public schools and
putting their money forward so they have
no more interest in those students those
students now are in a different school
why should they continue getting funding
for the students that are no longer
attending their
school I have been fighting this fight
since I was in high
school
and I have persevered only because my
parents were willing to go into debt to
put me through private school on their
own and this is a a problem with New
Hampshire that has been
longstanding since the
80s where we
have not
allowed for students who do not fit a
particular
curriculum to go to a different School
in my case it was because I was Advanced
from the current curriculum and they
said the only option they had was to put
me in the regress curriculum of the
special needs students in order to give
me special
one-on-one attention James we're not at
the end of your time other than that
they told me sit in the back of the
classroom and read books and don't do
anything and I will tell you straight
out we need to allow students to find
the ability to get the best education
that those students need
not everyone fits the same model and we
need to give people the ability to find
their model that fits their
education and give them the best ability
to to grow within their education
ability and we need to do that and this
bill allows us to do that thank you very
much for your testimony James appreciate
it are there any questions from the
committee for representative
Spain no question thank you very much
and have a great evening thank you
you're
welcome well for the committee that's uh
the end of the testimony for today uh we
will be back uh Tuesday at nine o'clock
in the morning not for this but uh for
uh bills which we will put in the
calendar those bills have not yet been
selected uh that will have to be done uh
prior to Wednesday noon uh by myself and
uh so we will convey this this
particular meeting today will be
recessed this
hb20 uh hearing is going to be recessed
until Thursday morning of next week
that's the 11th of February at nine
o'clock in the morning and we will
continue with the same rules we have in
place right
now okay folks Rick quick quick question
yeah what what are we looking at right
now as far as blue sheets and the pink
car in the pink SL in the you know Dave
I really don't have a hot
clue I'm saying that honestly uh de Deb
uh Hobson can give us that information
or even Jennifer four but uh we have a a
whole slug of people to come and uh the
the conversation I had with Paul Smith
was Rick you know you just you know
recess it conv in on another day and go
for it then no I think that's that's a
good plan but I think it is yeah so so
far so
far many of these people have already
submitted um written testimony because
I've been going through the list and
almost every single person that spoke
has already submitted written testimony
I think if they that they should all be
told to just either submit r written
testimony or a sign up to speak one or
the other I don't see why that's a
problem well you know the state of New
Hampshire believes in having a House of
Representatives allows everybody the
opportunity to come forward and say
they're two cents worth um and we always
ask if they have written testimony to
leave that at your doorstep there
Barbara so um you know I think that I
know it's our tradition though and we
can't give up on what New Hampshire
is what wasb what was Deb going to say I
was just going to tell you um I I'm not
sure what time this
report was given to us it was given to
us in the afternoon at some point but we
had um supporting 600 opposing
3,198 neutral 5 total testifying uh
131 can I also say that it's been very
difficult to look at the the hands that
are raised to speak from the attendee
list and find them on maybe this list
get text
messages um this list that I have of
speakers is not alphabetical so um I
appreciate your patience today um so
you've done a great job and you've done
you've done a good job could you give us
those numbers again
please yeah um support 600 oose
3198 neutral
five and total testifying 131 do we have
a count for the number that testified
today you would I'm sorry I don't I
would have to get back to you 30
sorry I have 30 God bless you Barbara
representative
Shaw I just I just say that I think that
debor you done a terrific job Rick you
you've done a good job in trying to
manage this thing this is not an easy
process we're into and we just have gota
you've got to be
patient thank you very much
representative lad can I ask for on the
11th if we finished would you plan on
executing bills because my vaccine
appointment is for
5:00 and I wouldn't want to miss that
but if you're going to exact bills I'll
have them get a sub for me because I'm
going for my vaccine let me get back to
that on Patricia I I I honestly don't
know at this point in time okay I gotta
do a little of this modern math with
these bills and find out if we go two
minutes a piece how many minutes are we
gonna need as long as I know in time to
get a sub if I have to yes I I will
definitely communicate that and uh
Patricia I'll work directly with uh Mel
my or your ranking rep and he can
disseminate that information amongst you
allk thank you Rick yeah Mr chairman yes
this is Jim um to clear up confusion in
my brain at this point last week I
believe you said to us that we would be
meeting Tuesdays and Thursdays for the
foreseeable uh but now we're talking
about next Tuesday and next Thursday say
are we not meeting two days hence no
we're meeting this thur let me tell you
what's going on here um the of course we
have to get those early bills out and
report them on the
18th at the latest at the latest um so
we had for these last this last week and
or this week and the next week we have
Tuesdays and Thursdays for the week of
the let's see that'll be the week of the
16th I believe or the 15 16 17 the
15th um we will get two days in that
week um we're going to have to have them
in fact when I spoke with the chief of
staff this afternoon they said yes this
education committee because we have a
whole slug of bills we we need that time
so I don't know the specific days
whether it's the 16th 17th or 15th 16th
17th or 18th um we will probably have
the the the 16th which is
the well I'm not going to say which of
the two but we're going to have two days
that last week so that means we're going
to have to set up a day in which we do
the
exact um and there if we have some time
at the end we'll try to exact bills that
um we don't have a mending language for
or we that we feel we can get through uh
without you know having to get into the
great debate and and you know
understanding that the folks don't
always see it the same way yes but um
when we get to issues like hb20 or maybe
like or Thursday we're going to be
talking about school building Aid Dave
and we have two bills there one
bill is exactly the same as the second
bill but the second bill goes farther
with looking at that that the formula
and the payment period and all that so
that will be some discussion there but
at the end we might be able to come up
with you know a solution of either
amending or or getting those things
through that's not going to be as hotly
debated I don't think as what we've been
just going through today so TimeWise I
hope to use our time efficiently get
some EXA sessions in the way we'll get
some of them done perhaps if we have
like a whole of a half hour 4 5 minutes
along the way between bills if we have
that um but looking at our history we
had so far this this this session we
have not had a lot of
holes so it looks like it's going to be
days just set up for exec
alone and and we'll try and get all the
amendments to people prior to the exact
sessions and that's why I asked the
question earlier today is legislative
Services sending them out as well to
committee members as as to the research
people upstairs where they used to run
them off for us and we picked them
up Glenn you had your hand up yes I just
wanted um to follow up with
representative allard's comment and um
uh correct me if I'm wrong but we are
meeting on Thursday as scheduled in the
calendar yes we are yes we
are okay folks that's it and I'll be in
touch with now we have one more comment
representative a clarification yes
on Thursday the 11th are you allowing
new testimony or only those that are
already on your listing today oh it's
only those which have you know
identified as of today uh we we don't
want to go in no I just didn't know I
didn't know what the process was I think
you concur right I'm just asking you
know you know Rick I'm not I'm not sure
um I I think last year the clerk gave us
advice to the contrary yeah
know yeah that's correct yeah we un I
hate to say this but my understanding
you might want to check with with Paul
uh Rick but when I checked with him he
said no if you if you have a public
meeting you've got to allow other people
in and um to
testify I'm not that I want to be a suer
of more time but I think just check with
Paul and he'll see what he says would be
any different than today people checking
in later on the day you would the
meeting so they're still checking in
yeah yeah I got it I got it okay I'll
talk with Paul thank you any other
comments maybe there's a good basketball
game on
tonight um Mr chair I actually wanted to
mention the State offices are closed on
the 15th for president for President's
Day so that shortens our time even more
days in that week it be 16th and the
18th but uh we'll see all right perfect
thank you thanks everyone yeah thank you
very much and have a great evening all